IN RESPONSE THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY IN CHECK PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERS IN HERE
SOCIAL DISTANCING FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS IN OUR
PRICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
THE PUBLIC CONDUCIVE AXES THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE WILL ADMIT
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT
SOCIAL DISSING REQUIREMENTS.
JUSTICE FOR REMOTELY DAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE ONE
ONE FOUR ZERO. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WE
MOVED PUBLIC COMING YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY THE MODERATOR DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME
AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER WHICH MAY TAKE A MOMENT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU AWAITING TWO FOR
MODERATE TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE ON
MUTE AND YOU'LL BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND AVOID ACOUSTIC FLEET
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING OR
LISTENING ON- PRIOR TO GIVING TO
US OVER THE PHONE ISN'T WE HEAR
FROM YOU WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
BASE PATIENTS. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTED MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE HEARINGS REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS. WE ARE PRESENTATION
OF BILLS LET'S. QUORUM CHIEF
COUNSEL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FOR PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM. UMBERG HERE. AMBERG HERE
FOR. GORGEOUS PRESENT COVEY
IT'LL- BE RUSSELL. THE RUSSELL
HERE GONZALEZ. HERTZBERG HERE
HERTZBERG HERE JONES. LAYERED
HERE LAYERED HERE STERN. WHITE
HOUSE SKI HERE WHY CASKEY HERE
WINNER. YOU HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED THANK YOU BELGAE
COUNCIL A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED BEFORE WE VOTE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR OF A FEW
ANNOUNCEMENTS MAKE WE WILL BE
GOING OUT OF FILE ORDER AND
HEARING PHYLUM NUMBER TWELVE S.
B. ONE THREE TWO SEVEN BY SEVEN
HERTZBERG FIRST LET ME REPEAT
THAT FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
WAITING ON THE PHONE- WE ARE WE
GOING OUT OF ORDER NUMBER TWELVE
WILL BE GOING FIRST THAT'S SB
ONE THREE TWO SEVEN BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG. AFTER THAT WE'LL BE
BACK IN FILE ITEM ORDER STARTING
WITH NUMBER TWO S. B. ONE ONE
EIGHT FOUR BY SENATOR CORTESE I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT
FILE I'M NUMBER THREE BY CENTER
EGGMAN FILE OR NUMBER TEN BY
CENTER SKINNER HAVE BEEN PULLED
FROM TODAY'S COUNT. HEARING WILL
BE DEFERRED BOB WILL HEAR THOSE
BILLS ON APRIL NINETEENTH
ADDITIONALLY FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN SB ONE ZERO NINE NINE
HAS BEEN PULLED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR LAST MINUTE OPPOSITION
AND WILL BE PRESENTED BY SENATOR
WHAT KOWSKI WE HAVE FIVE ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY
THE ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ARE AS FOLLOWS FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE AS CHAIR 14%
AROUND FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB. ONE ONE SEVEN NINE BY SENATOR
GLAZERS. FIVE SB ONE ZERO EIGHT
FOUR BY CENTER TITLE WITH
AMENDMENTS. FILE NUMBER SIX SB
ONE ZERO NINE ZERO BY CENTER
TATO AND FILING NUMBER ELEVEN SB
ONE THREE ZERO ZERO. BY SENATOR
RUSSELL WITH AMENDMENTS. WITH
THE CONSENT OF SENATOR LAYERED
MOVES THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THANK YOU MADAM MEMSIC. COUNTY
COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AT
THIS IS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
UMBERG HI AMBERG BY BURGESS
FORGES I CABALLERO. DRESSEL I'M
SERIOUS THE ICONS. HER HI
HERTZBERG BY JONES. LAYERED
LAYERED I STERN WHITE HOUSE GARY
BY CASKEY AYE WIENER. SO FAR YOU
HAVE SIX TWO ZERO WITH SOME
MEMBERS MISSING ALREADY WILL PUT
THAT ON CALL. NOW SO HERTZBERG
WHO'S BEEN WAITING PATIENTLY
CENTER HERTZBERG YOU MAY PRESENT
SB ONE THREE TWO SEVEN FLOORS
YOURS THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. SPILLS ABOUT THE-
HORRIBLE EPIDEMIC OF GUN
VIOLENCE. TODAY'S EDITORIAL TOP
EDITORIAL THE LOS ANGELES TIME
REACH. THE NATION'S SECOND TOLL
OF GUN LINE GUN VIOLENCE WHICH
MADE CLEAR AGAIN HERE THIS
WEEKEND. ON THE SAME DAY THE
EDITORIAL SAYS THE SAME THIS IS%
REFERRED SHOOTING AT LEAST
NINETY FIVE OTHER SHOOTINGS TOOK
PLACE ACROSS THE NATION. I SAY
THAT AGAIN IT WAS A THING NINETY
FIVE SHOOTINGS ON THE SAME DAY
IN APRIL CLAIMING THIRTY SIX
MORE LIVES AND INJURING NINETY
FIVE MORE PEOPLE. JUST ON THIS
ONE SUNDAY IN APRIL. GUN
VIOLENCE HAS EXPLODED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES OF THE LAST YEARS
FEW YEARS MUCH OF INCREASED
VIOLENCE COME FROM THE USE OF
ILLEGAL WEAPONS. THE SO CALLED
GHOST GUNS AND ASSAULT WEAPONS
AREN'T TO BLAMEIN LARGE BETS
AND WHAT'S A GHOST KIND OF GOES
GOING TO SOME DEGREE BY THREE D.
PRINTED OFF THE INTERNET OR IT'S
LITERALLY. IN A WEAPON THAT'S
REQUIRED TO HAVE NUMBER AND
FILING THE SERIAL NUMBER OFF OF
THE WEAPON WHAT IS THE PURPOSE
OF FILING A SERIAL NUMBER OFF OF
YOUR WEAPON IF YOU'RE GONNA GO
DEER HUNTING OR IF YOU NEED YOUR
HOME TO PROTECT YOURSELF FOR TO
PROTECT YOUR BUSINESS. THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT WHERE
I LIVE RECENTLY DECLARED GHOST
GUNS EPIDEMIC THEY SAID AS OF
OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND ONE THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE COMMISSION
REPORTED REPORTEDLY FOUND THAT
THE NUMBER OF GHOST GUNS
CONFISCATED BY THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT. JUMPED BY
FOUR HUNDRED. TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. DISTRICT ELEVEN CIVIC
CENTER ONE. THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE TO. SAUDI EVAN LOW RIDE.
COMPARED TO THE PE YEARS. UP
SEVEN ONE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY GHOST GUNS
CONFISCATED COMPARED ONLY EITHER
THIRTEEN TAKEN IN TWENTY TWENTY
OAKLAND TWENTY THREE PERCENT. OF
THE OF THE TWELVE HUNDRED
FIREARMS SEIZED GHOST GUNS LAST
YEAR SAN FRANCISCO SHE'S A
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR GHOST GUNS.
COUNTY 420% OF ALL THE GUNS
SEIZED IN SAN FRANCISCO ALL
ACROSS THE STATE. TO THAT
QUESTION. CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
NATION IN ACTING ROBUST GUN
LAWS. I DIDN'T COUNT THE NUMBERS
FOR THE LOS ANGELES TIMES
REPORTED THIS MORNING THAT THE
HUNDRED SEVEN LOSS IN CALIFORNIA
WE PASSED. AND WE'RE STILL
SEEING. THIS UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL
OF GUN VIOLENCE GOVERNOR NEWSOM.
MEMBERS HIS FIERCE LEADER IN
COMMONSENSE GUN REFORM THAT HE
SIGNED IN MULTIPLE NUMBER OF
THESE GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION
MEASURES INTO LAW THAT I JUST
REFERRED TO. YET THE TRAGIC
EVENTS. DISTURBING NUMBERS OF
REPORTING OUT OF OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENTS DEMONSTRATE THAT
THERE'S STILL MUCH TO BE DONE
AND WE NEED TO BE CREATIVE.
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF GOVERNOR
NEWSOM HIS ADMINISTRATION THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL DOES. S.
B. THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
PROVIDES A SET OF NEW TOOLS
INCENTIVES IF YOU WILL TO GET
THESE DANGEROUS WEAPONS OFF THE
STREET A PRIVATE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM. THINK ABOUT IT A
MINUTE IT'S A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION WHAT DOES THAT MEAN WHAT
IT MEANS IS THAT AN ORDINARY
PERSON IN THE COMMUNITY CAN
BRING A LAWSUIT AND COLLECT UP
TO TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PLUS
ATTORNEY'S FEES OF SOMEONE
MANUFACTURES WORK TRANSPORTS.
ARE ANY ANY WEAPONS. ST LOUIS
TRANCE. IN POOR SOMEBODY'S TO
OUT OF STATE BRINGS IN A BUNCH
OF. THEY CAN BRING AN ACTION TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER. NOW THE
BOTTOM LINE AND THE QUESTION IS
WILL IT WORK I DON'T KNOW. BUT
IF IT SAVES ONE COAST GUARD IF
IT SAVES ONE ASSAULT WEAPON THAT
CAN BE USED IN A CRIME WITH THE
NUMBERS WE SEEN. HIM PULL THE
NEW WHICH YOU. IF WHEN SOMEBODY
DOES THIS AND BRINGS DEPRESSED
GONNA RIP AND GOING TO BE A
STORY AND I'M HOPING THAT IT HAS
A CHILLING EFFECT ON OTHERS WHO
THINK THAT THEY'RE GOING TO USE
THESE WEAPONS IN CRIMES WHICH WE
SEEN CLICK RATE AT EXTRAORDINARY
LEVEL SO THIS BILL HARNESSES THE
POWER OF COMMUNITY A MEASURE OF
DETERRENCE WE DO THIS IN MANY
OTHER WAYS WE DO IT THE SIMPLE
FORM OF PUTTING SOMEONE'S
PICTURE UP IN THE POST OFFICE.
POSTED EIGHT HUNDRED. SACRAMENTO
POLICE DEPARTMENT TALKED ABOUT
COMMUNITY EVIDENCE OVER A
HUNDRED PEOPLE COMMITTEE HAD
VIDEOS COMMUNITY EVIDENCE
COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF WHAT WE DO
AS ANOTHER TOOL TO TRY TO COMBAT
THIS EXTRAORDINARY GUN VIOLENCE
OWNERS SAY THAT A PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION WHICH I HAVE NOT
ALWAYS SUPPORT IN OTHER
INSTANCES IT'S NOT NEW IN
CALIFORNIA YAHOO CIVIL RIGHTS
ACT CIVIL CODE SECTION FIFTY ONE
OF THE- CODES ALLOWS IT AGREE
PERSON TO PURSUE PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION FOR ACCOMMODATION SAME
THING WITH RESPECT AMERICANS
WITH DISABILITY ACT THERE'S A
WHOLE HOST OF ISSUES AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION ALIVE. IT
PROVIDES THIS TO REMEDY IT
DITION TO THE OTHER REMEDIES
THAT WE DO IN THE LAW NOW.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE TEXAS
STATE LEGISLATURE. DEBASE
PRIVATE AND FOR SKI AND THAT IN
THE- BUT AGREE. ABORTION IN WHAT
WAS KNOWN THEN AS S. B. EIGHT
WHICH ALLOWS ALMOST ANYONE
ANYONE TO PURCHASE TO PROVIDERS
WHO AIDS AND ABETS A PERSON
OBTAINING. AN ABORTION. IF TEXAS
CAN USE THIS MECHANISM TO TAKE
AWAY A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE
AN ENDANGER LIVES CALIFORNIA
COULD USE THE SAME MECHANISM TO.
ANYTHING CREATIVE TO BAN DEADLY
WEAPONS OF WAR AND SAVE LIVES-
THE SUPREME COURT DISALLOWED SP
EIGHT TO REMAIN IN PLACE SO WHAT
DID WE DO WE SAT DOWN AND WE
LOOKED AT THE COURT AND WHAT THE
SUPREME COURT SAYS
UNFORTUNATELY. IN THIS COUNTRY
THE COST SAYS WITH TO PRINT
COURTS AS IT IS AND SO WHAT WE
DID IS WE CRAFTED THIS LAW VERY
CAREFULLY. WITH RESPECT TO THE
GUIDANCE THAT WAS GIVEN OUT OF
S. B. EIGHT WE'VE PUT SOME OTHER
PROTECTIONS IN THAT I WILL
ADDRESS IN RESPONSE TO SOME
QUESTIONS WITH RESPECT TO THE
ISSUE OF KNOWING. FIRST IS JUST
. DID WELL TO PRECOURT.
RECOGNIZE IT IF IT. USUAL RIGHT
TO BEAR ARMS IT CERTAINLY DOES
NOT. OCCUR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
TO OWN MANUFACTURERS SELL
ILLEGAL ASSAULT WEAPONS WERE
GHOST GUN IT'S NOT THERE'S NO
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
MANUFACTURE AN ILLEGAL WEAPON.
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO TELL PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO PROTECT THEIR HOMES
TO PROTECT THEIR BUSINESSES OR
GO HUNTING OR WHATEVER THERE'S
NOTHING TO DO WITH THEM. THIS
LAW ONLY APPLIES TO VS FIFTY
CALIBER MACHINE GUN IF YOU GOT
AN ASSAULT WEAPON THAT REVERDY
IN ROOST PUT OUT AND DATE AND
PRADA DID IN EIGHTY NINE AND
NINETY NINE. THOSE HAVE BEEN
DECLARED ILLEGAL THE SUPREME
COURT THE COURT OF APPEALS
UPHELD THAT AND SO WE'RE SAYING
IF IT'S ILLEGAL ORDINAL FOR DISH
NEW MECHANISM THIS NEW DEVICE.
IN ORDER TO I TRY ANYTHING WE
POSSIBLY CAN CREATIVE AND
IMAGINATIVE USER. ALL AVAILABLE
TO TRY TO REDUCE THIS
EXTRAORDINARY IN HORRIBLE
EPIDEMIC OF GUN VIOLENCE SO IT
MAY NOT BE THE PERFECT SOLUTION
MEMBERS BUT IT DOES I SUGGEST
OFFER A CREATIVE TOOL THAT'S
NEVER BEEN USED OR TESTED
BEFORE. SO WITH THAT I WANT TO
TURN THIS OVER TO MY WITNESS A
CRYSTAL- LOW PALATO OF THE MOMS
DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN SENSE
WHO'S GOING TO TESTIFY IN FAVOR
OF THIS MEASURE MISTER CHAIRED
MEMBERS THANK YOU BOB MISS LOCK
OUT THE ONE ONE SECOND HERE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY-
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS- REGARDING
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS I'VE INSTITUTED TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE
WILL BE PERMITTED TO WITNESSES
WILL BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR TWO
MINUTES EACH. ALL OF THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME.
THEIR AFFILIATION AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE MEASURE- SO LET
ME REPEAT THAT TWO MINUTES. PER
WITNESS TO WITNESSES EACH SIDE.
AND THOSE WHO ARE CALLING IN TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT THEIR NAME
THEIR AFFILIATION IN THEIR
POSITION SO- WITH THAT MISS OUT.
LOPILATO THE CLASSIC CORRECT AND
YOU DID EIGHT GO AHEAD OF ME.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS CRYSTAL LOPILATO I'M A MOM
LIVING IN THE BAY AREA AND I'M A
VOLUNTEER LEADER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF MOMS
DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN SENSE. IN
THAT ROLE I CONNECT WITH PARENTS
AND PEOPLE ALL AROUND THE STATE
WHO WANT TO SEE CALIFORNIA LEAD
THE WAY ON GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION. SACRAMENTO MORIN'S
ONE OF THE DEADLIEST SHOOTINGS
IN THE U. S. THIS YEAR. I FIRST
WANT TO EXPRESS MY SOLIDARITY
AND SUPPORT FOR THE COMMUNITY
AND EVERYONE HERE THAT WAS
IMPACTED. I STARTED VOLUNTEERING
WITH MOMS DEMAND ATION BECAUSE
I WAS SICK OF FEELING HELPLESS.
EVERY TIME I SAW NEWS OF A
SCHOOL SHOOTING OR MASS
SHOOTING. AND EVERY TIME I
TALKED TO GRIEVING FAMILIES
WHOSE LOVED ONES HAVE BEEN TAKEN
BY GUN VIOLENCE. I KNOW YOU'VE
ALL SEEN OR EXPERIENCED THE
IMPACT OF GUN VIOLENCE IN YOUR
DISTRICTS OR RIGHT HERE WHERE
YOU WORK. AND FELT THAT SINKING
FEELING OF WHAT CAN WE POSSIBLY
DO TO STOP THIS. AND THE ANSWER
IS WE HAVE TO USE EVERY TOOL WE
CAN TO END GUN VIOLENCE IN OUR
STATE. SB THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
BRINGS US A NEW TOOL IN THIS
FIGHT. THE ABILITY OF
INDIVIDUALS TO BRING CIVIL
LAWSUITS TO RID OUR COMMUNITIES
OF LEGAL ASSAULT WEAPONS AND
GHOST GUNS. UNBOUNCE IS ON THE
RISE IN CITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND THE RIPPLE EFECTIVIDAD. HIDE
AS WE WATCHED FAMILIES BEING
TORN APART BY GRIEF AND FEAR. WE
CAN'T SIT BACK AND HOPE THAT THE
PEOPLE BRINGING THESE WEAPONS OF
WAR INTO OUR STATE WILL
CERTAINLY CHOOSE TO STOP. THIS
BILL OPENS UP ANOTHER LANE TO
PROACTIVELY ENFORCE PROHIBITIONS
ON A LEGAL ASSAULT WEAPONS AND
GHOST GUNS BEFORE THEY CAUSE
INJURY DEATH OR TRAUMA IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. CALIFORNIA LAW
ALREADY MAKES IT A FELONY TO
MANUFACTURE DISTRIBUTE OR IMPORT
ASSAULT WEAPONS WE ALSO ALREADY
HAVE A LAW REGULATING THE SALE
OF FIREARM PRECURSOR PARTS GO
INTO EFFECT IN JULY. BUT EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE THE STRONG LAWS
WE NEED BOLDER ACTION TO TRULY
AND THE PROLIFERATION OF THOSE
WEAPONS. THIS BILL GIVES US
ANOTHER WAY TO BE SURE
INDIVIDUALS AND COMPANIES WHO
CONTINUE TO DEFY OUR LAWS BY
BRINGING THESE WEAPONS INTO OUR
STATE ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE. WE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS LOPEZ A LOT OF
ALL RIGHT- OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED I DON'T SEE
ANYONE ELSE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE- ALL RIGHT. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE ON
THE- BEST OF IN SUPPORT. S. ONE
THREE TWO SEVEN- SO THEY PROVIDE
THEIR NAME THEIR AFFILIATION AND
THEIR POSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. ONE THREE TWO SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. FOR REVIVED THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY THAT'S- WHY ONE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN GARBAGE.
OF THE LOG GROUP TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
ON BEHALF OF THE AMOUNT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANKS PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M SIXTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JOHN OF
AND GO WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE THREE TWO
SEVEN THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FORTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I WAS
ACTUALLY CALLING IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT IF YOU GIVE YOUR
POSITION AND YOUR NAME IS
AFFILIATION THEN YOU NEED A CALL
BACK IN. OKAY AT NICOLE YOUNG.
LEGAL GUN OWNER IN CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NEXT IN
SUPPORT YOU'RE RIGHT THANK YOU
I'M SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TO BE AN ATTACKER WITH
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M AT EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
. YEAH. ONE EIGHT INTEREST. THIS
IS ONE DIRECT FLIGHTS ARE COUNTY
I AM OPPOSE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU-
LET'S NOW TURN TO THE OPPOSITION
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS- BUT
WE DO HAVE ANY IDENTIFIED
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WHOSE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
SAYING THAT THERE ARE NONE- ARE
THERE WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED IN OPPOSITION
WISH TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
SAYING NO ONE APPROACHED THE
MICROPHONE- UP MODERATE IF YOU
WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE ON THE
PHONE OH I'M SORRY- THIS ONE
PERSON- APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU SIR. TODAY MY NAME'S WATER
HARPER I OPPOSE THIS BILL I'M A
LEGAL OWNER CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR ALL RIGHT. ANYONE
ELSE IN THE IN THE HEARING ROOM
AT. SEEING NON WESTERN TO THE
PHONES- MATTER IF YOU TO UP
THOSE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
ASK THESE THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
JIM THANK YOU IN WHICH THE
TWENTY FOR THE RECORD MY NAME IS
MICHAEL FINLEY AND THE DIRECTOR
OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS. SHOOTING
SPORTS FOUNDATION THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR AMERICA'S.
FARMING MANUFACTURERS RETAILERS
AND RANGES. ALSO I'M SPEAKING-
FOR. THE CALIFORNIA WERE RIGHT
TO SOCIALIZATION SAY AND GUNNERS
CALIFORNIA AND ENSURE PLEASE
INDULGE ME WE WERE SUPPOSED TO
BE A PRIMARY WITNESSES ON THE-
WITH THE TECHNOLOGY. WHAT HAS
YOUR GOING GO AHEAD. SIR. GO
AHEAD YEAH YOU TO MINUTES.
WONDERFUL AND WE WILL TAKE THAT
MUCH- THERE COUPLE PROBLEMATIC
THINGS WITH THIS BILL THAT WOULD
LIKE TO POINT OUT. FIRST AND
FOREMOST HIS MOTHER WALKED OUT
WHILE THE PREVIOUS- FIRST
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TODAY MENTION
PRECURSOR PARTS PUT IT FEELS
REALIZE THAT BECAUSE PARTS ARE
STILL WIDELY AVAILABLE AND THERE
ISN'T A DEFINITION QUITE YET A
PRECURSOR PARKS. BILL WOULD DO
IS IT QUINTESSENTIALLY- GIVE ME
BILLION ISSUE ANYBODY FOR.
EITHER SELLING TRANSFERRING OR
LETTING. PEOPLE BORROW ONE- A
PRE PURCHASE PURCHASE THERE
ISN'T A DEFINITION THIS COULD
MEAN ANYTHING FROM A CHARGING
HANDLE COULD MEAN ANYTHING FROM
SCREWS. ARM ON YOUR LOWER YOUR
UPPER RECEIVERS. THIS COULD BE
SPRINGS. HAS THE- TO. OPEN UP A
WHOLE HOST WALL STREET FOR SMALL
TINY PART. OTHERWISE NOT BEEN
DETERMINED IN TERMS OF THE
CLASSIFICATION YET. OTHER
PROBLEMATIC PARTS OF THIS BILL
ARE. FLIES IN THE FACE OF
FEDERAL ALL RIGHT NOW THERE'S
THE T. L C. A. IN SHORT TALK AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL AS EVERYBODY
KNOWS WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO GO
TO THE CONSTITUTIONAL LESSON
HERE SAID. BUT THIS WOULD BE IN
DIRECT CONTRADICTION OF A
FEDERAL LAW WHICH OVERSEES THIS
PARTICULAR. ISSUE AT HAND- ON
BEING AS THE CONSTITUTION LAYS
OUT- IT FEDERAL LAW WOULD IN
THIS INSTANCE SUPERSEDE THAT OF
STATE LAW CREATING A CONFUSING
SITUATION FOR. FOLKS IN
CALIFORNIA- WITH THAT- I CAN
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE- BUT THAT START
THAT'LL HERE JUST. LIKE YOU SAY
THANK YOU RT THANK YOU SIR. ALL
RIGHT UP AND I. ON THE PHONE
LINE. THANK YOU I'M FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
SAMANTHA LET AND I AM IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ILLEGAL
GUN OWNER CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU I'M TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRAD ANDERSON
CONCERNED CITIZEN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY I'M IN OPPOSITION SENATE
BILL ONE THREE THREE SEVEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU BYE
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CARLENE ELLIS I REMEMBER THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND I BELIEVE IT IS
CRIMINAL VIOLENCE NOT GUN
VIOLENCE AND I AM IN OPPOSITION
TO AB. ONE THREE TWO SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE
THREE TWO. YES THIS IS DAN READ
LET YOUR REGIONAL DIRECTOR OF
THE NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
HOSTAGES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SURE THE CIVIC MAN ON
THE CHAIR OF THE SOUTH
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU RYAN NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD
. MY NAME IS FOR CAPITAL GAIN
FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
. THANK YOU BYE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE BILLION
AND SUPPORT OPPOSITION BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT'S JUST
THAT THE BRAIN ROGERS FROM
CLASSIC AYE OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JEFF TURNER I
AM A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION
PRESIDENT OF MONTEREY COUNTY AT
DEMOCRAT I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL AND REQUEST THAT THE
COMMITTEE VOTE ACCORDINGLY THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI MY NAME IS JERRY HUME I AM
VERY PLEASED COUNTY RESIDENT.
AND I REMEMBER AND IF YOU'RE A
TEAM MEMBER AND I OPPOSE SB. ONE
THREE TWO SEVEN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I. THREE FOR CALL HAVE
. THAT'S GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS PAT I AM THE OF THE TEAM
COUNTY GOING OWNERS CHAPTER THE
CALIFORNIA RIGHT TO SOLICITATION
RETIRED SERGEANT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. BRING IT BACK NOW TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS- CENTER
THE RUSSELL THANK YOU- YOU KNOW
ALL OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU RAISE
I'M TOTALING COMPLETELY IN
AGREEMENT WITH YOU I HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT. IT SAYS HERE AND
I CAN GIVE YOU THE EXACT- PLACE
BUT IT SAYS IF YOU KNOWINGLY
pABETS A VIOLATION REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THE PERSON KNEW OR
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN. THAT THE
PERSON AIDED OR ABETTED WOULD BE
VIOLATING THE OF THE VILE THE
SECTION- I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT- IN TERMS OF. NOT KNOWING
BUT BEING HELD- RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE CONDUCT OF SOMEONE ELSE. I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT. EXTENSION
OF LIABILITY GOING BEYOND THE
PERSON WHO COMMITTED THE
VIOLATION- BEING ACCUSED OF
COMMITTING THE VIOLATION SO IF
YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT. YEAH I
THINK WE READ IT IN ITS TOTALITY
CERTAINLY ARE I WAS QUITE
SENSITIVE- IN WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON THIS AND
THEY WERE AS WELL. BUT SIR
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD SOME
CHALLENGES WITH RESPECT TO THE
APPLICATION OF THE LAW IN TEXAS
RIGHT. SO THEY DON'T HAVE A
KNOWING STANDARD AND TO ME WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THIS IT SAYS
UNDERTAKEN SPACE. YOU'RE READING
FROM LOT B. ONE FORTY IT SAYS
ANY PERSON. MAY BRING A CIVIL
ACTION WHO DOES THE FOLLOWING
ONE KNOWINGLY VIOLATES THIS
SECTION TWO IF YOU COULD
KNOWINGLY ENGAGES RIGHT TEXAS
DOESN'T USE THE KNOWINGLY
ENGAGES STAND I SEE IS SOMEWHAT
CONFUSING BUT THEN. KNOWINGLY
COMMITS AN ACT WITH INTENT TO
ENGAGE IN THE CONDUCT UNDER ONE
OR TWO WHICH IS ABOVE SO MY
SENSE IS THAT. WOULD WHAT WAS
OUR INTENT IS TO CREATE A
KNOWING STANDARD TO AVOID THE
SITUATION WHERE YOU HAD OVER
DRIVER SAY HAD YOU KNOW THIS IS
AGAINST WHAT TRANSPORT SO LET'S
ASSUME A TAXI DRIVER IS DRIVING
SOMEBODY LESSEN ASSAULT WEAPON
IN THEIR BACKYARD IN THE BACK OF
THE CARD THAT. GETS PULLED OVER
BY THE POLICE AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN YOU SEE THAT ASSAULT
WEAPON AND THEN THEN THAT'S THE
TAXI DRIVER GETS CHARGED BECAUSE
THEY'RE TRANSPORTING WHAT YOU WE
SET THE KNOWING STAND IN THERE
SO I GET YOUR POINT TO EXTEND
YOU SEE FURTHER CLARIFIED HAPPY
TO DO IT THAT'S THE UNDERLYING
IDEA. THE PURPOSE OF THIS WASN'T
DO WHAT HAPPENED IN TEXAS WHERE
YOU HAD A TAXI. DRIVER TOOK
SOMEBODY. WORST OF A SUDDEN
WHICH CHARGE SO WE WANT TO GO
CLEAR. WITH WHICH TO THAT IF
THERE'S ANY. BE TO WORK FOR WITH
YOU ON OVER THAT'S THAT'S THE
UNDERLYING REASON WHY WE PUT
KNOWINGLY WHICH IS NOT IN SB
EIGHT. THANK YOU ONE MORE
QUESTION CORSET FOR THE AUTHOR-
THERE IS LANGUAGE IN THEIR NICE.
LOOKING FOR IT- THE SAYS THAT A
DEFENDANT COULD BE SUED OUT
REPEATEDLY- IN THE STATE OF FOR
THE SAME CONTACT EVEN IF. HERE
SHE HAS SUCCEEDED IN DEFENDING
THEMSELVES AGAINST THE SAME
CLAIMS- SO I JUST YOU KNOW A
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT CONCERN ME
AND I HOPE. WE CAN GET FROM YOU
TO KEEP ON WORKING ON MAKING
THIS LIKE THE KIND OF BILL THAT
DOESN'T- VIOLATE OTHER CIVIL
RIGHTS THAT WE HAVE FOUGHT FOR
SO LONG AND I KNOW. YOU HAVE TO-
BUT- THEY GET CAUGHT UP IN THIS
AND UNFORTUNATELY SOMETHING THAT
GETS DEVISED IN TEXAS. OF RATE
IS AND I KNOW IT'S BEEN UPHELD
BUT THAT'S NOT EXACTLY LIKE THE
BEST MODEL IN MY MIND
POLITICALLY- FOR WHAT WE HAVE
STOOD FOR IN IN CALIFORNIA SO
IT'S GOING TO BRING THOSE TO
YOUR TENSION AND I HOPE THEY
GET. ADDRESSED AND- TODAY I WILL
SUPPORT BUT KEEPING ALL THOSE.
QUESTIONS AND MINE FOR
OBSERVATIONS- YOU SEE THAT'S THE
PURPOSE AND INTENT WE ARE.
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF HAVING
MORE THAN ONE COMMITTEE THIS
ISN'T THAT COMMITTEE HOLDS THE
PURPOSE OF THE PROCESS SO HAPPY
TO WORK WITH YOU ON IT WORK WITH
THE GOVERNOR WITH A LOT OF.
LAWYERS ON THIS AND IT'S A
CHALLENGE BECAUSE WHAT YOU'RE
RIGHT I MEAN YOU RAISE A REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE WE'RE TRYING TO.
GET WITH THE FOUR CORNERS OF THE
SUPREME COURT DECISION RIGHT AND
YET DO WITH THE MORE INTELLIGENT
WAY BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE
DAY ASSUMING SOMEONE BRING. SAID
THAT ACTION TO CHALLENGE THIS.
AT THIS CAL. LAW WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO. TO PUT THE COURT IN A
IN A SITUATION WHERE THEY'RE
THEY'RE HELD. TO ACCOUNT AND I
JUST SAY ONE THING A CENTER SIX
IMPORTANT IN THIS REGARD. AND I
KIND OF TIE THIS INTO MY CLOTHES
AND ANSWER QUESTIONS IS. YOU
KNOW WHEN WE DID THE RESEARCH ON
LOOKING AT THE- BRIEFS THAT WERE
FILED BEFORE THE COURT. BY FOR
THE NC SUPREME COURT THERE IS A-
A BRIEF FILED BY THE FIREARMS
POLICY INSTITUTE CAN'T MAYBE
HAVE IT OFF. BUT BASICALLY THE
IDEA WAS THEY BROGHT A CAKE
THEY BROUGHT IN TO MAKE HIS CASE
A COURT AND SAID LOOK. IF THIS
APPLIES TO ABORTION. THE NEXT
THING IS GOING TO APPLY TO GUNS
AND SO THE ARGUMENT WELL THE
SUPREME COURT WASN'T AWARE OF
THIS THEY HAD A BRIEF AN
ARGUMENT THAT WAS QUITE
BRILLIANT. IN TERMS OF MAKING
THIS ARGUMENT AND THE COURT
REJECTED IT SO I THINK IT GAVE
US A LITTLE BIT MORE STRENGTH IN
THAT REGARD. SIR WHITE HOUSE.
THANK YOU SANDRA WAS AND WHAT
BECAUSE HE THE THAT GETS ABSENT
. UP AND SEND ASSISTS. A VENUE
QUESTION THE I THINK THE STAFF
REPORTER PAGE THIRTEEN TALKS
ABOUT. AN UNUSUAL- THE VENUE-
CONDITIONS ON THE ON THIS BILL
THAT. IS SHE'S MY COLLEAGUE
INDICATED. INVALIDATED
INVALIDATES NON MUTUAL ISSUE.
PRECLUSION AND NON MUTUAL CLAIM
PRECLUSION. AS DEFENSES IN
ACTIONS BROUGHT PURSUANT TO THE
BILL THIS BILL WHICH MEANS THAT.
YOU WOULD HAVE OF. A VARIETY OF.
SIM IDENTICAL CLAIMS IN
DIFFERENT COURTHOUSES
THROUGHOUT- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- WHAT YOU'RE THINKING ON
TECH AS A QUICK PROCESS.
SPECIFICALLY ARE SLAPPED
PROGRAMS THAT ALLOW FOR MOTIONS
TO STRIKE. THAT DO WHAT TEXAS
THEATER JUST SLIPPING I'M NOT
CAMERA TEXTED IS TO BE A TEXAS
ADDITION THE CHALLENGES WITH
THIS LET'S ASSUME SOMEONE WAS IN
COUNTY A. COUNTY BEING COUNTY
SEE AND HAD. SOUGHT WEAPONS
RIGHT AND SAY CENTER NUMBER IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND YOU KNOW THE
SENATE ACCOUNT SKIP IN FREMONT
AND CENTER LAYERED OVER THERE
AND SANTA CRUZ ONE TO BRING AN
ACTION. TO BE THREE ACTIONS IT'S
A PRETTY TOUGH STANDARD I GET
THAT BUT AS WE GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS WILL DRILL DOWN THROUGH
IT BUT IT IS IT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE DID THE MODEL AFTER
TEXAS. BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS TO CREATE THE GREATEST
TELLING AFFECTED WE POSSIBLY CAN
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE THESE
ILLEGAL. WEAPONS HAVE NO
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS HAVE.
THANK CENTER INTO YOUR ON THIS.
SINISTER THANK YOU MR AND- THE
POOR THE AUTHOR. FOR STEPPING
INTO THE BREACH HERE IN. GOING
THROUGH- THE BORDERLINE SHOOTING
IN THOUSAND OAKS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WAS A. AND CHANGE MY
LIFE AND WAS VERY HARD. PLACE TO
BE A PUBLIC REPRESENTATIVE WHEN
. HOLD THAT YOU KNOWS KIDS GET
KILLED- WITH WEAPONS THAT
SHOULDN'T BE HERE. AND TO TRY TO
MAKE SENSE OF ALL THAT IS SORT
OF IMPOSSIBLE AND NO BILLS EVER
GOING TO DO THAT SO FOR ALL THE
VICTIMS- AND ALL THE ADVOCATES
WHO'VE BEEN FIGHTING. I
APPRECIATE YOUR HUMILITY ABOUT
WHAT THIS ANY BILL CAN DO OR NOT
DO- BUT I THINK THIS BILL IS
COMPLETELY NECESSARY- THANK
TIMELY AND I THINK THE ANALYSIS
AND THE AUTHOR MAKE STRONG
ARGUMENTS FOR. THE- THE
STATUTORY BASIS FOR THIS I THINK
WE CANWE CAN OVERCOME WHATEVER-
CLAIM PRECLUSION ISSUES OR OR
PREEMPTION ISSUES MIGHT BE
PRESENTED IN FEDERAL SATUTE
THEY GIVE NEARLY TAYLOR TO THE
POTENTIAL DEFENDANT I THINK
THERE'S SOME OTHER ELEMENTS IN
HERE THAT THE MAKERS LEGALLY
DEFENSIBLE THE ONE QUESTION I DO
WANT TO RAISE THOUGH IS. THE
GENESIS HERE IS THE CHAIR- I
THINK YOU OUGHT TO MENTION. FROM
THIS AWFUL TEXAS DECISION. ARE
WE ARE WE PACKING OURSELVES TO
THAT DECISION IN OTHER WORDS IF
WE IF THE FUTURE COURT IS ABLE
TO OVERTURN. THAT UP HOLDINGOF
THE TEXAS ABORTION BAN WHICH I
THINK WAS A HARD DECISION AND
FRANKLY- I MISREAD A
CONSTITUTION. OF THE- YOU KNOW
THE SUBSTANTIVE DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS THAT PEOPLE HAVE ON THE
FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT AND A
NUMBER OF OTHER- IMPLIED AND
SUBSTANTIVE RIGHTS SO HOW HOW
MUCH ARE WE- HOW MUCH OF OUR
STATE OUR STRATEGY HERE SORT OF
BOUND UP WITH THAT SUPREME COURT
DECISION AND- IF IT WERE
OVERTURNED WOULD WE- WILL WE
LOSE FOOTING HERE IN UP HOLDING
THIS LAW OR DO YOU THINK THERE'S
AN INDEPENDENT. BASIS TO SORT OF
ARGUE THIS BEFORE THE COURT AND
GET A WIN AT THE SUPREME COURT
WHERE THIS CHALLENGED WITHOUT.
AFFIRMING WHAT I VIEW IS THAT
PRESIDENT. I THINK THE ANSWER TO
THE QUESTION SIR I THINK THAT
THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION IS.
FOR LEGISLATORS COULD DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT RIGHT AND IT
WOULD BE KIND OF NICE IN A
CERTAIN SENSE BECAUSE IT WOULD
BE IN TERMS OF THE SUPREME COURT
CHANGED OPINION. OF WE'VE SEEN
THIS YEAR'S COMPETITION THROUGH
COURT MAKES A DECISION AND
THAT'S THE LAW UNTIL THE NEXT.
GROUP OF JUSTICES. OVERTURNING
RIGHT SEPARATE BUT EQUAL WAS
LEGAL UNTIL BROWN VERSUS BOARD
OF EDUCATION CAME AROUND.
EXAMPLE AFTER EXAMPLE OF THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS BUT CERTAINLY WE
COULD DO THAT HOWEVER I WOULD
SIX FACT. THAT GIVING PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION BECAUSE UNLIKE.
IT PORTION ISSUE WHERE THERE'S A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT. AND
THERE'S AN ARGUMENT ABOUT THAT.
I DON'T THINK THAT THERE'S A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO HAVE IT
SOUGHT WEAPON. RIGHT THE FOLKS
HERE THAT ARE LEGAL GUN OWNERS I
RESPECT. GREATLY I LOVE THE FACT
THAT- THEY TALKED ABOUT BEING A
LEGAL OWNERS MISTER HARPER WHO'S
HERE TODAY. AND THE LIKE WITH
THERE'S NOTHING HERE ABOUT THE
ILL ABOUT LEGAL DIAL WHICH WE
DON'T TOUCH LEGAL GUN OWNERS
THEY CAN DO WHATEVER THEY WANT.
WE DON'T BURDEN THEM WE DON'T
TELL THEM HOW MUCH AMMUNITION
THEY CAN HAVE WE DON'T TELL THEM
THEY'VE GOT TO USE A GUN SAFE WE
DON'T TELL THEM ABOUT ANY OF
THOSE THINGS IT DOESN'T.
REGISTRATION GETTING PASSED OVER
WE JUST DEAL WITH THIS VERY
NARROW BAND OF ILLEGAL WEAPONS
FIFTY CALIBER MACHINE GUNS
ASSAULT WEAPONS AND GHOST GUNS.
AND JUST TO ANSWER IT'S ENOUGH
TO PUT IN THE CLUBS- THE-
QUESTION. IS REFERENCED. ABOUT
THE IN THE TESTIMONY. I'D GO
RUNS WAS ONE I THINK THE
STANDARD THAT THAT THAT- TALK.
I'M A BUT KNOWING SOLVE THAT
PROBLEM THE SECOND THERE'S A
MEASURE BEFORE THE SLOW AB SIX
TWENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GIPSON TO BASICALLY CLOSE THE
BALANCE OF ANY LOOPHOLES WITH
RESPECT TO GHOST GUNS THAT WAS
MET MENTIONED BY THE INDIVIDUAL
TESTIFIED SO I THINK THAT GIVES
US FLEXIBILITY HE BE INSTINCTIVE%
TO REVISIT THAT CERTAINLY WOULD
BE NICE BECAUSE MAYBE WE CAN FIX
THE THEIR OPINION WITH RESPECT
TO HOW IT RIDICULOUS OPINION
ABORTIONS. BUT JUST TO PUT A
FINER POINT AT THIS POINT WE ARE
DEPENDENT YES LEGALLY ON THAT
DECISION YEAH OKAY. THAT'S
CORRECT THANK YOU SIR. ALL RIGHT
OF SAYING NO OTHER QUESTIONS-
THANK YOU CENTERS FOR BEFORE YOU
CLOSE- THANK YOU THIS THE BILL
HAS TO LAUDABLE GOALS ONE IS TO
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL- IN
CREATIVE ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM
AS TO. ENFORCING CURRENTLY
EXISTING GUN LAWS IN CALIFORNIA
AND SECONDLY IS THE HIGHLIGHT
THE ABSURDITY OF THE- SLAUGHTER
I'M GRATEFUL THAT YOU PROVISION
IN THE IN THE BILL. THAT
ACTUALLY. BASICALLY VOIDS ARE
LAW SHOULD RIGHT THE COURT
ULTIMATELY DECIDES THE TEXAS AND
FORCE A MECHANISM IS. CRAZY
THAT'S RIGHT- IN AND I'M HOPEFUL
THAT THAT THERE WILL BE A
FINDING THAT THE TEXAS
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM IS CRAZY-
THE CHALLENGE OF COURSE IS THAT.
WE'RE WE'RE SORT OF TWO MINDS
HERE WHERE. WE AT LEAST ME AND I
THINK YOU JOIN ME CENTER
HERTZBERG AND HOPING THAT THE
TEXAS LAWS FOUND TO BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL- IN THE US
VOIDING THE LAW THAT MAY BE
PASSED ON THIS COMMITTEE TODAY-
HAVING SAID THAT I'M I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT IT. BUT IT IS MY HOPE
AND DESIRE THAT THAT ULTIMATELY
THIS BILL ACTUALLY NOT PROCEED-
BECAUSE THE TEXAS LAW IS FOUND
TO BE WRONG ON CONSTITUTIONAL
AND CRAZY THIS IS SORT OF COMES
UNDER THE MONKEY SEE MONKEY DO
RUBRIC- AND- HOPEFULLY WE WON'T
BE DOING THE MONKEY SEE MONKEY
DO THINGS. ALL THE WAY TILL THE
- DATE OF THIS YEAR SESSION SO
HAVING SAID THAT IS OUR MOTION
SOME OF THE SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
CAN MOVE THE BILL. K. BRIEFLY.
YES I JUST WANT TO KIND OF BREAK
A FINER POINT WHICH CENTERS
CHANGED IN WOULD YOU SAID OF
COURSE THAT'S THE CASE BUT WHEN
THE SITUATION HERE WHAT WHAT IF
IT TURNS OUT WHEN THIS IS GOING
TO LITIGATION PROCESSES WHOM IT
DOES IT WORKS THAT IT HAS A
CHILLING EFFECT THAT IS A
CONSEQUENCE IT HELPS GETTING
SOME GUNS OFF THE STREET WHICH
THAT MIGHT HELP THESE ILLEGAL
GUNS MIGHT HELP PREVENT CERTAIN
KINDS OF THESE HORRIBLE
TRAGEDIES RIGHT SO THERE MIGHT
BE A SILVER LINING WE MIGHT IN
FUTURE LEGISLATURES MIGHT WANT
TO COME BACK. ON THIS IT BY
VIRTUE OF IT BEING EFFECTIVE SO
IT'S A GOOD DOUBLE SILVER LINING
IN THE SENSE OF WHAT THAT WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE A LAST YOU WANNA
I'M SOMEONE WHO ALWAYS USE
CREDIT WHERE CREDIT'S DUE AND
ONLY A CREDIT TO THE GOVERNOR
YOU KNOW I DON'T TAKE RISKS I
DON'T TAKE THESE THAT TAKE A
CREDIT FOR THINGS THAT. HE WAS
THE ONE. PUT A PRESS CAR. EVER
IMHO. AND PASSIONATE WAY. TALKED
ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE AND TALKED
ABOUT THE HARM HE'S THE ONE.
WHO'S OFFICE IS. BEING VERY
CLOSELY AND VERY HARD ON THIS.
AND HE DESERVES A LOT OF CREDIT
BECAUSE HE'S AN INSPIRATION
BEHIND THE STUFF I AM JUST THE-
VESSEL. BASSIL OR WHATEVER IT
IS. THAT PROCESS. SOMETHING
YOU'RE BOTH. I DON'T KNOW YES
WHATEVER IT IS. A SITE THAT I
WANT TO GIVE HIM CREDIT AND ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTERS
BURKE ALL RIGHT THERE'S BEEN IN
MOTION BY CENTER WHITE HOUSE
EMAIL TO COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN BUT CENTER
HERTZBERG WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE GAVE THE
MOTION IS D. PASSED BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY- BURKE- HI. AMBER
GUY BURGESS. W. IT'LL THE
RUSSELL HI THE REST SO I
GONZALEZ HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG
AYE JONES. WHERE'D I LAYERED ICE
STERN ALL RIGHT STERN AYE
WIECKOWSKI AYE AYE CASKEY AYE
WIENER. SO FAR YOU HAVE SIX TWO
ZERO WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG- NEXT
WE HAVE S. B. ONE ONE EIGHT FOUR
BY SENATOR CORTESE OF CENTER
CORTESE IS HERE. NOW WOULD BE
THE TIME TO APPROACH I DO NOT
SEE CENTER CORTESE- CENTER COM
LONGER IS UNDER COM LONGER ERE
I DO NOT SEE SENATOR COM LONGER.
SO MY GUESS IS THAT THAT SOME OF
AUTHORS WERE ANTICIPATING THAT
OUR FIRST. ITEM OF BUSINESS WAS
GOING TO TAKE A BIT LONGER THAN
IT DID- SO WE'RE WE'RE READY FOR
ADDITIONAL BUSINESS WHATEVER
AUTHOR. YEAH WHAT KIND OF-
CENTER WHITE CAL SKI IS HERE AND
LOOKS ANXIOUS SO- SOMEWHERE CAL
SKI. CENTER WHITE CAL SKI FIRST-
SB. ONE ZERO NINE NINE REGARDING
BANKRUPTCY DEBTORS. IT WAS. TEN
TWENTY SIX. YES YOU'RE RIGHT-
JUST BECAUSE I CAN'T READ
CORRECTLY THAT SHOULDN'T BE HELD
AGAINST ME- ALL RIGHT SO- NUMBER
ELEVEN S. B. ONE ZERO TWO SIX
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND-
COLLEAGUES I WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT. TO BE TEN TWENTY SIX
THANK THE CONSULTANT FOR WORKING
WITH OUR WITH THEM ON WITH MY
OFFICE- S. B. AT TEN TWENTY SIX
EMPOWERS CONSUMERS WITH THE
BASELINE OF INFORMATION ON WHAT
THEIR ENERGY EFFICIENCY IS OF A
PUT UP FOR POTENTIAL RENTAL UNIT
WHEN CONSUMERS ARE SEEKING OUT
NEW RENTAL HOUSING THEY DO SO
KNOWING WHAT THEIR GENERAL
BUDGET IS UP BUT UNFORTUNATELY
THERE'S ONE COST CITY CAN'T
FULLY ACCOUNT FOR THAT'S OUR
ENERGY USE. SO WHEN THE CURRENT
LAW CONSUMERS GENERALLY DO NOT
KNOW HOW MUCH- MUCH ABOUT THE
EFFICIENCY OF THE RENTAL UNIT
UNTIL THEY COMMIT TO LIVING IN
THE RENTAL UNITS TO APPLIANCES
MAYBE OLDER MAYBE OUTDATED THE
BUILDING COULD LACK INSULATION
BECAUSE OF SINGLE PANE WINDOWS
AND THE LIST GOES ON RANCHERS
MAY QUICKLY DISCOVER THAT THEIR
ENERGY BILLS EXCEED THEIR
BUDGETS EVEN THOUGH THROUGH NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN SO BECAUSE
RENTERS PAY THE POWER BILLS
THERE'S NO INCENTIVE FOR A
LANDLORD TO MAKE ENERGY AND
MONEY SAVING EFFICIENCY UPGRADES
WHILE THE TENANTS HAVE NO.
INCENTIVE TO UPGRADE TO WINDOWS
SERVER TWO SEALED VICTORY- THAT
THEY CAN'T TAKE WITH THEM WHEN
THEY MOVE OUT SO THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE A BASIC ENERGY
EFFICIENCY DISCLOSURE FORM BY
THE LANDLORD AT THE TIME OF
SIGNING PLEASE SIMILAR TO THE
REQUIREMENT- FOR ALL RENTAL
LEASES IN THE STATE OF MAINE AS
OUTLINED INDIA. THE STAFF REPORT
IT LISTS THE BASIC INFORMATION
ABOUT HEATING SYSTEMS INSULATION
WINDOWS DOORS AND APPLICATIONS I
WOULD FURTHER CHARGE ENERGY
COMMISSION TO CREATE A RATING
SYSTEM LABELING- OR LABELING-
SYSTEM WHICH THE CONSUMERS
COULD. YOU TO SAY LOOK THE-
DIFFERENT. RENTAL UNITS SEE IF
IT. EXCEEDS FAILS THE BASIC
TENANTS OF MODERNITY EFFICIENCY-
SEVENTY ABSENT. OPPOSITION
HISTORIES OF THE PRIVACY
CONCERNS IT'S IN- IN I DON'T
BELIEVE IT INFRINGES WERE ASKING
FOR DISCLOSURE OF. INFORMATION
THAT WOULD IDENTIFY INDIVIDUAL
PEOPLE WE JUST FOR NOW WITH THE
UNIT- IS THAT I'M HAD SOME
CONVERSATION WITH THE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
LANDLORDS ABOUT- GETTING THIS
INFORMATION AND-I. PLEDGE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM AND-
AS WE TRY TO UPGRADE OUR HOUSING
STOCK IN A PROVIDE CONSUMERS
WITH THAT I DO HAVE STEVE NOT
DOWN IF HE'S- ON THE LINE HE'S
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. FOR THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL FOR AN ENERGY
EFFICIENT ECONOMY. THANK YOU SIR
WHAT KELSEY MR IN THE DELL ARE
YOU AVAILABLE. I REALIZE THAT
WE'RE GOING A BIT OUT OF ORDER-
AND MAYBE WE PROCEED TO OTHER
SUPPORTERS AND COME BACK TO MR
THE DEL IF HE APPEARS ON THE
PHONE LINE- NYONE ELSE HERE IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED. WHO IS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF ONE ZERO
TWO SIX. JUST SO FOLKS KNOW WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS I'M GONNA TAKE
CENTER WHITE HOUSE SKIS S. B.
TEN TWENTY SIX WHICH BEING HEARD
RIGHT NOW FOLLOWED UP BY SEN
WHITE KELSEY'S SB ONE ZERO NINE
NINE. AND THEN- ONE ONE EIGHT
NINE SB ONE ONE EIGHT NINE SAID
A WHITE CAL SKI AND THEN
FINALLY- TO CONCLUDE THE CENTER
WHITE CAL SKI SHOW SB ONE FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN BY CENTER WHAT
KOWSKI- LAST ALL RIGHT. SO
MODERATOR ON THE PHONE LINE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. ONE ZERO TWO SIX. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK N
SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE ZERO TWO
SIX. THE FIRST ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT- IN
MR NOT APPEARED I ASSUME. L. ALL
RIGHT SO LET'S NOW TURN TO
OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND THAT-
NIKOLINA I'M SORRY GO AHEAD
MODERATOR. A YOUNG. WOMAN I JUST
GOT CONNECTED. ARE YOUR TAX BILL
ALL RIGHT TONIGHT MISTER SHOWMAN
IF YOU'RE HERE TO TEST FUND SB
ONE ZERO NINE NINE WILL GET YOU
IN A FEW MOMENTS- BUT LET'S
RIGHT NOW ON OPPOSITION TO SB
ONE ZERO TWO SIX IS IKOLINA
HERNANDEZ ARE ARE YOU AVAILABLE
. NIKULIN ANALYSTS UP AND
RUNNING- ONLINE YOU ARE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THE BILLIONS
OF AMERICA- BUT HE'LL GAS AND
ELECTRIC SHE SAID THE OFFICE
INTENSIVE WHILE AT THE TIME I
THINK YOU WILL BE DISCONNECTED
OUR ISSUES WITH THE TAP AND MANY
ARE CONCERNED THERE ARE LARGELY
AROUND THAT CUSTOMER PRIVACY. OR
THE ELECTRIC CORPORATIONS-
PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE SECTION
EIGHTY THREE ZERO FORGET THE
FACT WILL DISCLOSE ANY CUSTOMER
DATA- TYPICALLY WHEN YOU PAIR
VOTE USES DATA WITH THE UNIT
ADDRESS IT RAISES QUESTIONS
ABOUT- POTENTIALLY VIOLATING
FACT THAT THE CODE SECTION THAT
CAN BE THIRTY FIVE SO WE HAVE
THAT WE ACTUALLY WOULD REQUIRE
THAT MIMIC BETTER ABOUT THE FACT
THAT MY DATA ALLOWANCE I'M FINE
WITH THAT THE DETECTION THE
BOTTLE AT- HELP ME. CARE OF THE
BILL'S LOUDEST YET AGAIN IT'S- A
VERY IMPORTANT GOAL AND MAKE
SURE THAT FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO
BUDGET- I HAVE BEEN A GOOD
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
UTILITY BILLS MAY BE- YOU KNOW
WHAT. THAT HAVE THAT. RIGHT
MARKET I FEEL BAD.
RIGHT NOW PLEASE BROTHER HE'S
NOT VERY- THANK EVEN MEDICAL.
FAMILY BY AND HOW OFTEN DOES.
ALL OF OUR- I- THAT ARE- PART
BLIND THAT- BUT THE OFFICE. SO-
IF WE ARE WE ARE AND CORD LIKE
MANY AND ARE HAPPY TO BE A BIG
IN LOOK AT THE OFFICE END OF THE
ACTUALLY BEFORE AS WELL YEAH I
DO FEEL WELL I'M TO CAN'T. LET
ME KNOW- OUT ON THE FIFTIETH
BASIC BENEFITS RT THANK YOU
MISTER OTHERS UP HERE IN ROOM
HUNDRED SINGING ONE APPROACHING
MIKE. EXCEPT FROM KINGSTON SELF. OKAY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN A MEMBER THE COMMITTEE
MISTER CAL SKI- HE I'VE HAD A
CHANCE TO TALK THE ISSUE A
LITTLE WE REPRESENT HIS OWN
APARTMENT SO SHE IS JUST TREAT
AND SEVERAL OTHER SO. THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. FACILITY THAT HAVE
READ. AMOUNTS TO TAKE ONLY
CHARGE THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE UNITS- THAT OR RESTRICTED
OR THAT ARE REGULATED REGARD AS
TO THE ISSUE. OF WE'RE NOT AWARE
OF THE. BUT TENANTS ARE CLAMOR
FOR THE SIM FROM. IN FACT- IN
LLYNFI COVERED. WITH ASKED DOZEN
OF LATE. AND NOT ONE OF A MAY
SAID SECOND. ONE THE WITNESSES
TALKED ABOUT PRIVACY PRIVACY IS
A VERY SIGNIFICANT ISSUE GETTING
THE INFORMATION FROM IN THIS
CASE P. JEANNIE OR ESTY GENIE.
ARE CAN BE A VERY SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM THERE IS NO AUTHORITY
THERE'S NO AUTHORIZATION FOR US
TO GET THAT INFORMATION. IN A
TIMELY MANNER AND IF WE DON'T
GET IT- THEN WHAT IS THE
PERSPECTIVE TENET TO SAY NO I'M
I'M NOT GOING TO. OF RAN FROM
YOU. MISTER WHAT KOWSKI RAISES
THE ISSUE ABOUT THE REFRIGERATOR
WELL. EVEN THEIR CONDITIONING
ONE PARTY MAY USE AN AIR
CONDITIONER AND ONE DOESN'T HAVE
ANY INTEREST IN MUSIC IT ALL
FELL THERE IS A DISPARITY IN. A
USE WHICH CAN BE VAST FROM THE
PREVIOUS TENANTS TO THE NEW
TENANTS WHAT SEEMS TO US TO BE
ABLE A PLAUSIBLE SOLUTION TO ALL
OF THIS. IS TO ASK THE UTILITY
COMPANY TO PUBLISH. A WHITE RATE
FOR OUR AND THEN LET THE
CONSUMER THE TENANT- DECIDE EVEN
IN PURCHASING OR ACQUISITION OF
SINGLE FAMILY ONE TO FOUR
PROPERTIES. THERE IS NOT ONE
REQUIREMENT IN DOZENS OF YEARS
THAT'S EVER ASKED THAT QUESTION
NOR DO THE PURCHASERS ASK THIS
QUESTION WHAT IS YOUR CONCERN.
SO SAID MANY OTHER RE- WE REMAIN
OPPOSED YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU-
OTHERS OPPOSED HERE IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED SINGLE YES GO
AHEAD SIR. AMBER MEDICINE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
SIMPLE REASONS THE FIRST IS THAT
LANDLORDS RT REQUIRED- WE WE'RE
NOW DONE WITH OF THE TWO
WITNESSES THAT EACH HAD TWO
MINUTE. I GOT TWO DOOR SERVICE
YOUR OPPOSITION YES GOT IT OKAY.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED SEEING ONE
MATER IF YOU QUEUE. UP THOSE ON
THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO ASK B. ONE ZERO
TWO SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE
END ZERO AT THIS TIME. OR TO Y.
ONE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
POLITICS FOR MAKING THE COR Q.
TECHNIQUE FAN I'M HAPPY
CALIFORNIA THIS SHOULD BE IN
DEMAND MANAGEMENT COUNSEL AND
SUPPORT AT THE TEN TWENTY SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE. FIVE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SCREAMED RETAIL BEHALF
CALIFORNIA REALTORS WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL AT FIRST BECAUSE THE
AMENDED THAT WE REQUEST THE
NOTEBOOK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M FORTY TWO PLEASE CALL
AHEAD. WELL YEAH AND AYE OPPOSED
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I WON
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD- MY NAME'S
MELANIE HIT BY HAVE RENTED A
HOUSE AND- I OPPOSE ABOUT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS LINDA RICHMAN OF THE LAND
OWNER I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU LANDLORDS I'D LOVE TO STILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT- SO. ANYONE ELSE
OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND THAT MR
IN THE DELL IS NOW ON THE PHONE
LINE SO SIR- GO AHEAD. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND SPEAKING
A DROP IN THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
FOR AN ENERGY EFFICIENT ECONOMY.
FOR NON RESEARCH ORGANIZATION
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
INCORPORATED IN CALIFORNIA. I'M
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ABSENT TEN TWENTY SIX. ARE WE
FOR I THINK THAT THIS
LEGISLATION CAMINO PORTENT FIRST
STEP IN EFFORTS TO REDUCE THE
ENERGY FELT CALIFORNIA RENTERS.
THESE COSTS CAN BE QUITE HIGH.
ENERGY CAN BE A MAJOR COST OF
RENTAL UNITS. OUR RESEARCH HAS
FOUND THAT THE AVERAGE U. S.
HOUSEHOLD SPENDS OVER 3% OF ITS
INCOME ARE FOR ENERGY HOME
ENERGY USE OUR RECORDS ON
AVERAGE HAVE. 13% HIGHER ENERGY
BURDENS AND HOMEOWNERS. YEAH LOW
INCOME HOW PAYS A FOR THAN EIGHT
AFTER ON HOMELAND. ARE WITH WE
ARE NOW COME A STUDY ON RANGE TO
REACTION TO VERY POSSIBLE PART.
LATE DESIGN- THIS WILL PUBLIC IN
MAY BUT WE HAVE FOUND THAT
RENTERS VALUE. HERE FOR MAKE
SHOULDN'T WHEN LOOK. ENTER.
INFORMATION IS PROVIDED ON ALL.
WE DO FOR THAT LATE TO HELP
TENDED TO IDENTIFY MARKETS POP
APARTMENTS THAT THEY WILL TO PAY
MORE IN IF WILL HELP THEM REDUCE
THEIR ENERGY GO. BY THE LATE
BECAUSE I WE LOOKED IN. PART OF
DIFFERENT THE DIFFERENT NINE AND
AT TEN TWENTY. ALL THE DESIGN TO
AT WORK. TO KNOW WAY FALL. BUT
WE CONCLUDE THAT THE F. AND THAT
MAKE TEN TWENTY SIX WILL TENANTS
THAT WITH USEFUL INFORMATION AND
WILL THEM TO REDUCE THEIR AND
BILL. ARE WE ALSO KNOW THAT. THE
BILL HAS ANY USE. AVAILABLE UPON
PAYMENT REQUEST. TO ALLOW
RENTERS TO COMPARE PROSPECTIVE
APARTMENTS WE RECOMMEND THAT
THIS INFORMATION BE PROVIDED. TO
PROSPECTIVE TENANTS AND ALL
HOMES AND NOT JUST ON A
VOLUNTARY BASIS. AND ALSO
SUGGESTED THAT HE SEE HAVE A
PARTY TO REQUIRE THAT- RENTAL
LISTINGS INCLUDE THAT
INFORMATION. PEOPLE WHO DISAGREE
CAN MAKE ARGUMENTS OF THE FEE
FREE AND THEN THEY CAN DESCRIBE
. THE ALSO NOTE DISCLOSURE OF IN
. THANK YOU SIR WHEN I HAVE BUT
PRETTY SURE YOU TEST THANK YOU
SIR. ALL RIGHT OKAY YEAH THE
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE BUT
BE WE DO LET ME ADDRESS ONE
HOUSEKEEPING MATTER- THE RISK OF
FURTHER CONFUSING OUR AGENDA
TODAY- WE TOOK SENT A WHITE CAL
SKIS FIRST BILL AND I ANNOUNCED
TO THE WORLD THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE ALL THE SENATE WHITE CAL
SKIS BILLS AND I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE FOLKS THAT ARE ON THE PHONE
LINE THAT. WAITING I KNOW THIS
LEYVA IS BEEN WAITING HERE
PATIENTLY AS WELL AND I THINK
CENTER CAMARGO ALSO HERE SO JUST
FOR. THIS JOE JUST SIT. YOUR
TIME. ESTIMATES WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
COMPLETE CENTER WHITE CAL SKIS
BILL AS I PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED.
AND THEN- WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
CENTER LABOR'S BILL AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA GO TO CENTER COM
LOGGERS BILL. AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
ORDER SO IF THAT MAKES SENSE TO
THOSE ON THE PHONE LINE AND
THOSE THAT ARE PRESENT. THAT'S
THE ANTICIPATED ORDER OF
PRESENTATION. ALL RIGHT SO-
BRING IT BACK HERE TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS FOR CENTER WHITE CAL
SKI WERE NOW ON SB. ONE ZERO TWO
SIX. SAY NO QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT-
IS THERE A MOTION. I'M OF THE
BILL SENATE CAREER MOST THE BILL
AND IS THAT WHAT BECAUSE HE
FIRST WILL BEFORE WE GET TOO
CLOSE TO YOU AND I HAVE
DISCUSSED THE PRIVACY ISSUES
WHICH ARE- OF CONSEQUENCE HERE
GIVEN CALIFORNIA'S PRIVACY LAW
IN THE INTEREST CALIFORNIANS IN
THEIR PRIVATE- YOUR- TO BE ABLE
TO. PROVIDE INFORMATION TO A
POTENTIAL TENANT THAT DOES NOT
INVADE THE PRIVACY RIGHTS OF THE
PREVIOUS TENANTS- WEEK WE SIR I
WANT TO. CREATE INCENTIVES TO-
HAVE ENERGY EFFICIENT
ACCOMMODATIONS AND I KNOW THAT
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE THAT KIND
OF INCENTIVE. HAVING SAID THAT
THIS IS AS I UNDERSTAND IT'S
STILL A WORK IN PROGRESS I BASS
. SENATE JUDICIARY STAFF TO
CONTINUE TO BIRD DOG THIS SO
THAT THAT- WE ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS PARTICULARLY IN
RELATION TO PRIVACY AND IN
RELATION TO VERY SMALL FOR
EXAMPLE- LAND NOT NOT SMALL
STATURE BUT SMALL THE NUMBER OF
UNITS THAT ARE OWNED. LANDLORDS
HAVING SAID THAT SENATE WHITE
HOUSE YOU CARE TO CLOSE I THINK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I WOULD DIE
FOR. WELL IT'S THAT THERE'S NO
PURSE I. INFORMATION HI SHARE
THE CONCERNS ABOUT THAT YET YOU
PHRASE I'M PRIVATE SUITE THAT'S
NOT THE INTENT HERE THIS IS THE
SECOND BILL OF ITS KIND MAIN
BECAME TE FIRST ONE THEY HAVE
THIS- THIS TYPE OF BILL AND-
THEN AT SOME OF THE OPPOSITION
HAS POINTED OUT. MAYBE FOR ME
FOR PATIENTS THAT YOU KNOW. YOU
USED OF ENERGY AND ONE. UNIT
MAYBE IT'S A CUMULATIVE OF THE
WHOLE BUILDING SO THAT PEOPLE
HAVE MEANINGFUL OF. DONE SO WITH
THAT. TO KEEP THE STAFF. IN AS
WE MOVE FORWARD IF I'M SO LUCKY
AND I WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH BECAUSE
HE SAID A COUPLE HEROES AND FOR
ME THAT THAT SHE HAS MOVED BILL
. HER CHIN IS- THIS IS. OF YOU-
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED HERE YEAH I DID
THAT IN MY OPENING I. EXPECT ALL
THE GOVERNMENT BUT ALSO I THINK
IN TERMS OF SOME OF THE OTHER
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN VOICE
CONCERNING PRIVACY. I'VE HEARD I
SEE A HEAD SHAKE IN THE
AFFIRMATIVE ALL RIGHT. SO
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION WAS UNDER
COVER YEAR AMENITIES. COUNCIL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS.
SB TEN TWENTY SIX BY SENATOR WAY
CASKEY WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR COVEY IT'LL- THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS- BURKE I. AM
BURKE. PORTIS. CABALLERO
CABALLERO BY THE WRESTLE.
WRESTLE I GONZALEZ HERTZBERG.
JONES LAYARD ARE LAYERED AYE
STERN ALL RIGHT STERN AYE
WIECKOWSKI AYE AYE CASKEY AYE
WIENER. YOU HAVE SIX TO ZERO SO
FAR WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALL
RIGHT THE BILL'S ON CALL SENATOR
TRUMP SPOKE WITH LOW ESSEX'S.
JONES SAWYER ALRIGHT YEAH. OUR
ALRIGHT SENATOR JONES. THAT'S
OKAY JONES NOW OKAY ALL RIGHT AT
THIS IS BACK TO SB TEN TWENTY
SIX- WITH THE MACHINE BACK UP
YET- JONES. JONES NO SUITE SIX
TWO ONE. ZERO ONE. THANK YOU YES
YES YES THAT'S WISHFUL THINKING
CENTER JONES ALL RIGHT SO- NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO- CENTER
CAL SKIS BILL S. B. ONE ZERO
NINE NINE. SO YOU'RE GOING
YOU'RE GOING TO SENATOR. YEAH
THANK. SEPTEMBER YOU SAY THAT IF
I SAID THAT THEN I WILL TRY TO
KEEP MY WORD- I'M TRYING AND
WE'VE WE'VE CREATED SOME
CONFUSION HERE THAT SO. NO WORK
HERE. IT IS A WE'RE GOING TO DO
JUST JUST JUST FOR AVOIDANCE OF
. OR MAYBE THIS HAS SUIT
DECISIONAL CONFUSION- WE'RE
GOING TO DO CENTER LEYVA THEY
WERE GONNA DO SETOR COM LAGER
AND I SEE CENTER CORTESE'S HERE
AND THEN AFTER CENTER CAMARGO
WERE TO COME BACK TO CENTER
CORTESE AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO
GO IN FILE ORDER. LIKELY
INTENDED AT THE OUTSET. ALL
RIGHT SO- CENTER LEYVA S. B.
ELEVEN FORTY NINE. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I WANT TO FIRST THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL I WILL BE IT-
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS RELATED. TO
THIRD PARTIES ON PAGE SEVEN OF
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS MEMBERS
SENATE BILL ELEVEN FORTY NINE
ALSO KNOWN AS THE PUBLIC RIGHT
TO KNOW ACT WOULD PROHIBIT
FACTUAL INFORMATION ABOUT
DANGEROUS PUBLIC HAZARDS. FROM
BEING HIDDEN FROM THE PUBLIC
THROUGH OVERLY BROAD COURT
PROTECTIVE ORDERS AND AGREEMENTS
TO KEEP INFORMATION ABOUT
DANGERS A SECRET. IN AN OPEN
SOCIETY OUR COURT RECORDS ARE
PRESUMPTIVELY OPEN TO PUBLIC
INSPECTION. EVEN IN A DISPUTE
BETWEEN PRIVATE PARTIES THE
COURTS RESOLUTION OF THAT
DISPUTE AS A MATTER OF PUBLIC
INTEREST. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
TRUE WHEN THE CASE INVOLVES A
PUBLIC DANGER SUCH AS A
DEFECTIVE PRODUCT BOARD OF OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SOARED. OR THREE
PRE REPEAT ISSUE OVER BROUGHT.
ORDERS THE KEEP DISCOVERY
INFORMATION SECRET AND PROTECT
INCRIMINATING DOCUMENTS. AND
LAWYERS MUTUALLY AGREED TO
SETTLEMENTS AND STUFF STIPULATED
ORDERS THAT PROHIBIT DISCLOSING
THE VERY FACTS THAT PROMPTED THE
CASE. SECRECY IS SOMETIMES
NECESSARY TO PROTECT PERSONAL
INFORMATION OR LEGITIMATE TRADE
SECRETS BUT IT IS GROSSLY
INAPPROPRIATE WHEN IT CLEARLY
KEEPS INFORMATION ABOUT ONGOING
DANGERS FROM THE PUBLIC. WHICH
IN A VERY REAL WAY CAN AND DOES
THREATEN THEIR HEALTH SAFETY AND
EVEN THEIR LIVES. IF SIGNED
CALIFORNIA WE'RE JOINED SEVERAL
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE ENACTED
SEVERAL ANTI SECRECY LAWS.
INCLUDING FLORIDA LOUISIANA
MONTANA SOUTH CAROLINA AND
WASHINGTON. WITNESSES WITH ME
TODAY WILL SURE EXACTLY WHY THIS
IS CRITICAL BUT I JUST WANT TO
MENTION A COUPLE OF QUICK
EXAMPLES TO HIGHLIGHT THE NEED
FOR SB ELEVEN FORTY NINE. IN THE
CASE OF PURDUE PHARMA THE
COMPANY TOLD OUTRIGHT LIES FOR
MANY YEARS REGARDING SAFE DOSAGE
LEVELS AND THE LIKELIHOOD OF
ADDICTION FROM OXY COTTON. WHICH
ULTIMATELY KILLED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE. THESE
TRAGEDIES THAT TOUCH FAR TOO
MANY FAT. FOR NOW AND THE NEW.
WAS LAW ENABLED THROUGH CAP
COURT SECRECY AND THE VERY
TACTICS THAT THIS BILL SEEKS TO
ADDRESS IN THE CASE OF THE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN BALCONY
COLLAPSE AT A BIRTHDAY PARTY IN
BERKELEY SEVEN PEOPLE DIED AS A
RESULT OF THAT TRAGEDY WHAT THE
PARTY GOERS AND EVEN STATE
REGULARS DID NOT KNOW REGULATORS
DID NOT KNOW WAS THAT THE
CONSTRUCTION COMPANY WHO BUILT
THE COMPLEX HAD PAID OVER TWENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
SETTLEMENTS IN EARLY DEFECT
CASES. BUT THE INFORMATION ABOUT
THOSE CASES REMAIN SHIELDED AS
YOU MAY REMEMBER MANY OF YOU
WERE HERE THE YOUNG WOMAN WHO
INITIALLY SURVIVED THE COLLAPSE
ACTUALLY TRAVELED TO SACRAMENTO
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO
TESTIFY BEFORE A LEGISLATURE
ABOUT HER LIFE CHANGING
EXPERIENCE SADLY SHE NEVER
RECOVERED FROM THE BRAIN AND
OTHER INJURIES SUFFERED AS A
RESULT OF THE BALCONY COLLAPSE
SHE DIED EARLIER THIS YEAR AFTER
SUFFERING SUFFERING A STROKE
BRING THE TOTAL NUMBER OF DEATHS
TO SEVEN. SO THAT NO FURTHER
FAMILY EVER AGAIN HAS TO BURY
THEIR LOVED ONE AS A RESULT OF
THIS UNACCEPTABLE SECRECY. I
HOPE YOU'LL SUPPORT S. B. ELEVEN
FORTY NINE TODAY. HERE WITH ME I
HAVE TO WITNESSES WHO WILL SPEAK
ON THE IMPORTANCE OF THE RIGHT
TO KNOW ACT THE PUBLIC RIGHT TO
KNOW ACT. RICHARD ZITTRAIN
PROFESSOR EMERITUS AT UC
HASTINGS APPEARING ON BEHALF OF
PUBLIC JUSTICE AND AMY COOPER
WITH THE NATIONAL COALITION
AGAINST PRESCRIPTION DRUG ABUSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU SIR EARLY REGISTER FOR
VOICE. DID YOU ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED I CERTAINLY
DID BUT I'LL SET THEM AGAIN IF
YOU'RE LIKE THAT'S FINE ONLY
ONCE IS REQUIRED ALL RIGHT- SO-
PROFESSOR. ZITTRAIN YES YES
THANK YOU JENNIFER. OUR
EVERYTHING THAT I'M ABOUT TO SAY
ABOUT THE BILL IS IN THE- REPLY
TO THE OPPOSITION THAT I THINK
WE'VE ALL DISTRIBUTED TO EACH
ONE OF YOU. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ALLOWING INFORMATION ABOUT
DANGEROUS PRODUCTS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL HAVES HAZARDS TO
BE ON FREELY AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
FACTUAL INFORMATION. IF ONLY WE
KNEW IT. WOULD SAVE COUNTLESS
LIVES WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT.
DOING AWAY WITH TRADE SECRET
PROHIBITIONS THE OPPOSITION SAYS
THAT WE ARE THAT'S NOT TRUE
SURVIVORS CAREFULLY CONCUR.
RIGHT TO THE SUIT YOUR CONTINUE
TO BE TRADE SECRET PROTECTIONS
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT MAKING
SECRECY. REMAINS PUBLIC TO
EVERYBODY AS THE CHAMBERS
CITIZENS OPPOSITION WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT MAKING THE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE FACTS.
PUBLIC FOR EVERYBODY TO SEE IT'S
NOT THE AGREEMENT IS THE FACTS
WHY IS IT THE FACT. THE FACTS
PLUS SECRECY BECAUSE DEATHS
SEVEN RELAVIS DECIDED TO A
COUPLE OF EXAMPLE I WANT TO
MENTION A COUPLE MORE CAR SEAT
BACKS THAT WHEN THEY ARE HIT
FROM THE REAR SNAPBACK AND EXIT
PEOPLE EXIT AND HIT THE REAR
WINDSHIELD AND ARE KILLED.
SOMETIMES THEY SNAP BACK IN THE
HIT CHILDREN IN CAR SEATS IN THE
BACK ELEVEN THOUSAND DEATHS
BETWEEN 200-020-0015 OVER A
THOUSAND THEM WERE CHILDREN IN
CAR SEATS. COOPER TIRES THAT
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO HOLD THE
TWO FLIES TOGETHER WHICH
SEPARATE AND SHRED THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO DEATHS DOCUMENTED
BY A LAWYER. FLORIDA JEAN
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND TO THE FOR-
TWO ENGINEERS WROTE A LETTER TO
UPPER MANAGEMENT SAYING WHY
AREN'T WE DOING THESE VERY SAME
OLD TOOL. CLIENTS TO GATHER AND
UPPER MANAGEMENT SAID IS SIMPLY
TOO EXPENSIVE WE DON'T WANT TO
SPEND THE MONEY. QUESTION OF
MONEY UNFORTUNATELY FOR THE
WORST OF OUR PUBLIC COMPANIES.
ARE YOU SURE HAS HURT TENS AND
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF WOMEN
BECAUSE OF THE SHREDDING
SHRAPNEL THE I. U. D. THAT
CAUSES PAIN AND THE INABILITY TO
HAVE ORDINARY RELATIONS IN THE
WAY THAT IS NORMAL THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF CASES SETTLED
SECRETLY BECAUSE THE INFORMATION
WAS NOT KNOWN. I'VE GOT A SHEET
HERE THAT HAS TEN OTHER EXAMPLES
I CAN GIVE YOU FIVE OTHER
EXAMPLES I'M MORE KNOWS HOW MANY
THERE ARE THAT WE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE WORST MAYBE OXYCONTIN
AND STRIDE LIKE TO LOOK AT THE
REST OF THE TIME TO MISS AMY
COOPER TO SPEAK ABOUT HER OWN
PERSONAL CIRCUMSTANCES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU PRESS WAS COOPER
. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANNE
COOPER AND I AM THE MOTHER OF
JOHN GOTTLIEB. I'M HERE TO SHARE
HIS STORY FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
. BECAUSE OF THE MASSIVE. RIPPLE
EFFECT HIS LOSS HAD ON OUR
FAMILY AND OUR COMMUNITY. WE
WERE UNAWARE AND WE WERE ON
EDUCATED. ABOUT THE CONSEQUENCES
OF OXYCODONE. AND THE RESULT OF
HIS DEVASTATING AND PREVENTABLE
DEATH. AT AGE TWENTY SIX. JOHN
WAS MY FIRST BORN SON. HE HAD A
HUGE HEART AND FAMILY WAS THE
CENTER OF HIS LIFE AND HE LIVED
JUST BROTHERS AND A SISTER
IMMENSELY. AND I WANT YOU TO
KNOW HIM BECAUSE HE'S MORE THAN
A STATISTIC AND THERE'S A LOT OF
THEM OUT THERE NOW. HE WAS
OPERATIONS READER. AN ENTHUSIAST
OF ART AND LITERATURE AND MUSIC
YOU CAN FIND LISTENING TO
EVERYTHING FROM MOZART TO
METALLICA. HIS FAVORITE MUSICAL
THE SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX AND HE
LOVED TO COOK. AND HE LOVED TO
OUR FAMILY DINNERS THERE ARE A
LOT OF TIMES IT WAS LIKE
POLITICAL BANTER. AND THERE ARE
A LOT OF SIBLING ROCK BAND LATE
NIGHTS. AND PING PONG GARAGE
TURN IMMENSE. HE WAS PART OF HIS
HIGH SCHOOL ROTC. AND A MEMBER
OF THE MOCK TRIAL WHERE ACTUALLY
TODAY STILL A MEMORIAL PLAQUE
HANGS IN THE LOBBY AT THE SCHOOL
IN HONOR OF HIM. HE GRADUATED
FROM COLLEGE WITH A DEGREE IN
PHILOSOPHY AND RHETORIC FROM
THOMAS MORE COLLEGE AND BECAME
THE FOUNDER. AND CEO OF A START
UP COMPANY. AND FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE HE WAS LIVING HIS
BEST LIFE. HE HAD AN APARTMENT
HAD A PUPPY HAD A GIRLFRIEND.
AND IT WAS LIVING WHAT WE ALL
THINK OF THE SILICON VALLEY
DREAM. IN THE SUMMER OF TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN YOU JUST
FINISHED TAKING HAS ALL SETS AT
SANTA CLARA UNIVERSITY AND HAD
PLANS ACTUALLY GO TO LAW SCHOOL.
WHEN USING CALL PRESCRIBED OXY
CODEN. FOLLOWING A MOTORCYCLE
INCIDENT. AND WE BELIEVE THAT'S
WHAT TRIGGERED HIS FALL INTO
ADDICTION WHEN HE WAS IN COLLEGE
. WE LATER FOUND EVIDENCE
ACTUALLY THAT OXY CODE OWN WAS
PRESCRIBED FROM VARIOUS DOCTORS
IN VARIOUS STATES. ALL DURING
HIS COLLEGE YEARS. JOHN DID NOT
SHOW EVIDENCE OF SUBSTANCE
MISUSE AND THAT'S WHY WE WERE IN
COMPLETE SHOCK. WHEN MY PHONE
RANG. AND BY A CALL FROM THE SAN
JOSE POLICE LETTING ME KNOW THAT
MY BELOVED SON WAS DECEASED.
FIVE MONTHS BEFORE WE KNOW WHAT
ACTUALLY TOOK MY SIX FOOT FIVE.
VIBRANT BRILLIANT YOUNG MAN. WHO
WAS SITTING OUTSIDE ON HIS PATIO
. AND HE WAS FOUND BY HIS
GIRLFRIEND NO LONGER RESPONSIVE. THAT WAS ON JULY SEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. HE DIED OF
OVERDOSE. AND HE WAS PRESCRIBED
FIFTY SIX PILLS. OF OXY CODE ON
ON JULY FIRST. I'M JUST HERE TO
TELL YOU THAT WHEN A CHILD DIES
IT IS AN IMAGINABLE BUT WHEN
THEIR DEATH IS PREVENTABLE IT IS
TRAGIC BEYOND WORDS. I HOPE WITH
EDUCATION AND PREVENTION
SENSELESS DEATHS LIKE MY SONS
WILL STOP. AND THAT'S WHY. FOR
MY POSITION IN ADDITION TO MY
JOB EVERY DAY AND TACK I'M A
BOARD MEMBER OF A NON PROFIT AND
OUR MISSION IS TO PREVENT
DESCRIPTION DRUG ABUSE I
APOLOGIZE AND I AM DEEPLY SORRY
FOR YOUR LOSS IT'S UNIMAGINABLE
PAIN BUT ON CHANNEL WE HAVE
LIMIT CERTAIN TESTIMONY THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND SYSTEM THANK
YOU. BOB ALL RIGHT- OTHERS THAT
ARE ON THE PHONE OR EXCUSE ME
THOSE WHO ARE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED WHICH TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
IF YOU APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
AND GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
FILIATION AND YOUR POSITION. OF
SAYING NO ONE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED- GO INTO OKAY GO AHEAD
IF YOU IF YOU'RE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF. OF S. B.
ELEVEN FORTY NINE AND YOU'RE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
SENATORS I'M KIP MILLER I'M A
CIVIL RIGHTS AND I AM FIRMLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SAYING NO
ONE ELSE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE- IN ROOM TWELVE-
MODERATE WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE
ARM ON THE LINE WHICH THIS IS.
S. ONE OR NOT. YEAH LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AFTER TIME
THAT IS. ONE ZERO SIX. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HOW CAN
WE WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT FINE
LINE NUMBER FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. J. SOLOMON STANFORD
CENTER ON THE LEGAL PROFESSION
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL
THANKS. THANK YOU. BY NUMBER ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NUMBER. ONE TWENTY SEVEN. YOU
MIGHT HAVE A NEW. GLOBAL TO THE
NEXT FINE LINE NUMBER TWENTY
THREE YEAR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NUMBER ONE TWENTY THREE.
JENNINGS FROM THE DIRECTOR OF
CALPERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NICOLE YOUNG
PLASTER COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF THE
FELT. THANK YOU MY NUMBER. ONE
OH THREE. ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MY NUMBER TWENTY SIX PEOPLE HAD
. THIRTY THIRD ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THE RIVER BOTTOM LINE NUMBER
TWENTY NINE NUMBER TWENTY THEIR
OFFENSE. HI MY NAME IS DORIAN
CHEN I FEEL RECALLS THE COMFORT
THE CONSUMER REPORT HE ARE IS
PLEASED TO BE A CO SPONSOR AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AT ELEVEN
FORTY NINE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. MY NUMBER THIRTY FIVE ONE
NUMBER THIRTY FIVE. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS KNOWN AROUND ONE AND A
MEMBER OF THE STATE PARK
CONSTITUENTS SENATOR DROPPED
THOUGH AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE ALLIANCE FOR JUSTICE WE URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT AT ELEVEN FORTY
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU'RE INTO FOUR
HUNDRED ONE DAY ZERO. WITH A
BOTTOM LINE NUMBER ONE TWENTY
TWO- MEMBERS MARIE KARAOKE HARA
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ABOUT THREE MORE
INSTITUTE A FLIGHT NUMBER ONE
TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SURENDRA MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SHARON A LUNCHEON I MEAN
REPRESENTING JANE STREET BRADLEY
FOR U. S. SENATE. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU. Q.
RIGHT NUMBER FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. RIGHT IT IS AN INVALID
AND I AM STRONGLY SUPPORT ITSELF
. THANK YOU. IN OUR LAST
EARNINGS URUGUAY NUMBER ONE
TWENTY NINE. HELLO CRAIG BRISKIN
FROM PUBLIC JUSTICE WE ARE CO
SPONSOR THIS LEGISLATION AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL. YOU
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN Q.
MESSENGER. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
LET'S NOW TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION- I UNDERSTAND THERE
ARE TWO WITNESSES THAT ARE
PRESENT HERE IN OPPOSITION- MR
MOULTRIE AND MISS JOHNSON YES
MISTER THANK YOU ROBERT MOTRIN
TO HALF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND I WOULD
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT- MISTRANSLATION
SEJAK HAS BEEN POLITE ENOUGH TO
SEAT ME ONE OF HER TWO MINUTES-
SUCH TWENTY FIVE THAT FOR THE
SHERIFF FRONT. ALL RIGHT NOT AND
OTHER WORDS IS FOUR MINUTES IN
TOTALITY YES AND FOR ME I HAD
FOR THANK YOU. GOOD CHAIR
MEMBERS CENTER LEYVA AND- FELLOW
KNIFE- HASTINGS- FIRST I WOULD
HAVE LIKE THREE POINTS ON THIS
BILL I'LL START BY SAYING WE OF
COURSE ARE SYMPATHETIC TO THE
EXAMPLES ARE NOT HERE TO DEFEND
THOSE ARE CONCERNS ARE WITH THE
BUSINESSES WHO ARE OPERATING
PROPERLY AND IF NOT HAVE THESE
PROBLEMS BUT WOULD BE AFFECTED
BY THESE CHANGES TO EXISTING
LEGAL PROCEDURES. FIRST I WANT
TO FLY THE BREADTH OF HE BILL-
THE BILLS ARE FITTED REPEATEDLY
REFERRED TO AS PRODUCTS FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITIONS
ACTUALLY THE BILL IS NOT LIMITED
TO IN ADDITION TO SIMPLY SAYS
TIONS THAT CAUSE HARM SO WE
ACTUALLY VIEW THIS IS VIEW IT AS
AFFECTING POTENTIALLY THE
MAJORITY OF CIVIL CASES WITH
THESE CHANGES THE DISCOVERY
BECAUSE THAT LANGUAGE ISN'T.
ACTUALLY THE DEFINITION THE BILL
- A SECOND THE SUBTLE PROVISIONS
HERE ARE NOT THE BIGGEST CHANGE
TO THE BILL IN OUR MIND- BUT WE
CERTAINLY ARE OPPOSED TO
POLICIES THAT PROHIBIT PARTIES
FROM CONTRACTING TO DO THAT IF
THEY WOULD LIKE. AND BELIEVE
THAT MAY DISINCENTIVE I
SETTLEMENT LEAD TO MORE CASES
BEING FOUGHT TO TRIAL THAT ISN'T
THE BIGGEST CHANGE INOUR
READING. THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE THE CHANGE. PROCEDURES
PARTICULARLY PROTECTIVE ORDERS-
THAT THIS BILL CREATES THAT. THE
PROFESSOR MADE THE POINT
CORRECTLY DOES NOT. PROHIBIT THE
MAKRIS A STRONG PRESUMPTION
AGAINST PROTECTIVE ORDERS. AND
THAT'S A REALLY BIG DEAL FOR
SOME CONTEXT PROTECTIVE ORDERS
ARE REGULARLY USED IN
LITIGATION. WHEN THERE ARE
DOCUMENTS WHICH MAY OR MAY NOT
BE SOMETHING THE PARTIES
DISAGREE ABOUT TO FACILITATE THE
EXCHANGE I USE THE MY LITIGATED.
IT'S VERY COMMON BASICALLY
YOU'RE SAYING HEY. WE MAY NOT
AGREE ON WHERE THESE ARE PUBLIC.
BUT LET'S PUT THAT ASIDE AND
COME TO THE COURT IF WE HAVE TO
AND LET'S EXCHANGE NOW. AND WE
WILL PROVIDE ABOUT THAT FOR THE
COURT SUBSEQUENTLY PURSUANT TO
THIS ORDER IF IT COMES UP. THE
FACILITY DISCOVERY I USE THEM IN
CIVIL RIGHTS CASES RELATED TO
POLICE POLICIES. WE MIGHT SAY WE
DON'T WANT TO GIVE YOU THE
POLICY ON HOW THE POLICE CLEAR
AN ARMED ROOM. THAT COULD BE
DANGEROUS TO POLICE CAN GIVE IT
TO UNDER PROTECTIVE ORDER. AND
THEN WE CAN DEAL WITH THAT IF
YOU WANT TO MAKE IT PUBLIC
LATER. SO THESE ARE NORMAL
DISCOVERY PRACTICES PRACTICED IN
IN. THE I WOULDN'T SAY THE
MAJORITY BUT OF. A VERY
SUBSTANTIAL CHUNK OF CIVIL
CASES. WE HAVE GREAT CONCERN
ABOUT CREATING A PRESUMPTION
AGAINST THEM. FOR PERSONAL.
PERFECTLY PROPER USES- FIVE
BRIEFLY TO- BRIEFLY TOUCH ON-
ONE OF FRANCE'S ACTIONS COMMENTS
WHICH WAS ABOUT THE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE FACTS OF THE CASE WE
ALSO SOME SOME CONCERNS THAT THE
LANGUAGE WHICH IS USED IN THE
BILL DOES NOT LIMIT ITSELF TO
SAY FOR EXAMPLE THE DEFECT OR
THE HOUSE PUBLIC THAT LANGUAGE
OF INFORMATION ABOUT THE FACTS
OF THE CASE IN OUR MIND IS MUCH
BROADER AND TOUCHES ON JUST
ABOUT EVERYTHING COVERED IN
DISCOVERY WHICH IS ALL ATTORNEYS
WOULD KNOW IS MUCHBROADER THAN
IN FACT THE CORE ELEMENTS OF THE
CASE OR EVEN WHAT'S MISCIBLE
TRIAL- THOSE ARE CONCERNS AND I
WANT TO BEGIN THANK- FORTY FROM
C. JACK FOR GIVING ME THE ONE
MINUTE. THANK YOU SINCE MISTER
KAREN MEMBERS GORDON JOHNSON
WITH FERNANDES RUNS GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS SAY ON BEHALF OF C. JACK
ADDRESSING THE COMMITTEE WITH
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE
IMPACT SB ELEVEN FORTY NINE
WOULD HAVE ON THE INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY RIGHTS OF CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES AND CONSUMERS ABILITY
TO SETTLE CLAIMS IN AN EFFICIENT
COST EFFECTIVE MANNER UNDER S.
B. ELEVEN FORTY NINE ANY
INFORMATION CONCERNING AN
ALLEGED PRODUCT FACT OR HAZARD
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE
INFORMATION IS RELEVANT TO THE
ACTION IS PRESUMED PUBLIC. WE'LL
SEE BUSINESSES PUT IN THE
POSITION OF SETTLING FRIVOLOUS
CLAIMS TO AVOID THE
DISSEMINATION OF PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION ENCOURAGING MORE
DEMANDS OUTSIDE THE EYES OF THE
COURT WHERE THERE IS NO
ACCOUNTABILITY THE FUNCTIONAL
IMPACT OF THIS BILL WILL BE IT
TO PENALIZE A BUSINESS BY
SUBJECTING THEM TO INFORMATION
SHARING PRIOR TO EVIDENCE EVER
BEING PRESENTED OR SUBSTANTIATED
IN COURT ANOTHER HUGE CONCERN
WITH THIS BILL IS WHO CAN
INTERFACE INTERVENE IN THE
ACTION EVEN IF THE PARTIES TO
LITIGATION AGREED
CONFIDENTIALITY AND ANYONE
ACTING ON BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC
THE MEDIA YOUTUBER OR ANYONE
WITH AN AXE TO GRIND CAN CAN
INTERVENE. AND IN THE LITIGATION
AND DEMAND PUBLIC DISCLOSURE OF
THE BUSINESSES INFORMATION FOR
THESE REASONS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT OTHERS IN OPPOSITION HERE
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED FEET
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE UP IF
THERE'S OTHERS IF YOU TO QUEUE
UP GO AHEAD SIR THANK YOU
FEELING GRIEVES WITH OUTCOME
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF FOR FIFTEEN
HUNDRED MEMBER AT LIFE SCIENCE
MEMBER COMPANIES RESPECTFULLY
POST THANK. OTHERS HERE IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED SEEING NONE ARE
LISTED IN THE FALL THIS MODERATE
IF YOU TO HELP THOSE IN
OPPOSITION. THE GENTLEMAN IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION IT IS FOUR ONE
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. OPPOSITION
ONE ZERO WE DO HAVE ONE CURING
UP IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT. WE
WILL GO NOW TO THE LINE. EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
GIVING GONZALEZ ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN IN
OPPOSITION OF ONE THEN ZERO. E
DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY QUEUING UP
MR ALL RIGHT OF IF THERE'S NO
ONE ON THE PHONE LINE LET'S TURN
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
ASSEMBLY KOWSKI. I'M A- I HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH. THE ARCHITECTURE
OF THE BILL I FOR THE LIFE OF ME
DON'T UNDERSTAND ON PARAGRAPH
PAGE FOUR PARAGRAPH TWO WHAT WE
PUT DEFECTIVE PRODUCTS
ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITION TOGETHER
THOSE ARE TWO DIFFERENT THINGS.
I AT THAT THIS ME. WELL I HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH HER NOT TO LET THIS
BILL DIE TODAY BUT I'M NOT I
DON'T FEEL LIKE I WANT TO
SUPPORT IT BECAUSE- BECAUSE THE
YOUR WITNESS GAVE US. LOTS OF.
EXAMPLES OF DEFECTIVE PRODUCTS.
WE'VE IN THE IN YOUR TESTIMONY
TALKED ABOUT HAZARDOUS
ENVIRONMENTAL WELL THAT'S NOT
THE TEXT IT DIDN'T FIX IT THAT'S
NOT THE TEXT BEFORE MISTRESS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL. CONDITIONS IN THE
SUPPORTERS EACH OF THEM PUBLIC
JUSTICE TALK ABOUT TALK ABOUT
PUBLIC HAZARDOUS SECRETS THE
TALK ABOUT THE CONSUMER-
ATTORNEYS TALK ABOUT HAZARDS THE
EVEN THE CONSUMER PORTS TOUCH
BUT TOXIC HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS
IT'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN AN
ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARD WHICH I
FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITION. THAT
MAY IMPOSE EVERYTHING BECAUSE IT
SEEMS TO ME IT'S TOO LOW FOR
MAKING CALLS EVERYTHING VERSUS A
DEFECTIVE PRODUCT IS A DEFECTIVE
PRODUCT. IS DEFECTIVE AND CAUSES
HARM VERSUS ACT AND HAZARD I CAN
SEE THAT SO THAT'S MY CONCERN ON
THAT USE OF JUST A SUCH A LOW
BAR AND MUSHING THEM ALTOGETHER.
SO FAIR ENOUGH IS IT JUST
SEMANTICS FOR YOU WE KNOW
THERE'S HAZARDOUS ENVIRONMENT
HAS JUST MEANS SOMETHING
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENTAL
CONDITIONS YEAH THERE'S A DIFF
THOSE IN THE FIELD KNOW THAT AND
I ASSUME THE PEOPLE PUT TO SEE
GATHERED NO THAT ALSO IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE IT'S NOT. IT'S BRING
IN TOO MANY. WE ARE A LOT INVITE
HAPPY CONDITIONS IN THE STATE
WHICH ARE THERE I'M MORE WORRIED
ABOUT THE HAZARDS THAT ARE THERE
VERSUS A CONDITION SIMILAR
PROFESSORS AT TRON- ADDRESS THAT
BUT I WOULD JUST SAY THIS. JUST
BECAUSE I DIDN'T MENTION IT IN
MY TESTIMONY DOESN'T MEAN IT'S
STILL CONCERNED DOESN'T MEAN
THAT HOUSE URGED AREN'T STILL
THERE WITH THE ENVIRONMENT AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITIONS IF YOUR
CONCERN IS THAT THE BILL'S
OVERLY BROAD. WE CAN TALK ABOUT
THAT. OKAY DID ANYTHING
PROFESSOR YOUR SON IN MY LITTLE
SHEET THAT I WHIPPED AROUND BUT-
AND I WHILE CALDERON WAS SEVERAL
SHEETS THERE WERE SEVERAL ON.
I'M SORRY DR PASSER YOU'RE FINE
. OKAY OKAY. I DON'T WANT TO
MESS UP PROTOCOL. THE HEAD
PROFESSOR SYNAPTICS PROFESSOR
YOU DON'T WANT TO MESS UP
PROGRAM- THERE ARE SEVERAL
ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARDS THAT. ARE
PART OF THE LITANY OF THESE-
SECRET SITUATIONS I DID. HAVE
CORRESPONDENCE WITH YOUR STAFF
MEMBER HEATHER WITH REGARD TO
THE USE OF THE WORD CONDITION
VERSUS HAZARD. AND I KNOW THAT
THERE WERE PREVIOUS DRAFTS OF
ITERATIONS OF THESE- BILLS THAT
USED THE WORD HAZARD I
PERSONALLY HAVE. I TAKE YOUR
POINT I PERSONALLY HAVE NO
PROBLEM. WITH THE WORD HAZARD
BEING INSERTED FOR THE WORD
CONDITION AND- THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT SENATE DELAY FROM HER STAFF
AND I WILL BE. HAPPY TO DISCUSS
WORK WITH YOU ON I DO HAVE ARE
YOU HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH YOUR
POINT. AND I HAVE NO PROBLEM
WITH YOUR WORK CHANGE FOR ME
PERSONALLY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
PROFESSOR ARE YOU- CENTERS WITH
THOSE THAT ARE WITH US FINISHED.
THERE ARE SINISTER. THANK YOU
MISTER I SOLD ALL THE TAIL THEN
BECAUSE I'M HAVE A CONCERN WITH
THAT- DEPENDING ON HOW THE
PROFESSOR THE AUTHOR- ANSWER BUT
- I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE
APPLICABILITY THERE IS A THERE'S
A SECRET SETTLEMENT ON THE
LEASE- CANYON GLASS GAS BLOWOUT
HAS VERY EXCITED SEE THIS BILL
BUILDING ON YOUR PAST EFFORTS.
AND THAT SORT OF WHAT CLOSER
SECRECY DUE TO STALL PROGRESS.
THIS IS A TWO BILLION DOLLAR
SETTLEMENT COME OUT WHERE THE
GAS COMPANY ADMITTED NO
WRONGDOING BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY-
DIDN'T ADDRESS ANY OF THE NON
DISCLOSURES OF ENVIRONMENTAL
CONDITIONS ALL THE INSPECTIONS
ALL THE SORT OF HISTORY THERE.
AND THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION IS GOING TO
REGULATORY PROCESS WHERE THEY'RE
TRYING TO ASSESS WHETHER THEY
SHOULD FINE OR NOT AWARE THERE
WAS. MISCONDUCT OR NOT. AND IF
THEY HAVE NO THAT THAT THAT
LITIGATION IN THE CLASS ACTIONS
THAT IS COMPLETELY USELESS TO
THEM. AND THE RECORD IS
COMPLETELY OPAQUE. AND THEY'RE
STILL FIGHTING. NOW HOW MANY
LATER EIGHT YEARS LATER WITH THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION NOT
DISCLOSING ANY OF THAT
INFORMATION. SO MIKE MY QUESTION
IS- WHAT DO YOU THINK THIS BILL
ENCOMPASSES THAT KIND OF
SETTLEMENT WHERE. YOU KNOW I
KNOW IT'S A IT'S BEEN IT IS THE
NATURE OF THE LITIGATION WAS
ABOUT HEALTH RISK RIGHT PEOPLE
BEING INJURED BY THAT THAT GAS
BLOWOUT. BUT I JUST DON'T I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT ENVIRONMENTAL
CONDITION QUOTE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONDITION THAT POSES A DANGER TO
PUBLIC HEALTH OR SAFETY. IS
INCLUSIVE AND THAT IF YOU ARE
GOING TO MAKE ANY CHANGES JUST
THAT WE DON'T BOX OUT THOSE
KINDS OF BIG SORT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL TORT. CASES SO
THANK YOU CENTERS ARE WE WOULD
NOT WANT TO DO THAT I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THAT SPECIFIC CASE I AM
AWARE OF IT. BUT THIS BILL MY
INTENTION IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
COMPANIES LIKE THAT CAN'T HIDE
THAT WHY DID THAT HAPPEN WHY DID
THE EXPLOSION HAPPEN SO THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN AND KILL
MORE PEOPLE PROFESSOR DID YOU
WANT TO ADD ANYTHING BECAUSE OUR
OUR GREECE ARE VERY CLEARLY THE
INTENT OF THE BILL IS TO
INCLUDE. THAT I DON'T THINK THE
WORD HACER DETRACTS FROM OKAY
FROM THIS SITUATION- AND I THINK
THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT IS CLEAR
TO INCLUDE EXACTLY THAT THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENED OXYCONTIN THE FDA
WAS TRYING TO REGULATE
OXYCONTIN. BUT THEY COULDN'T GET
THE INFORMATION EXACTLY THE SAME
RIGHT ALL THAT DEPOSITION
TESTIMONY BUT THE BUT THE OTHER
POINT I JUST WANNA MAKE CLEAR
BECAUSE I HAVE HEARD FROM THE
FROM THE OPPOSITION I DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE CHAIRS WORK
ESPECIALLY ON. CLARIFYING SORT
OF THE WHAT WHAT ISN'T SUBJECT
TO THE DISCLOSRE- AS WELL AS
THE PRESUMPTION PROCESS RIGHT
YOU COULD STILL ACTUALLY
CHALLENGE THE DISCLOSURE IN
COURT IT'S NOT AT. NOT JUST
DOESN'T JUST OPEN THE DOOR IT IT
IT PUTS A THUMB ON THE SCALE BUT
THEY COULD STILL FIGHT SOME
DISCLOSURE IN AND THE COURT
WOULD HAVE TO EVALUATE THAT BUT
JUST TO. TO BE SURE THAT- THAT
WE ARE. THAT WE'RE CAN. THE
RIGHT ACTION HERE AND THAT WE'RE
NOT- YEAH THEY WERE NOT SOMEHOW
ARBITRARILY EXCLUDING CERTAIN
CLASSES OF ACTION BUT IT SOUNDS
LIKE IT'S INCLUSIVE MAYBE ALL
LOOK INTO A GOING FORWARD JUST
PROVIDE SOME ASSURANCE ON THAT
FRONT- BUT I THINK IF I THINK
I'M COMFORTABLE VOTING ON THE
BILL- IN THE AMENDED FORM SO.
BRING IT FORWARD AND HONESTLY IF
YOU KEEP IT STRONG LIKE IT IS
I'D LOVE TO BE AT IS A CO AUTHOR
TO THE SENATE THANK YOU. SENATE
COVER YEAR THAN CENTER LAYER.
THANKS VERY MUCH- SO THERE'S A
COUPLE OF THINGS AND I HAVE A
QUESTION I. TELL YOU IT MIGHT MY
CONCERNS ARE. RIGHT AND I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
HERE THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
IT'S JUST A QUESTION OF BEING
ABLE TO GET IT RIGHT- I'M
CONCERNED WITH THE SAME ISSUE
THAT CENTER RIGHT HOUSE KEY-
RAISED ABOUT- THE USE OF. I
THINK IT'S TOO BROAD I THINK YOU
ASKED THAT QUESTION I THINK
THAT'S TRUE NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TWO IS- THE- WHO CAN. ASK OR
REQUIRE THE INFORMATION I THINK
IT'S TOO BROAD AS WELL- AND I'M
WILLING TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
ABOUT THAT BUT BUT THE THIRD
THING IN AND I'M I MAY BE
SPEAKING- FOR PART OF THE
COMMUNITY THAT. THAT IS
OBJECTING- AT THE END I MAY HAVE
IT WRONG. BUT SO USING THE
OXYCONTIN EXAMPLE- THE IT WAS IT
WAS LITIGATION BETWEEN THAT
PRODUCERS OF THE PROJECT- AND
THOSE THAT HAD BEEN HURT RIGHT.
BUT THERE WERE BUT THERE WERE.
OTHER PARTIES THAT HAD TO MAKE
THAT. PARTICULAR DRUG AVAILABLE
LIKE DOCTORS AND HOSPITALS AND-
AND IN THAT PART AND SO- WOULD
IT YOUR BILL REQUIRE THE
DISCLOSURE AND I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE THOSE AT
OVERPRESCRIBED BECAUSE THAT
THAT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT ISSUE
RIGHT- THE MILLS THAT STARTED
CHURNING OUT- HILLS FOR ANYBODY
BUT- PRESCRIPTIONS FOR ANYBODY
THAT WANTED HIM OUT TALK ABOUT
THOSE I'M TALKING ABOUT- THIRD
PARTIES THAT MAY HAVE BEEN PART
OF THE- OF THE- THE SALE IN THE
PURCHASE OF THE PROJECT. BUT
DIDN'T PRODUCE IT NECESSARILY
WORK WERE ACCEPTING THE- THE
ASSURANCES OF THAT OF THE-
MANUFACTURE THAT IT WAS A GOOD
PRODUCT AND IT SERVED ITS
PURPOSE WHICH LATER ENDED UP NOT
BEING TRUE CORRECT EVAN LOW
PROFESSOR OF SOFT BETTER ANSWER
BUT WHAT I WOULD JUST SAY IS
THIS WE WANT TO HOLD EVERYONE
RESPONSIBLE AND WHAT I'VE HEARD
FROM DOCTORS- SINCE WE DISCOVER
THE OXY CODE IN AN OXYCONTIN
WERE SO ADDICTIVE. IT WAS NOT
THE WAY IT WAS SOLD TO THEM IT'S
NOT WHAT THEY WERE TROUBLED BY
THE MANUFACTURER RIGHT IF THIS
BILL IS SIGNED INTO LAW AND
THESE COMPANIES SEE THAT THEY'RE
GONNA BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR LIES THEN MY HOPE WOULD BE
IS THEY WOULDN'T LIE TO OTHER
PEOPLE DOCTORS WITH THIS CASE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT DRUGS SO I
THINK RIGHT NOW INPUT- COMPANIES
DRUG COMPANIES ANY COMPANY.
THEY'RE NOT TOO WORRIED THEY
KNOW THAT THEY CAN GO TO COURT
AND THEY CAN GET THIS
INFORMATION SEALED AND THAT WE
WON'T KNOW WHAT THEIR PRODUCT
CAN ACTUALLY DO TO SOMEONE BUT
ONCE THEY KNOW THAT THEY'RE
GONNA BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE I
THINK WE CAN SEE CHANGE BUT
PROFESSOR AND IF THERE'S
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO ADD. WELL
I AGREE WITH THAT I'M JUST
TRYING TO EXTRAPOLATE TED THEIR
CONCERN IS THAT THEY DON'T GET
LOOPED IN ON SOMETHING THAT THEY
HAD NO THAT'S RIGHT YOU KNOW-
BUT THEY DIDN'T PRODUCE THE
PRODUCT IS SO THAT IF YOU'VE GOT
AN ANSWER THAT I DO SO THE
HISTORY. WILL ACTUALLY COTTON IS
AT THE STATE OF WEST GENUSS THE-
PADUCAH. TO TWO AND THOUSAND
FOUR THAT CASE WAS SETTLED. AND
IT WAS SETTLED BUT- APPARENTLY
FOR A GREAT DEAL OF MONEY BUT
THE JUDGE INVOLVED IN THAT CASE
CREATED A PROTECTIVE ORDER. SO
THAT NONE OF THE TROOPS OF THE
OVER PRESCRIPTION OVER ADDICTIVE
PROPERTIES. AND THE RATCHETING
UP OF THE DOSAGES CAME OUT TO
THE PUBLIC AS A RESULT FROM TWO
THOUSAND FOUR TO AT LEAST TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN ANOTHER TWELVE
YEARS. UNTIL INFORMATION WAS
RELEASED TO THEM TO THE L. A.
TIMES. DOCTORS INNOCENT DOCTORS
ARE SEEING PATIENTS WHO DIDN'T
KNOW ABOUT THIS WHO DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND THAT THESE THINGS
WERE BEING GROSSLY
OVERPRESCRIBED AND WE'RE GROSSLY
ADDICTIVE. LATER ON A JUDGE A
FEDERAL JUDGE IN CLEVELAND OHIO
AT TWO THOUSAND INDIVIDUAL CASES
IN FRONT OF HIM. AND HE CREATED
UMBRELLA PROTECTIVE ORDER A
COMPLETE CONE OF SILENCE SO
AGAIN. THE PUBLIC HAD NOT NO
IDEA WHATSOEVER. FTA WHICH WAS
TRYING TO INVESTIGATE THIS IS A
POINT THAT- STERN RIGHT FTA WAS
SHUT OUT OF THE PROCESS THEY
COULDN'T INVESTIGATE. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE DOCTORS THE GOOD
HONEST MY PARENTS FOR DOCTORS
THE GOOD HONEST DOCTORS REACHES
95% OF THEM OUT THERE. JUST
SIMPLY DIDN'T KNOW THAT THE
OXYCONTIN WASN'T WORKING AND
THEY BOUGHT INTO. TO PRODUCE
SPIEL BECAUSE THIS JUDGE IN
CLEVELAND FRANKLY HAD KEPT TWO
THOUSAND CASES SECRET ALONG WITH
MANY MANY OTHERS. SO IN A REAL.
SENSE SENATOR CARILLO. THE WERE
. TO ANOTHER A FIELD DOCTORS AND
DR LIKE THE DOCK THAT THE- MISC
TELL YOU ABOUT THAT. HELP COME
SON BUT TO DIE. FOR IN BY THE BY
THE LANGUAGE BECAUSE NONE OF
THIS SHOULD COME OUT INTO THE
OPEN AND THEY SIMPLY THANK YOU
PROFESSOR. I'M SORRY THANKS
THANKS OKAY ASCETICAL EURO IS
THE QUESTIONS THAT THE ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION- WELL I JUST I'M
I'M I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE BILL DOESN'T END UP.
LOOPING IN YES AS YOU SAID-
DOCTORS WHO HAD NO CLUE NO HAN
WHO WERE NOT A PRIVY TO THAT
INFORMATION AND THAT SOMEHOW
THEY END UP. AT THAT THEIR THEIR
NAMES IN THE INFORMATION- ABOUT
THE- M. GET UP IN IN THE NINE
TO. SO I HEAR YOU WE WILL LOOK
AT THAT BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
THAT EITHER THAT IS NOT THE
INTENTION OF THE BILL BUT WILL
LOOK AT IT AND SEE IF THERE'S A
WAY THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
THAT DOESN'T HELP THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT NOT A PROBLEM.
OTHER QUESTIONS CONCERNS- YEAH
CENTER LAYER. THANK YOU I THINK
SOME OF THE- CONVERSATION HAS
PASSED. OR WHERE I WAS BUT- A
INITIALLY. I ACTUALLY THOUGHT
THERE WAS A DISCONNECT- WITH
CENTER WHITE HOUSE SKIS CONCERN
ON YOURS BECAUSE I THINK HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT OVERLY BROAD AND
YOU THOUGHT THAT ONE WORD WAS
GONNA DRESS IS OVERLY BROAD I
DON'T THINK IT DOES. A. N. N.
AND SO I THINK IT GETS
SYNTHESIZED MAYBE I WOULD SAY
GIVEN ALL THE DISCUSSION. THAT
THIS BILL ADDRESSES A PROBLEM
THAT WAS REALLY EMPLOYEE. YOU
KNOW DEMONSTRATED AND I SUSPECT
WE ALL REALLY WANTED TO BE
ADDRESSED. AND THEN THERE'S A
PROCESS AND THERE'S A QUESTION
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THE PROCESS
ACT ADEQUATELY ADDRESSES A
PROBLEM AND THEN THERE'S A
QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER THERE'S
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. AND THE
PROCESSES IT AND SO I'M WITH THE
GROUP THAT- I WANT TO GIVE YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THIS.
BUT I JUST HOPE THERE'S NOT
KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT THOSE ARE
THE ISSUES IT AND THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT HAVE TO BE ASKED. IN
A CLEAR WAY TO MAKE SURE AS THIS
MOVES OR COMES BACK THAT IT IT
DOES ALL THAT IN IT AND THIS
BILL WAS SO BIG BECAUSE IT
ADDRESSES SUCH A BIG PROBLEM.
THAT WHETHER IT'S DISCOVERY OR
FOR OTHER THINGS IT HAS THE
POSSIBILITY REALLY ROPING A LOT
OF THINGS IN HERE AND SO. I'M
JUST HOPING THAT MAYBE IT WAS
SOME OF THE SENATORS THAT MADE
COMMENT YOU'LL GROUND TROOPS
THIS IN A WAY THAT AND WILL
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES IT AND THAT
LEADS TO. THE POINT THAT YES-
IT'S SUCH A BIG PROBLEM THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED I'M GONNA
VOTE TO MOVE THE BILL FORWARD IN
THE HOPES THAT YOU WILL BE ABLE
ABSOLUTELY. YES ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU- THANK YOU CENTER LIVER FOR
WORKING WITH US ALSO ON SOME
CLARIFICATION- AND IT. THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT POLICY HAS TO BE AT
ACTUALLY- INTERPRETED AND THE
POTENTIALLY ENFORCED BY A JUDGE
AND SO ONE OF OUR CHALLENGES
MAKE SURE IT'S CLEAR ENOUGH FOR.
THE JUDGE TO BE ABLE TO.
PROPERLY INTERPRET THIS IS A
QUESTION I AND I DAHLE DIRECTED
TO USE OUR LEYVA BUT MY GUESS IS
THAT- PROFESSORS IT TURNS
PROBABLY GOING TO WANT TO TAKE
IT. SO I'M LOOKING AT PAGE FIVE
AND I'M LOOKING AT THE
PRESUMPTION THAT SAYS. THE PARTY
REQUESTING THE ORDER
DEMONSTRATES THAT THE
PRESUMPTION IN FAVOR OF
DISCLOSURES CLEARLY OUTWEIGHED
IF YOU RECOGNIZE THAT. BOB I
ASSUME THAT THIS IS A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION RIGHT. RIGHT AND
IT'S REMARKABLE BY A
PREPONDERANCE OF EVIDENCE.
BECAUSE THE LANGUAGE IS NOT
CUSTOMARY LANGUAGE. WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO ANSWER SOME YES
PLEASE YES ARE THE WAITING
PROCESS IS DEFINED AS. ARE
CLEARLY OUTWEIGH IT IT'S NOT
UNCOMMON FOR LEGISLATION TO HAVE
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T SPECIFY
CURRENT CONVINCING EVIDENCE IS
SUPPOSED TO A PREPONDERANCE OF
EVIDENCE AS OPPOSED TO PROVE
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT THIS
RESERVE IT'S CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE THAT USES
THE WERE WERE CLEARLY OUTWEIGHED
BUT THE POINT IS THAT THE
PHRASE. ORDINARILY IN THE
LEGISLATION THAT I HAVE READ AT
LEAST- PUTTING IN A BURDEN OF
PROOF WOULD NOT BE APPROPRIATE
IN THIS SITUATION RATHER THE
PHRASE CLEARLY OUTWEIGHED GIVES
THE JUDGE GARDENS IS THE
INFORMATION THAT SOUGHT TO BE
PROTECTED CLEARLY OUT MORE.
CLEARLY OUTWEIGHS THE PUBLIC
INTEREST IN THE IN THE INSTANCE
OF HOW YOU CREATE AN IPHONE THE
ANSWER IS GOING TO BE US IN THE
ANSWER AND THE INSTANT SUPPORT
YOUR PROTECT SOMETHING THAT'S
DEFECTIVE HATCH IS GOING TO BE
NOW. BUT THE OUTWEIGHED WORD
MEANS THE JUDICIAL DISCRETION IS
GOING TO BE EXERCISED BY EACH
INDIVIDUAL JUDGE TO SAY BASED ON
WHAT I'VE HEARD. IS YOU
SUBMITTED TO ME COUNSEL YOUR
ARGUMENTS I'D THE JUDGE BELIEVES
THAT IT HAS OR HAS NOT BEEN
CLEARLY OUTWEIGHED SO FIRST LET
ME SURE CUT YOU OFF. YEARS WORTH
. MY EXPERIENCE IS THEJUDGES
ACTUALLY LIKE US TO DEFINE THE
EVIDENTIARY STANDARD THAT
THEY'RE IN REQUIRED TO. EMPLOY
IN THE T'S WHY
QUESTION AND I ASSUME THAT IT'S
A REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION THAT
CAN BE OVERCOME BY A
PREPONDERANCE ALTHOUGH THAT THE
USING THE PREPONDERANCE STANDARD
THAT THE COURT THE NEEDS TO LOOK
TO SEE. IF IT'S CLEARLY
OUTWEIGHED BY SPECIFIC AND
SUBSTANTIAL OVERRIDING
CONFIDENTIALITY INTERESTS SO I'M
THAT'S THAT'S ALL I'M
INTERPRETING IT AND I SUPPOSE
WHEN SOMEBODY LOOKS BACK AT THE
LEGISLATIVE. HISTORY THEY'LL
HEAR THOSE COMMENTS SO THAT'S
THAT'S POINT ONE. POINT TWO IS
THAT- AND IT WAS MY SUGGESTION
CONCERNED I THINK THAT YOU- AT
LEAST INDIRECTLY ADDRESSED THAT
CONCERN THE CONCERN IS THAT. IF
THERE IS A THIRD PARTY WHO IS
SUBPOENAED FOR INFORMATION FOR
EXAMPLE A DOWNSTREAM SUPPLIER
AND UPSTREAM SUPPLIER OF
CERTAIN- INFORMATION THAT THEY
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY AND I WE'VE
WE'VE MENTIONED ANALYSIS BUT
THEY HAVE A- AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO. OBJECT AND THAT THAT
THAT THAT THAT THAT POINT IN
TIME I'M NOT SURE THAT THE-
STANDARD SHOULD APPLY TO THEM
THEY'RE NOT A PART OF THE
LITIGATION BUT THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PROTECT OUR OWN
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY- IF THE
COURT SO FINDS THAT THAT- IT IS
IN THE PUBLIC'S INTEREST TO
PROTECT. OTHERS NOW THIS BILL
CREE IT'S THIS INTEREST.
PHILOSOPHIC CHALLENGE FOR US THE
CHEN. THAT SOMEBODY'S GOING TO
PAY THE PRICE FOR THE BILL
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO PAY THE
PRICE WE'RE GONNA BE INDIVIDUAL-
PLAINTIFFS INDIVIDUAL PLAINTIFFS
WHO COULD REACH- AND SETTLE THE
MATTER IN A MUCH MUCH MUCH
HIGHER LEVEL. THAN THEY MIGHT
OTHERWISE BY FORGOING THAT
RIGHT. OR FOREGOING THAT
OPPORTUNITY KEEP THE SETTLEMENT
CONFIDENTIAL. NOT MY JOB NOT MY
JOB TO FIGURE OUT- THAT MY JOB
IS TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S BEST
PUBLIC POLICY IN HIS DISCLOSURE
AND TRANSPARENCY BETTER PUBLIC
POLICY I THINK IT IS BETTER
PUBLIC POLICY. BUT BUT WE SHOULD
BE MINDFUL THAT THAT IT'S NOT
FREE THAT SOMEBODY'S GIVING UP-
AN OPPORTUNITY HERE TO A HIGHER
SETTLEMENT SALT- HAVING SAID
THAT- IT IF I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WANT TO RESPOND ANY THAT
pSENATORS I KNOW YOU'VE GOT A
LONG AGENDA. THAT'S HUSH MONEY
AND IN FACT THERE WILL BE HARSH
MONEY BUT IT'S INTERESTING THAT
WE HAVE THE VERY STRONG
SUPPORTER CA OC. AND THEY'RE THE
ONES TO REPRESENT US LIKE THIS.
WITH RESPECT TO THE ISSUE OF
THIRD PARTIES I PROVIDED
CHRISTIAN WITH TWO DIFFERENT
VERSIONS OF LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
CORRECT THAT. DISCUSSED IT WAS
SENATOR LABOR WE ALL AGREE THAT
IT IT IT IS WORTHY OF. BEING PUT
INTO THE BILL CHRISTIAN SENT ME
AN EMAIL LAST NIGHT SAYING HE
PREFERRED ONE OVER THE OTHER I'M
NOT SURE WHICH ONE. BUT CLEARLY
THAT NEEDS TO BE. TAPPED A-
LITTLE LOOPHOLE NEEDS TO BE. A
FIX AS TO THE BURDEN OF PROOF
IT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
CAN BE THE PRODUCT OF ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS ARE. WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING IT INTERNALLY ARE
CAMILLE AND I'VE BEEN DISCUSSING
IT A LOT. THE CENTERS STAFFERS
FROM DISCUSSING AND WE OUGHT TO
MAKE SURE IF YOU THINK SOMETHING
NEEDS TO BE CLARIFIED ME MAKE IT
MORE CLEAR THAN. WE CAN MAKE
MONTHLY RIGHT. WE OUGHT TO DO IT
HERE THAN HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT TO IT SO THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT ANSWER
REASONABLE RIGHT. RIGHT SO
CENTER LEYVA- THIS THERE BEEN IN
MOTION. MOST SINISTER MOST THE
BILL- WHICH I CLOSE I WOULD LIKE
TO CARS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR ALL OF YOUR
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. I AM NOT A LAWYER
BUT I BROUGHT ONE WITH ME AND
ALL OF YOU ARE LAWYERS AND SO
YOU WORRY ABOUT THE DETAILS. I'M
A PERSON WHOSE PASSION ABOUT
KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE. ABOUT
COMPANIES THAT DESIGN PRODUCTS
OR THEY CREATE SITUATIONS WHERE
PEOPLE ARE EITHER. HARMED OR
KILLED AND THIS BILL IS SIMPLY
ABOUT KNOWLEDGE THIS IS ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT YOU AS AN
INFORMED CONSUMER. CAN MAKE THE
DECISION THAT IS RIGHT FOR YOU
AND YOUR FAMILY. THE COFFEE THAT
YOU'RE DRINKING. IF THAT COFFEE
COMPANIES HAD PROBLEMS AND MAYBE
THEY PLEASANT PEOPLE YOU WOULD
PROBABLY WANT TO KNOW THAT. SO
IN CLOSING WHAT I WILL SAY IS.
THIS BILL WILL DO THREE THINGS
ONE IT WILL CREATE A PRESUMPTION
. PROHIBITED UNLESS THE COURT
FINDS THAT THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
INDICATED INTEREST INTEREST
INDEX DISCLOSURE IS CLEARLY
OUTWEIGHED BY SPECIFIC AND
SUBSTANTIAL NEED FOR SECRECY
WHAT WE JUST DISCUSSED. TWO IT
WILL PROHIBIT SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS THAT RESTRICT THE
DISCLOSURE OF INFORMATION ABOUT
A DEFECTIVE PRODUCT OR
ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITION. THAT
POSES A DANGER TO THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND MAKE ANY PROVISION IN
AN AGREEMENT VOID. AS AGAINST
PUBLIC POLICY AND THUS AND
FORCIBLE WE WILL WORK ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PART SENATOR
AKOWSKI. THREE IT NARROWLY
TAILORS ITS APPLICATION TO ONLY
INFORMATION ABOUT A DANGER. TO
PUBLIC HEALTH OR SAFETY. THAT IS
LIKELY TO CAUSE SIGNIFICANT OR
SUBSTANTIAL POTTERY BODILY
INJURY. OR ILLNESS OR DEATH THIS
IS ABOUT KNOWLEDGE AND SPOT P.
KEEPING PEOPLE CONSUMERS SAFE.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SAID
EARLIER- MINUTE CHIEF COUNSEL IF
YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
SB ELEVEN FORTY NINE BY SENATOR
LEYVA WITH THE MOTION BY SENATOR
STERN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AMBERG HI I'M BURGER AYE
BOARD. CAREER DID I SELL THE
REST SO HI GONZALEZ. HERTZBERG
JONES LAYERED LAYERED HI STERN
ALL RIGHT STERN AYE WHITE HOUSE
SKI. WIENER SO FAR YOU HAVE FOUR
GUYS WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT ON CALL THANK
YOU THANK YOU BOB THEN- I TINK
CONSISTENT MOUNT YOU CAN SEE
MAKE SURE THAT IS CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT I ANNOUNCED THAT I
THINK. SENATOR COM LOGGERS NEXT.
RIGHT RIGHT. THANK YOU SENATE
CAMARGO FOR YOUR PATIENCE. YEAH
HE. SENATOR FLOOR'S YOURS I
THINK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS I AM HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE BILL TEN
FIFTY FIVE. DRIVER'S LICENSE
SUSPENSIONS RELATED TO CHILD
SORT CHILD SUPPORT ARREARS AND I
AM TAKING THE AMENDMENTS I AM
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS. I AM
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS OKAY.
HELLO TEN FIFTY FIVE. ANY MY
COFFEE SIX TO ADDRESS PUNITIVE
MEASURES TAKEN AGAINST THOSE
THAT HAVE FALLEN INTO CHILD
SUPPORT ARREARS SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILLTARGETS DRIVER'S
LICENSE SUSPENSION MANDATES
RELATED TO MISSED CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
HAS AN INCREDIBLY HIGH PUNITIVE
MEASURE IN PLACE FOR CHILD
SUPPORT ARREARS. IN ADDITION TO
DRIVER'S LCENSE SUSPENSIONS THE
STATE ALSO IMPOSES A 10%
INTEREST RATE ON MISSED PAYMENTS
AND PASSPORT AMOUNT FOR BALANCES
THAT REACHED TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS ON THEIR OWN THESE
MEASURES ARE OVERLY PUNITIVE BUT
TAKEN TOGETHER THEY SEVERELY
IMPACT FAMILIES LIVES AND HAVE
SHOWN NO EVIDENCE OF INCREASING
CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS. LOW
INCOME NON CONSTRUCT
NONCUSTODIAL PARENTS ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING TO MAINTAIN THE BASIC
NECESSITIES THE THREAT OF LOSING
THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSE AND THEIR
MEANS TO COMMUTE TO WORK OR TO
VISIT THEIR CHILDREN. CAN BE
DEVASTATING STUDIES CONTINUE TO
SHOW THAT NONCUSTODIAL PARENTS
WHO AREN'T THREATENED WITH
PUNITIVE MEASURES TEND TO PAY
THEIR CHILD SUPPORT MORE
CONSISTENTLY VISIT MORE OFTEN
WITH THEIR CHILDREN AND HAVE A
BETTER RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR
CO PARENT. REPORTS HAVE ALSO
SHOWN THE CYCLE OF UNEMPLOYMENT
INCARCERATION IN DEBT ARE MORE
PREVALENT WHEN PARENTS ARE
SUBJECTED TO AGGRESSIVE
ENFORCEMENT SB TEN FIFTY FIVE
WILL ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
DESTRUCTIVE CHILD SUPPORT
ARREARS MANDATES WITH THE TWO
FOLD APPROACH. FIRST CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES WILL NOT BE
ALLOWED TO NOTIFY DMV TO
SUSPENDED DRIVER'S LICENSE DUE
TO CHILD SUPPORT ARREARS IF THE
INDIVIDUAL MAKES AT OR BELOW 60%
OF THE COUNTY MEDIAN INCOME. AND
SECOND IT WILL EXTEND THE
CURRENT DECSS PRACTICE OF DMB
NOTIFICATIONS AFTER THIRTY DAYS
OF OVERDUE CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS TO NO MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY. THIS
EXTENSION FROM THIRTY DAYS TO
SIX MONTHS WILL ALIGN THE
STATE'S DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES DMB
NOTIFICATION PRACTICE MORE
CLOSELY WITH MANDATES AND OTHER
STATES. OTHER STATES IN CLOSING
90% OF PEOPLE IN ARREARS ARE
CONSIDERED POOR. THERE IS NO
PROOF THAT THESE PUNITIVE
MEASURES WORK IT IS
COUNTERINTUITIVE TO EXPECT
SOMEONE TO PAY THEIR CHILD
SUPPORT WHEN WE'VE TAKEN AWAY
THEIR MEANS TO GET OR KEEP THEIR
JOB. CALIFORNIA MUST NOT
CONTINUE TO PUNISH SOMEONE WHO
IS IN A TERRIBLE FINANCIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE WHO WANTS TO
CONTRIBUTE AND BE A PART OF
THEIR FAMILY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. AND WITH ME
HERE IN SUPPORT AS MICHAEL
HERALD FROM THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY AND PAUL GIVE
IDA AND IMPACTED PARENT. ALL
RIGHT MR HERALD GO AHEAD. OF YOU
SENATOR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY CAROL WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY. WE STAND STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN FIFTY FIVE
TODAY. SB TEN FIFTY FIVE
CONTINUES IN THE VEIN OF MANY
BILLS THAT WESTERN CENTER
ANOTHER ADVOCATES ABROAD IN
RECENT YEARS. REALLY POINTING
OUT THE HIGH COST OF BEING POOR.
AND OUR CURRENT CHILD SUPPORT
LAWS HAVE THAT AFFECT ALSO JUST
LIKE WE SEEM TO TRAFFIC COURTS
PARKING TICKETS JUVENILE FINES
AND FEES CIVIL ASSESSMENTS- AND
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON. OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE OVER TIME
THAT WE THOUGHT AT THE TIME
WE'RE GOOD POLICY BUT ACTUALLY
END UP BEING. NEGATIVE AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY NEGATIVE FOR
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
PARTICULARLY BLACK AND BROWN
CALIFORNIANS. AS SENATOR CALM
WATER POINTED OUT THE IMPACTS OF
OUR CURRENT POLICY ARE THAT. OF
THE EIGHTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
THAT THE STATE IS VOTED ON PAY
CHILD SUPPORT. MORE THAN 80% OF
IT IS OPEN PEOPLE WHO MAKE LESS
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
OR WHO HAVE NO REPORTED INCOME
AT ALL. SO THIS POLICY. SIGNIFY
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS THE
LOWEST INCOME CALIFORNIANS AND
MAKES IT HARDER FOR THEM TO LIVE
UP TO THEIR OBLIGATIONS TO BE
ABLE TO PAY CHILD SUPPORT- ARE
WITNESSED. AN IMPACTED COMMUNITY
MEMBER WILL SPEAK TO THIS
DIRECTLY IN A MOMENT- BUT
WITHOUT A DRIVER'S LICENSE IT IS
VERY HARD TO GET A JOB- IN NEW
JERSEY 40% OF THE PEOPLE LOST
THEIR LICENSE DIDN'T GET THEIR
JOB BACK. AND ANOTHER 30% HAD TO
TAKE LOWER PAYING JOBS SO THIS
HAS A REAL IMPACT IF WE WANT
PEOPLE TO PAY CHILD SUPPORT.
THEY NEED TO HAVE THEIR LICENSES
HENCE MISTER GOODBAR IS WAITING
ON LINE I THINK TO. GIVE HIS
TESTIMONY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SIR MISTER GOODBAR. MY
NAME IS OLGA OUR SANDRA DAY I
BECAME A FATHER WAS ONE OF THE
BEST DAYS OF MY LIFE. THE
PENALTY COVERAGE MY CHILDREN. I
WORK LONGER HOURS IT'S
CONTRIBUTED TO MY WIFE'S
INFIDELITY AND SEND TO MY
AMERICA. MY DIVORCE MY EX FILED
A MOVE AWAY ORDER SO SHE BLEW
AWAY WITH HER YOU KNOW I THINK.
YOU ARE WITH MY CHILDREN. IN THE
BLINK OF MY- I. BOUGHT KING
WANTED TO ORDERED THEM AWAY HER
FAVOR. NOT ONLY DID I NOT. THEY
MIGHT. CHILDREN WHO I LOVE YOUR
- FELT ALSO ORDERED TO PAY
CHILD. AGREEMENT. FOR I THOUGHT
THAT WOULD BE TO HAVE NOTHING
LIKE IT'S AN- X. BECAUSE FIVE
HOPE THAT AGAINST THAT I AM.
GONNA TELL WITH BUT THE THING IS
REFUSE WORKER ARE. I AM A JUNIOR
HIGH SCHOOL DROP NINE WORKING
MINIMUM YOUR SPINE PARALYZED. ON
ARE FAR. THE FARMERS MARKET IN
FISHERIES AND- MOREOVER. THERE
HAD BEEN. A LOT OF BY AND
STABILITY OF. OUR PARTY YOU COME
TO SEE WORK. HELP SUPPORT FOR.
WE TO WORK FOR ME. I AM NOT
INTERESTED IF YOU TO PAY IT'S
BECAUSE- WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT
REFUSES LISTEN TO MY- MUCH OF.
EVERYDAY LIKE IT'S NOT ONE
SHOULD ALL. BECAUSE I'M IN A
RARE ALSO. I HAVE ALSO MY DRY
LICENSE NOT HAVING TO DRIVE
LICENSE. PLATE AND- MY- WHAT
LIFE AND ABILITY TO EARN. I LIVE
IN RURAL AMERICA HOW NO HE NO
AIR AND- OF. I REMIND MY NAME TO
TAKE TO THE ONE CERVANTES.
ENTERTAINER I CAN I WILL. ANY
JOB WITHOUT A GUY LICENSE PLATE
YOU OR- AND- BEST. BUY NO BUDGET
RIGHT IN VERY SELF DIFFICULT FOR
ME TO GET A.
MAYBE IF I DO ALL THAT I WILL BE
WITH YOU MUCH OF IT AGAIN. AFTER
MY DIVORCE I LOST MY CHILDREN
WHY DOES THE GOVERNMENT FEEL.
I'LL HAVE TO LOSE MY DIGNITY AND
MY ABILITY TO SURVIVE ARGUED LOS
YET AND FEDERAL SB TEN FIFTY.
BECAUSE ARE LIKE BENTON IS THE-
SITUATION BY MINORITIES THIRD
FOR HER CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR ALL
RIGHT- OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. MY REVIEW QUEUE THEM UP
PLEASE. THANK YOU ARE PEOPLE
SHOULD SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
AT TEN FIFTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DO
HAVE A FEW IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE
ONE MOMENT FOR THE FIRST COMMENT
. SH.
BARBARA COMMENTED PROVIDE ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON HI MY NAME IS
GAIL YOUNG WOULD REBOUND A CO
SPONSOR AND A MEMBER OF THE
TRUTH AND JUSTICE AND CHILD
SUPPORT COLLECTION BONTA BURKE
HAD FIFTY FIVE EVERY TEN THIRTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES HELLO MY NAME IS
RACHEL FRIEDMAN ON THE NUMBER OF
THE TRUTH AND JUSTICE AND CHILD
FOR COALITION I WOULD LIKE TEIR
VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR SB TEN
FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME
IS CYNTHIA BODGER AND I'M AT THE
BALLOT THIS FALL I MAKE THE
COURT ITSELF. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT LET'S NOW
TURN TO OPPOSITION- THOSE AND-
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
DO NOT HAVE ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- OTHERS
AND IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
WISHING TESTIFYING OPPOSITION
PLEASE APPROACH MICROPHONE
SEEING NONE WE QUEUE UP THOSE ON
THE PHONE. THOSE IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. ONE ZERO FIVE FIVE.
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD LET US
KNOW WHO'S ON THE PHONE IF
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO ONE ZERO
FIVE FIVE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO ASK B.
ONE ZERO FIVE FIVE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BY
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
CARE ONLY GOOD FOR MARRIAGE BUT
CALIFORNIA KNOWN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL FOR
CHILDREN FAKE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. RIGHT THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT A BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE THE MOVE THE BILL
ASSEMBLY BECAUSE HE MOVES THE
BILL QUESTIONS WE SEE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- SIMILAR
COLOR WHICH LIKE CLOSE. YOU KNOW
I DON'T WANT TO JINX ANYTHING SO
I'M JUST GONNA SAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT- CHIEF
COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL. YES THIS IS THE S. SENATE
BILL TEN FIFTY FIVE BY SENATOR
KAMLAGER- WITH A MOTION BY
SENATOR WAY CASKEY THE MOTION IS
D. PASSED AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND THEN RE REFER. TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
BURKE BURKE HI BORGIAS CABALLERO
CARRIERA I DID ASAL HI THE REST
SO I GONZALEZ HERTZBERG. JONES
LAYERED LAYERED I STERN. WHITE
CAL SKI. WHY CASKEY I WIENER.
BEFORE YOU HAVE TWO ZERO WITH
MEMBERS MISSING. I WILL PUT THAT
ON CALL THING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CENTER CENTER CORTESE WHO'S BEEN
WAITING VERY PATIENTLY. SENATE
CORTESE. S. B. ONE ONE EIGHT
FOUR. YES IT IS. ONE THIRTY.
THANK YOU MR SENATORS SOME
PLEASE PRESENT S. B. ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS GET THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SUPPORT THEY NEED. IN MY
HOME DISTRICT IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY- AS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR
WAS PROUD TO PIONEER A PROGRAM
THAT CONNECTS STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES TO COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELING CASE MANAGEMENT AND
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES. THAT
HAPPENS ON DISTRICT IN SCHOOL
SITE CAMPUSES THROUGH
COORDINATORS. WHICH TODAY SERVE
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED SCHOOLS ACROSS
FIFTEEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THAT
COUNTY ALONE. OF THESE PROGRAMS
CALLED COMMUNITY SCHOOLS IN SOME
PLACES OF COURSE EXIST IN MANY
OTHER PLACES IN CALIFORNIA. I
BELIEVE. THAT THE SUCCESSFUL
WITHOUT SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS THAT
LINK MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
BETWEEN COUNTIES IN SCHOOLS
GUIDE THE FRAMEWORK OF SCHOOL
BASED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
STATEWIDE TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF CREDENTIALED PEOPLE SUPPORT
SERVICES PERSONNEL LIKE
COUNSELORS SCHOOL SOCIAL WORKERS
NURSES PSYCHOLOGISTS IT'S CENTER
AT OUR SCHOOL SITES. WE MUST
EXPAND OR SEE WHAT STRATEGY TO
PROVIDE PROVIDE SCHOOL BASED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
STUDENTS AND ENSURETHE SERVICES
PROVIDED AMONG VARIOUS ENTITIES
ARE SUSTAINABLE EQUITABLE AND
BETTER COORDINATED TO FILL GAPS
IN SERVICES THAT EXISTS FOR
STUDENTS. AND SUPPORT THE
OVERALL HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
OUR CHILDREN THAT'S BALONEY
FORWARD TO FINDTHE CALIFORNIA
LAW THE SCHOOLING SERVICES
COORDINATOR. AS THOSE
INDIVIDUALS OR ENTITIES WITH A
PUPIL PERSONNEL SERVICES
CREDENTIAL LOCATED ON A SCHOOL
CAMPUS OR UNDER CONTRACT BY
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROVIDER. TO ENSURE THAT THESE
SCHOOLING SERVICES COORDINATORS
CAN BATTERY FOR BOTH STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES. TO MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT CARE. BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN THE SUICIDE RATE FOR
CHILDREN AGES TEN TO FOURTEEN
MORE THAN DOUBLED. SUICIDE IS
NOW THE SECOND LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH FOR INDIVIDUALS. BETWEEN
THE AGES OF TEN AND TWENTY FOUR.
CODE NINETEEN OF COURSE IS ONLY
EXACERBATED THESE ISSUES. A
RECENT REPORT PUBLISHED BY THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION TOLD THE EFFICACY OF A
SCHOOL BASED APPROACH TO STUDENT
WELLNESS DEMONSTRATED THAT WE
ARE WHAT WE ALREADY KNOW.
STUDENTS ARE TWENTY ONE I SKEWS
ME STUDENTS ARE TEN TO TWENTY
ONE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO RECEIVE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES WHEN
THEY'RE PROVIDED ON A SCHOOL
CAMPUS. SO WE MUST MEET STUDENTS
WHERE THEY ARE ON THE SCHOOL
CAMPUSES. SCHOOLS MUST SERVE TO
DEVELOP CHILDREN HOLISTICALLY
LASTLY I'D LIKE TO ALSO
HIGHLIGHT FOR THIS COMMITTEE
RECENT AMENDMENT IN THE BILL ON
PAGE NINE LINE SIXTEEN THAT
EXPLICITLY CLARIFIES THAT ANY
SHARING OF INFORMATION MUST BE
PURSUANT. TO A WRITTEN
AUTHORIZATION BY THE PATIENT OR
IN THE CASE OF SCHOOL CHILDREN
OFTENTIMES A GUARDIAN. IF THE
PATIENTS UNDER EIGHTEEN. IN THAT
NEEDS TO BE COMPLIANT WITH HIPAA
THIS BILL IS A STUDENT CENTRIC
AND FAMILY CENTRIC. BILL WITH ME
TODAY IS JENNIFER TRAN EXCUSE ME
- MISTER CHURCHILL FOR TRÊN HAD
TO LEAVE BECAUSE OF- THE
SCHEDULE LET'S JUST SAY THE
SCHEDULED TODAY- I DON'T KNOW IF
CHEN UP- SHOES FROM AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED- GEN UP I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO COME UP WITH A BACK UP
SO I HAVE RAVINA- NIMBALKAR IN
REAL VIENEN YES RAVINA NIMBALKAR
EXISTS THE SECTOR DIRECTOR OF
NAMI OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY. AND
SHE SHOULD BE- AVAILABLE TO
TESTIFY THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WHAT. THANK YOU POLITICAL
G. THREE I MEAN IT'S RUBINA
BARKER AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR ACT NAMI SANTA CLARA
COUNTY I THINK ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF NOT BECAUSE THE CURRENT
COUNTY AND BE SUPPORT FIFTY ONE
ONE FIFTY FOUR. AND THE TIME FOR
THE COMPLETE THE FOR CONVINCED
AS A GROUP BELIEVE THE FLOW BY
CHILDREN AND THE CHILDREN.
MENTAL HEALTH HAD THE BECAUSE
ENOUGH- COMMITTEE EVEN BUT
DISTINCT OF AFTER. ASKED WHAT.
INCLUDE BE BECAUSE OF A TO KEEP
THEIR HEADS. SUPPORT TO OUR
STUDENTS- IN THE COMMUNITY
FEDERATED PASSAGE OF THE CLEAN.
AND LOCAL. IN OUR SCHOOL TRIED
TO THE NEST CENTERS. THAT CAN
THE MAN HEALTH. OF TO THE. THIS
COOLING SERVICE PROGRAM. STUDENT
IN FAMILIES BE CONNECT TO MAKE
HEALTH COUNTY CASE. AND FROM
HEALTH. ON THE DISTRICT AND AYE
CAMPUS. LEAVE GOT A ONE ONE
EIGHT FOUR TWO THE BECAUSE OF
OUR CHILDREN AND THE CHILDREN
COME. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. OTHER IN SUPPORT OF ANY
HERE IN ROOM TWELVE IF IN SOME
PLEASE MIKE TO SEE NO ONE ON THE
PHONE LINE MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE UP THOSE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF IT. SB ONE ONE
EIGHT FOUR. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE ONE EIGHT FOUR. THREE FOUR
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR OUR FIRST
COMMENT.
OUR FIRST COMMENT WILL COME FROM
WIND SIXTY SEVEN THAT'S SEVEN.
CALL HELLO MY NAME IS DIANE
GARCIA HELLO MY NAME IS DIANE
GARCIA I AM FROM PETALUMA
CALIFORNIA I HAVE A MASTER'S
DEGREE IN HEALTH EDUCATION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB ONE ONE EIGHT
FOUR. THANK YOU. OTHERS YOUR
FOUR PEOPLE HAVE. HI THANK YOU-
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOSH BOOTY
THERE'S NINE BE FOUR CHAIRED THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
COUNSELORS AND WE CALL IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE ONE EIGHT
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO MORE LIFE IN
SUPPORT ALL RIGHT- LET'S NOT
TURNED OPPOSITION ANYONE HERE IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED OPPOSITION
SAYING NO WHEN APPROACHING THE
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION. YES
OUR ICE SERVICES COURT. OKAY
TRANSITIONAL SCHOOL. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M CHERYL MCEWEN
HARPER THANK YOU FOR HEARING ME
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE'S CONVOY OF CALIFORNIA
AND WE'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU
FOLKS. YOU WORK FOR US. THANK
YOU. ALREADY THANK YOU- OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION WE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE SAYING NO ONE HERE IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED ON THE PHONE
LINE ANYONE OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE MY MODERATOR FEW WE QUEUE
THEM UP. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO ACT
THE ONE ONE EIGHT FOUR. WE'VE
PRESS ONE SEVEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. BY ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I CAN REMEMBER CALLING
THE CAMPUS. THERE ON THE
PERMANENT SIDE OF THE HOUSE OF
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER- FOUNDATION
RESPECTFULLY A OPPOSED TO A
COMMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
WANTING TO AUTHOR FOR- CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIDE ONE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS WORKING WELL- I'M
CALLING FROM WEST HOLLYWOOD
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY IN
OPPOSITION TO ONE ONE EIGHT FOUR
I'M ALSO PART OF NATURAL HEALTH
FIRST AND LGBT HELP FREEDOM
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M FORTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE CALLED JOHN AFTER
COUNTY CHAPTER CHAIRMAN FOR
LIBERTY REPRESENTING OVER TWO
THOUSAND PROCTOR COUNTY FAMILIES
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BYE ONE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME AND
OTHER INGREDIENT IN THE
CALIFORNIA PRISON KEEPERS CAN WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB ONE ONE EIGHT
FOUR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
X. IT. ALONE BERMAN AND THE
FAMILY FOCUSED I'M FARMS SEVERAL
COUNTY MY MOTHER OF TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB. ONE ONE
EIGHT FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. RIGHT SIX WE'VE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS CYNTHIA BODGER I'M
WITH THE FREEDOM COMMUNITY OF
THE CENTRAL COAST DOWN WITH THE
BEST SELLING WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIDE ONE TWENTY SEVEN THREE
FOUR AT. IF I CAN HEAR ME YES WE
CAN- MY NAME IS RELAXED. AND I
AM CALLING AND- THE THIRD JAMES
BRADLEY. AND IT'S IN MY FRIEND
PARTIAL. AND WE WORK WITH A LAW
ORGANIZATION THAT BURKE FINALLY
OPPOSED. STATE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ONE ONE TWENTY GO AHEAD. I
MIGHT FATE I'M A VERY CONCERNING
PARENTS STRONGLY OPPOSING BAIL
SB ONE ONE EIGHT FOUR IT IS
GOING ON- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND OF MENTAL HEALTH ALL RIGHT.
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS RICK CAL HOKKIEN REPRESENTING
CATHOLIC FAMILIES FOR FREEDOM-
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE- YES THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE FORTY SIX
PEOPLE HAVE. BY ONE FOUR SIX. I
IN THE MIRROR AND I'M THE
CONCERNED PARENTS AND A CITIZEN
OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR AND I ENCOURAGE YOU
TO DO THE RIGHT THING OPPOSE IT
AS WELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SEVEN FIVE. HELLO MY NAME
IS ROXY RIGHT I STRONGLY AND
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL BUT
PEOPLE SHOULD BE HEARD THANK YOU
. THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS KIM
EMERSON I AND B. EMILY OPPOSED
FOR MONEY FOR. COMBUSTOR COUNTY
THANK YOU. I THINK THIS IS YOUR
MIND FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE FOUR ONE. WELL I MEAN
PHILIP AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
CELL. THANK YOU. SOME. THANK YOU
I WON FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU YES THIS FLOOR A SPIN
OFF FROM CALIFORNIA- COUNTY
CALIFORNIA I REPRESENTS IVERSON
NOMA COALITION OF PARENTS
EMPLOYEES WILL- ADMINS AND- WE
ARE STRONGLY AGAINST THIS BILL
WE PREFER MEDICAL FREEDOM AND
PRIVACY THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU ALL RIGHTY- BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS KERRY
MEMBERS SAYING YES SIR CABALLERO
. I JUST HAVE A QUESTION IN
REGARDS TO- I THINK THIS IS
REALLY AN IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE SCHOOL TO KNOW- GET
INFORMATION. WITH THE APPROVAL
OF THE PARENTS- ABOUT- THINGS
THAT WOULD HELP THE SCHOOL TO
BETTER PREPARE A GOOD LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT AND I SAY THIS AS- A
MOTHER OF FIVE CHILDREN IT-
THAT- NEEDED EXTRA HELP IN THEIR
LEARNING AND THEY HAD
DISABILITIES AND SO IT'S REALLY
TOUGH ON THE TEACHERS- TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT KIND OF ENVIRONMENT
THEY SHOULD CREATE AND- AND THIS
THIS PROVIDES IN. A PATHWAY TO
BE ABLE TO SHARE INFORMATION BUT
I WANT TO BE VERY CERTAIN THAT
UPON SHARING INFORMATION WITH
THE SCHOOL THAT THE INFORMATION
IS KEPT IN A CONFIDENTIAL-
ENVELOPE. ONLY TO BE OPENED BY-
INDIVIDUALS THAT ACTUALLY HAVE A
NEED TO SEE THAT INFORMATION. I
WOULDN'T BET YOU KNOW IT IT WILL
BE ALL HAVE SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TRICKS IN OUR IN OUR
IN OUR DISTRICTS. THAT HAVE VERY
VERY- LIMITED NUMBER OF TEACHERS
AND STAFF IN THE FRONT OFFICE
THEY KNOW EACH OTHER THEY GAS UP
THEIR FRIENDS- THEY WERE ALL
FROM MY NEIGHBORHOOD INSIDE WANT
TO MAKE SURE. FOR INFORMATION.
IT WOULD. BUT THEN WOULD BE USED
TO TRACK MY KID- AS THEY GROW
OLDER AND MAYBE GROW GROW OUT OF
SOME OF THAT BEHAVIORAL ISSUES
THAT ARE CHALLENGES FOR
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHERS SO- I
JUST WANT TO PUT THAT OUT THERE-
I ASKED THE QUESTION AS TO
WHETHER IT WOULD BE KEPT
CONFIDENTIAL- AND THE ANSWER IS
YES BUT I REALLY DO THINK THAT
IT PROBABLY REQUIRES A LITTLE
BIT STRONGER THAT THAT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT STEEP IT IN. THE
FILES THE I ASSUME. SEEING IT.
AS EARLY THAT. THE STAFF THEY
DON'T NEED TO SEE IT. THANK YOU
SIR GOING ARE OTHER QUESTIONS
SIR MOTION SIR SIR RUSSELL
QUESTION. I JUST REALLY AGREE
WITH THAT THE CENTER NIGHT- FUND
WHEN I FOUND OUT THAT IT WAS
WITH A GUARDIAN CONSENT- THAT
REALLY CALMED ME DOWN A LOT SO-
WITH SIMILAR CONCERNS AS THE
CENTER BUT I WILL MOVE THE
WHOLE. OF QUE SERA SO MOST THE
BILL. WHICH CLOSER CORTESE.
MISTER ALL IT WAS THE THOUGHT
THROUGH PRETTY WELL IN HIS YOU
KNOW- PRIOR TO MY SERVICE HERE
SERVING AS COUNTY SUPERVISOR IN
A COUNTY WITH THE SECOND LARGEST
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM IN THE
STATE- WE WERE ALL TRAINED OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN ON
PRIVACY AND CONFIDENTIALITY AN
PARTICULARLY COOPER AT THE SAME
TIME- GRANT WE'VE RUN INTO THIS
PROBLEM AS HAVE OTHER COUNTY
ORGANIZATIONS AS THE STATE
CONTINUES TO INVESTMENT ALL
SERVICE. IS BUT THE PRIVATE.
REFERRING TO SOME CENTER COMING
. IN THIS IS GOVERNED BY THE
CODE AND HIPPER FEDERAL LAW OVER
THE TOP OF THAT BUT THE AD CODE-
IS VERY VERY CLEAR AND
PRESCRIPTIVE IN TERMS OF THE
SHARING AND CONFIDENTIALITY OF
INFORMATION NOT JUST STUDENT
RECORDS BUT PARTICULARLY HEALTH
RECORDS- BUT THAT'S THE EIGHT
CODE THE COUNTIES ARE GOVERNED
AS YOU KNOW IS A FORMAL ACTIVE A
LOCAL OFFICIAL BY THE
GOVERNMENT. SO WE BUILD IS FROM
IT STANDPOINT IS BASICALLY
CREATE A PASS UP A PASSAGEWAY HE
WILL YOU KINDLY DESCRIBED FROM
THE GOVERNMENT CODE OVER TO THE
ED CODE WITH PREEMPTING HIPPER-
OR OR INTO THE PRIVACY LAWS IN
FACT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE
COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF- FOR TALKING TO US ABOUT
INCLUDING THAT LANGUAGE THAT I
REFERRED TO EARLIER- TO MAKE IT
VERY VERY CLEAR. AFFIRMATIVELY
IN THE BILL OTHER THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS BILL THAT IT
PREAMPS. HIP BUT AND IN FACT-
HIP. YOU NOT ONLY HAVE TO
COMPOSE COMPORT HIPPER BUT HAVE
A SIGNED AUTHORIZATION- EVEN
KNOWS TREATMENT IS STILL A
REQUIRED IN THIS BILL THAT WAS
SIGNED AUTHORIZATION WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU- IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR ALSO MANAGE
ACCOUNTS IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL YES THIS IS- S. B. HELLO.
BEFORE BY SEN. WITH THE AT
MOTION SENATOR US SO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS. UMBERG BY AMBERG BY
BURGESS CABALLERO GUERRIERO I US
I THE REST SO I GONZALEZ
HERTZBERG. JONES LAYERED-
LAYERED ICE STERN WHITE CAL
SKENEIDAE BY CASKEY AYE WIENER.
YOU HAVE FIVE TO ZERO SO BIRTH
MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT LET'S
PUT THAT ON HIS ALMOST THIRTY.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN.
W. THE END OF THEIR PAIN FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON- FAIR MEMBERS- PROUD
TO PRESENT TO YOU SENATE BILL
ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO- IF YOU'RE A
STUDENT AND YOU NEED TO TAKE AN
EXAM- REMOTELY- THE SCHOOL MAY
REQUIRE YOU TO VERIFY YOUR
IDENTITY THROUGH HI PRACTICING A
PROCTOR IN COMPANY THAT STATE
THAT THE SCHOOL IS CONTRACTED
WITH. AND THE PROCTER COMPANY
MAY ASK OF THE STUDENT SO WITH
THAT HAPPENS OF YOUR CHILD OR
MAYBE YOURSELF. ALL SORTS OF
PERSONAL INFORMATION. AND SO
WHAT THIS BILL DOES SENATE BILL
EVANS ANY TO DOES IS TO PROTECT
THE PRIVACY OF OUR STUDENTS BY
LIMITING THE AMOUNT OF PERSONAL
BIOMETRIC INFORMATION DATA
REMOTE ACTING COMPANY CAN
COLLECT THE ONLY INFORMATION
THAT'S NECESSARY TO OFFER THEIR
SERVICES. THIS BILL ALSO
EMPOWERS STUDENTS TO TAKE ACTION
IF THEIR PRIVACY HAS BEEN
VIOLATED BY REQUIRING DATA
MINIMIZATION AND ALLOWING THE
HARM USERS OF REMOTE PARKING
SOFTWARE TO SUE COMPANIES. THE
OTHER PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
SINCE THE START OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC MORE STUDENTS
AND INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN
REQUIRED TO TAKE TEST REMOTELY.
AND REMOTE PROMPTING COMPANIES
ARE COLLECTING BIOMETRIC DATA
SUCH AS FACIAL RECOGNITION
TEMPLATES FINGERPRINTS
CITIZENSHIP DATA MEDICAL%
INFORMATION BROWSING HISTORY AND
VIDEO AND AUDIO. OF THE USER'S
SURROUNDINGS. CURRENTLY THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
COVERS PARKING COMPANIES BUT THE
LAW IS NOT STRONG ENOUGH TO
LIMIT DATA AND PROVIDE THE
STUDENTS THE TOOLS TO RECRUIT TO
RECUPERATE DAMAGES. REMOTE
CONTRACTING COMPANIES HAVE BEEN
EXPLOITING A LOOPHOLE IN THE C.
C. P. A.'S DEFINITIONS BY
CLIMBING THERE ARE SERVICE
PROVIDERS THAT WORK THROUGH THE
SCHOOL AND NOT WORKING DIRECTLY
WITH THE STUDENTS SO THEY SAY
WELL WE HAVE A CONTRACT WITH THE
SCHOOL WE DON'T HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH STUDENT. AS A
RESULT THESE COMPANIES COLLECT
STUDENTS PRIVATE INFORMATION AND
HOLDER DATA FAR LONGER THAN IS
NECESSARY TO ADMINISTER AN EXAM.
OR FOR OTHER K. TO TWELVE
PURPOSES THIS BILL IS ABOUT
GIVING OUR STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES MORE TOOLS TO PROTECT
OUR OWN PERSONAL INFORMATION AND
ENCOURAGING PROMPTING COMPANIES
TO ME WERE MORE TRANSPARENT.
ABOUT THEIR DATA COLECTION SO
IT IS LIMITED TO ONLY WHAT IS
NECESSARY TO CONDUCT AN EXAM TO
SURE IT'S SECURITY. AGAINST
STUDENTS WILL HAVE A CHOICE YOU
HAVE TO TAKE THE EXAM IN ORDER
TO PASS THE CLASS AND THE
PROPERTY COMPANY YOU DON'T GET
TO CHOOSE YOU AND FOR THE DAY
THE MANIFESTATION. YOU ARE NOT
IN A POSITION TO REFUSE UNLESS
YOU PLAN NOT TO PASS THAT CLASS.
SO JOIN ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
VERY REMOTE CONFERENCE IS. HALEY
TSUKAYAMA SENIOR LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR LIKE CHRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION AND
CHRISTIAN PAKSE. UNDERGRADUATE
RESEARCHER AT CALTECH
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATE PAN OF MISS
HAYLEY TSUKAYAMA ARE YOU
AVAILABLE YES HI I AM HELLO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS AND- THANK YOU HI
REALLY FAMOUS IN THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION WE HAVE TO
DISTILL FOOTBALL THE DIFFERENCE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA I THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY PART
OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO. THIS
BILL EXTENSIBLE DATA
MINIMIZATION GUARDRAILS TO LIMIT
WHAT INFORMATION CAN BE
COLLECTED BY REMOTE PROXY
COMPANIES SUCH AS FACTORY OKAY
AFTER YOU AN EXAMPLE AND ALLOW
STUDENTS TO TAKE PARKING COMPANY
TO COURT IF THE GUARD REAL ARE
NOT FOLLOWED. DURING PANDEMIC
REMOTE TRACKING SERVICE USE HAVE
INCREASED 2% FOR MANY STUDENTS
SERVICES ARE NOT OPTIONAL ONE
STUDY FOUND 97% OF TO KEEP USING
THE TOOLS WERE REQUIRED TO
STUDENTS ARE OFTEN POWERLESS TO
EXERCISE ANY CONTROL OVER THEIR
INFORMATION FOR USE THAT
SOFTWARE AT THE PREREQUISITE FOR
TAKING A PATH OFTEN INCLUDING
FOR IMPORTANT. EXAMS THAT CAN.
IT TOOK THEIR LIVES. THE
COMPANIES COLLECT A VAST OF DATA
AS- AND PAN- AT. THEY OFTEN HANG
ON TO THIS. FOR YEAR. REMOTE
PROCTER AND- ALL THREE. THAT
ACCURACY. WOULD BE ABLE TO THE
FIVE FAILING RECOGNIZE BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE PROPERLY AND IN
ACCURATELY FLOODING. AS CHEATING
CREATING A RECORD OF DATA THAT
MAKES IT HARDER FOR SOME ALREADY
DISADVANTAGED USERS TO SUCCEED.
DESPITE IRAQI NEWS RESULT IN
DATA BREACHES OF CREDIT PRIVATE
INFORMATION COLLECTED BY.
HOLDING CONCERTS THREE BY
FEDERAL LAWMAKERS IN CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT. THERE NO
PLACE TO PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF
TEST TAKERS. WHAT CALIFORNIA'S
YOU HAVE SOME PROTECTION FEDERAL
AND STATE AND YOU CAN CREDIT YOU
ARE DO NOT ADEQUATELY LIMIT THE
INFORMATION COLLECTED BY THE
SOFTWARE. THAT THEY PROVIDE
INDIVIDUAL REPORT FROM A STUDENT
INFORMATION IS USED TO VIOLATION
OF THE LAWS. OF THE CCPA
ALLOWED. TO COLLECT USE AND
SHARE INFORMATION BEYOND WHAT IS
STRICTLY NECESSARY TO CORRECTLY
SERVICES BY BEARING THE
ADDITIONAL USES OR DISCLOSURES
AND THE PRIVACY QUALITY.
DIFFICULT BILL RIGHT THE
IMBALANCE THAT EXISTS AND IF YOU
CAN BE BILITY TO PROTECT THEIR
OWN PRIVATE INFORMATION. WILL
ALSO REQUIRE FRACTURING
COMPANIES TO BE MORE TRANSPARENT
ABOUT THEIR DATA COLLECTION AND
USAGE WHICH WILL HELP INCREASE
SECURITY. AND IT WILL ALLOW
COURTS TO ANALYZE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THESE TOOLS. I
THINK FROM DR RICHARD PAN FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
ALL. OF YOU FOR YOUR TIME. I
URGE YOUR VOTE FOR SB. SEVENTY
TWO. THANK YOU. MISTER ON SAY.
THANK YOU FOR ME HERE TODAY IN
BY THE TO SHARE OUR- FORTY FIVE
YEARS AGO MY GRAND IN THE
GREATEST. WHERE SHE CAN BIRTH MY
FOR MY FATHER GRAHAM RETURNS
MEXICO SO MY FATHER WAS FOUR
YEARS OLD WHICH POINT THEY'LL
MOVE BACK CALIFORNIA STARTED
LIKE TO PURSUE THE AMERICAN
DREAM HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
DESPITE GROWING UP IN THE
PROPERTY IN THE LONG BEACH THE
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE ALL THESE
APPLICATIONS RELY PROBLEMS THE
FACTORY READING HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE EVENTUALLY EARNING
BACHELOR'S DEGREE A COUPLE YEARS
AFTER MY BIRTH. SIMILARLY MY
MOTHER USED EDUCATION TO BUILD
LIKE BETTER THAN THE ONE GIVEN
TO HER THANK YOU ACCESS TO
EDUCATION MY PARENTS HAD A
TREMENDOUS EFFORT TO PASS
GENERATIONS BOTH NIGHT WORK FOR
THE GREAT COLUSA FINANCIAL
STABILITY HOME ISSUES AND CHECK.
THEIR RETURN TO CALIFORNIA UNDER
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT MORE
PROBABLY CIRCUMSTANCES BANKER
SO. I CAN SEE MY JUST CONTACT
JACQUI DEDICATION SPENT WITH MY
FAMILY UPWARD MOBILITY ARE
CONTINUED PURSUIT OF THE
AMERICAN DREAM SHE'S ALSO TO
MANY OTHER STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
ACROSS OUR STATE THIS IS WHAT
PROTECTING EXPECTATIONS OF DEEP
IMPORTANT FOR ME. TO LIVE THE
DREAM OF MY FAMILY'S BENEFIT SO
MUCH FROM IN WHICH MANY FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY FOR MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO BENEFIT
FROM I BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT
ACTUALLY EDUCATION IS MOST
CRITICAL ON THE NEXT DREAM.
HOWEVER THE JACKETS EDUCATION
FRIEND BY THE CHOICE. THAT MAY
BECOME FACE TODAY. GREEN PARTY
AND- TO MIDDLE SCHOOL SCHOOL.
YOU CAN CROSS OUR STATE EIGHT
OPTION IN THE CHOICE TO COMPLY
WITH DOCTOR BROWN THREE. WITH
THE FAILING REVIEW TO BUY. IT'S
PROBABLY SOLD THE COMPANY NEARLY
EVERY. I IN A BETTER. WITH OUR-
PORTION FOR WRECKING. ACTUALLY
HE WILL PROGRAMS ARE RUNNING ON
COMPUTER. ACCORDING TO THE SINCE
AROUND AND VIDEO RECORDINGS YOU
WHILE YOU THE EXAM. WHICH HAVE
NO OTHER. TO SERVING AS CO
PARTLY OF THE PRIVATE WESTERN.
PLATFORM SERVICE ACTIVE THE REST
OF COMPANIES SUCH AS PROCTER
HAVING OUR- PRINTED WEEKS.
PACKAGE WHICH- IN CHRIS. PARTS
WILL HAVE CHEESE- JOHNSON SHOULD
IT BECOME AGAINST. IS BY FAR FOR
YOU TO MOVE RESEARCH PUBLIC BY.
AT THE FOREFRONT OF THE SITE BUT
WE DO NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES A
COMPANY LIKE PROCTER. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THE
SOON TO THE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
ASK FOR YOUR HELP TO MAINTAIN
ACT OCCASIONS. DURING
PROSECUTION'S BYPASSES AT THE
HOME TIMES. THANK YOU FOR THE
CAR.
HUNDRED THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME
FORWARD. WELCOME THANK YOU AT
CHAIR MEMBERS SAT THANKS CENTER
PAN MARIN BANANA WITH CALIFORNIA
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF PRETORIA
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL- WE BEEN
MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS IN THE
TESTIMONY- WE THINK THAT THE
BILL IS A GREAT STEP FOR WE
SUPPORTED- WE WOULD NOT AND
OPPOSE IT WE ACTUALLY HAVE FOUR
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD MAKE THE
BILL STRONGER AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL TO
PROTECT STUDENTS THAT THAT'S
THAT MISSION THAT PRETORIA HAS.
NINE PEOPLE THAT IN HERE THAT
THIS IS THE POINT WHICH I DID
YOUR AND THEN- IF YOU COULD TELL
US IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT THAT
WOULD BE TERRIFIC IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE. BOB
AND WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
TODAY AND OBVIOUSLY HAVE AN
INTEREST IN THIS BILL AND- CAN
PROVIDE SOME GOOD GOOD SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM. SAYING NO WHEN MOVING-
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE- THAT
LINE IS OR ANYBODY ON ON THE
LINE- THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
. ANYBODY IN THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AN HE ONE
ONE SEVEN TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHY ONE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS TRACY
RIGHT. BURKE CALLING ON BEHALF
OF OAKLAND PRIVACY EXPRESSED OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR S. B. ONLINE
SEVENTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WHAT'S NEXT PLEASE TAKE YOUR
RIGHT ONE FORTY ONE WE THOUGHT.
FRICTIONAL PROCTOR SPORTY RIGHT
CLEARINGHOUSE ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION AND CONSUMER REPORT IN
SUPPORT OF AT ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
THOSE IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE. TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE IDENTIFIED
THEMSELVES AND IN OPPOSITION
THEY ARE BOTH HERE IN THE ROOM-
IF SO WE'LL TURN IT OVER TO YOU
I TO HEAR COURTNEY JENSEN I'M
ARE NOT A LOT- HEY RENEE. IN
HOTEL LOBBY I WALK I APPRECIATE
IT THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL RUN
OKAY LET ME WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE RESPECTFULLY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY TWO. OUR ASSOCIATION
CONTINUES TO REVIEW THE BILL AND
WE INTEND TO WORK WITH AUTHORS
OFFICE TO PROVIDE MORE DETAILED
FEEDBACK TO MY COMMON STATE WILL
BE FAIRLY HIGH LEVEL. FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE BELIEVE ROBUST
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS APPLY UNDER
EXISTING STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
AROUND THE NOTICE COLLECTION USE
AND DISCLOSURE OF STUDENT OUR
EDUCATIONAL INFORMATION.
INCLUDING THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
STUDENT ON MY PERSONAL
INFORMATION AND PROTECTION ACT
OR OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE PEP
UP. CALIFORNIANS ALSO ENJOYS
STRONG PRIVACY PROTECTIONS UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY
ACT OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
AMENDMENTS TO THAT ACT BY THE
VOTER APPROVED PRIVACY RIGHTS
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY WHICH THIS
BILL NOW SIX DEMAND. NOTABLY
EXISTING CCK PROTECTIONS APPLY
EQUALLY TO ALL TYPES OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION AND SENSITIVE
PERSONAL INFORMATION
IRRESPECTIVE OF THE TYPE OF
INDUSTRY COLLECTING IT. AND
USING THAT INFORMATION WITHOUT
REGARD TO THE PARTICULAR
TECHNOLOGY USED IF ANY TO
COLLECT THAT INFORMATION STATED
ANOTHER WAY AS THIS COMMITTEE
KNOWS VERY WELL. THE LAW WAS
PURPOSEFULLY DESIGNED NOT TO
TAKE A COMPREHENSIVE TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRALAND INDUSTRY NEUTRAL
APPROACH TO PROTECTING CONSUMER
DATA PRIVACY RIGHTS. AND IT WAS
DONE SO WITH A LIMITED PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION FOR DATA
BREACHES. IN CONTRAST THIS NOW
SIX TEMAS. TEN ACCIDENT KILLING
STRINGENT. RESTRICTIONS THAT GO
BEYOND THE- NECESSARY STANDARD.
USED FOR DATA MINIMIZATION
PROVISIONS APPLYING TO SENSITIVE
PERSONAL INFORMATION. AND ADDS A
NEW PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION. AND
THESE ARE ONLY FOR COMPANIES
THAT PROVIDE PROMPTING SERVICES
IN AN EDUCATIONAL SETTING AND
EVEN OR THE P. I. IS DE
IDENTIFIED OR AGGREGATE CONSUMER
DATA. SUCH CHANGES SHARPLY
DEVIATE FROM THE EXISTING
STRUCTURE AND OPERATIONS CPRE.
AND WE'RE CHIEFLY CONCERNED AT
THIS BILL SIGNALING A RETURN TO
THE PRE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
PIECEMEAL APPROACH TO
ESTABLISHING PRIVATE FOR PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS DEPEND ON THE TYPE
OF INDUSTRY. DATA OR TECHNOLOGY
INVOLVED. WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
THIS IS LARGELY OUT OF A DESIRE
TO ADD NEW PRIVATE RIGHTS OF
ACTION MOVING FORWARD TO THE SEA
CARE A. WERE ONLY A LIMITED ONE
EXISTS TODAY. ULTIMATELY WE
BELIEVE THAT REVERTING TO
PICKING AND CHOOSING CERTAIN
TYPES OF DATA INDUSTRY OR
TECHNOLOGY SWITCHED A PIE
INDIVIDUALIZE RULES. WILL ONLY
UNDERMINE THE EFFICACY OF THAT
LANDMARK PRIVACY LAW. AS SUCH
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB. ELEVEN
SEVENTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CORPS ENGINE WITH
RUNNING AROUND GOVERNMENT IF. ON
THE OF C. JACK ADDRESSING THE
COMMITTEE TODAY WITH CONCERNS
ABOUT THE IMPACT SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY TWO WOULD HAVE ON
BUSINESS LIABILITY IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW CONSUMER TO BRING A CIVIL
ACTION AGAINST A BUSINESS
COLLECTING RETAINING USING OR
DISCLOSING PERSONAL INFORMATION
GATHERED ONE OFFERING PROCTOR
RING SERVICES. I MUST AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE CHAMBER
THAT THIS BILL IS CHIPPING AWAY-
IT CONTINUES TO CHIP AWAY OF
VOTER APPROVED TREATMENT OF DATA
UNDER EXISTING PRIVACY LAWS. AND
TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA VOTERS
PASSED PROP TWENTY FOUR AND
WHAT. WITH IT A BROAD FRAMEWORK
FOR HOW PERSONAL AND SENSITIVE
INFORMATION WAS TO BE HANDLED BY
BUSINESSES. REGARDLESS OF
INDUSTRY TYPE OR SERVICES. WHY
NOW BEFORE THE GOVERNING AGENCY
HAS EVEN RELEASED RULES AROUND
COMPLIANCE WITH THIS NEW PRIVACY
LAW. IS IT NECESSARY TO EXPAND
LIABILITY FOR THOSE PROVIDING
PROMPTING SERVICES. VOTERS HAVE
ALREADY APPROVED A LIMITED
ACTION UNDER EXISTING PRIVACY
LAW THAT DOES NOT SINGLE OUT
SPECIFIC INDUSTRIES OR SERVICES
LET'S ALLOW TIME FOR RULEMAKING
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT LAW
PRIOR TO ADDING ON. ADDITIONAL
AN UNNECESSARILY UNNECESSARY
LIABILITY FOR THOSE REASONS
SEJAK MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. REMOVE ON TO OTHERS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED THAT IS IN SUPPORT OF
THE SPOUSES OPPOSITION. OH I'M
SORRY. BRAIN FREEZE OPPOSITION
MOVE ON TO- PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TEST FOR
HEARING ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED.
SEEING NO MOVE WILL MOVE TO THE
KIDS TELECONFERENCE LINE-
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
LINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TEST AND
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. WE HAVE
CERTAIN DUTIES THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
ASK THE ALLOWED THEM SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO SEND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. BORDERLINES NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS-
CALTRAIN RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO OUT. HI
I'M SURE IN A LARGE. AFTER
CARRYING REPRESENTING JERSEY
BRADLEY U. S. SENATE AND
STRONGLY OPPOSE. WELL AT ELEVEN
SEVEN TWO WE BELIEVE IN THE
RIGHTS OF PRIVACY AND THAT'S THE
GOAL THANK YOU VERY FRAZIER FONG
LAST WEEK THE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MA'AM NEXT PLEASE HI THIS
BILL. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
VERY GOOD WE WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS ARE
THERE ANY CENTER HERTZBERG.
YEAH- I SPENT MORE HUNDREDS OF
HOURS NEGOTIATING- WHATEVER
THESE THINGS THE FIRST ONE ON
THE BALLOT FIRST ONE OFF THE
BALLOT AND THE SECOND ONE ON THE
BATH YOU KNOW TOP TWENTY FOUR.
AND IT WAS TOUGH. VERY TOUGH
BECAUSE UNLIKE INDUSTRIES OR YOU
HAVE LIKE LABOR AGAINST
MANAGEMENT THE LINES ARE PRETTY
CLEAR OR THE DOCTORS AGAINST THE
LAWYERS AND THE LIKE AND IT WAS
CLEAR YOU KNOW THE KANA EASIER-
POSITIONS YOU DON'T I MEAN WHEN
YOU HAVE THOSE KINDS OF THINGS.
THIS WAS VERY DIFFERENT BECAUSE-
ALL THESE COMPANIES THAT HAVE
SOUGHT TO MONETIZE THE INTERNET
HAS DONE IT IN DIFFERENT WAYS I
CAN NAME SPECIFIC COMPANIES IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO IS HARD FOR
THEM ON THE ONE HAND. TO TRY TO
COME TO AN AGREEMENT ABOUT
HERE'S WHAT WE WANT VERSE THE
CONSUMER GROUPS RIGHT AND- AND
THE CONSUMER GROUPS BUT WE GET
IT WILL GIVE US A LIST OF FORTY
ONE THINGS WERE GIVEN TWENTY
SEVEN OF THE THINGS IN THE
GROCERY ASIANS BUT YOU KNOW
THEY- DIDN'T UP SOME OF THE NAP
SUPPORTING OF SOME OF THEM DID.
BUT THE THING THAT WAS THE MOST
AGO SHEETED THING HERE WHICH I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT. WAS THE WHAT
DOES IT MEAN TO IMPLEMENT THE
LAW. OKAY EXISTS ALSO GOES TO MR
MAKOWSKI IS MEASURED HERE TO.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO IMPLEMENT
THE LAW. ARE WE GOING TO ALLOW
WE GO THROUGH ALL THIS HEARTACHE
TO GET SOMETHING PASSED BY THE
VOTERS AND THEN THE LEGISLATURE
CAN CHANGE IT IN ANY WAY WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE GUARDRAILS
OR NOT WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE IT
WE DON'T TIME WE GET IN TAX
POLICY WITHOUT LABOR POLICY. WEALL SORTS OF THINGS AND SO ONE
OF THOSE GUARD RAILS LOOK LIKE.
IS THE BIGGEST ISSUE QUITE
FRANKLY LOOK HELLO THE HIP AT
THE PARK RECEIVE IT OFF. BECAUSE
I JUST WAS HERE TO. TO GET.
PRIVATE FACTION BILL. BUT THAT
WAS BASED UPON A DEEPLY WAS
DIFFERENT THIS WAS NEGOTIATED
DEAL. AND SO I JUST WANT TO
REFERENCE THIS BECAUSE I DON'T
SUPPORT THIS BUT WAS SUPPORT
WITH WITH WITH SOME.
QUALIFICATION I THINK YOU KNOW
IN THE DISCUSSION AS WE ENGAGE
IN PRIVACY GOING FORWARD I'M
GONNA BE GONE IN TEN SECONDS OUT
OF THE SHOP AND- THEY'LL BE
SOMEBODY ELSE NEW SITTING IN
THIS SEAT. BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE SOME OF THE
INSTITUTIONAL MEMORY AND IN THAT
REGARD. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS ONE OF THE- BIGGEST ISSUES
THAT WAS NEGOTIATED AMONG
EVERYBODY. WAS IMPLEMENTATION IN
THE WORDS THE BALANCE OUT THE
PROTECTION FOR CONSUMERS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. BUT GOING
FORWARD HOW MUCH FLEXIBILITY
THEY WERE GONNA HAVE. AND HERE
WAS THE DEAL THAT WAS THE
BIGGEST PIECE SECTION. IS C.
PARAGRAPH SIX. THE LAW SHOULD BE
AMENDED IF NECESSARY TO IMPROVE
ITS OPERATIONS. PROVIDED THAT
THE AMENDMENTS DO NOT COMPROMISE. OR WEAKENED CONSUMER PRIVACY.
AB CRITICAL THE- APPROACH TO
ADOPT FOUR WAS NO WEAKENING OF
CONSUMER PRIVACY WHILE GIVING
ATTENTION TO THE IMPACT ON
BUSINESS AND INNOVATION. AND MY
SUGGESTION AND TRYING TO READ
THIS INTO THE RECORD FROM MY
EXPERIENCE WAS THAT THIS WAS THE
LANGUAGE IT WAS TOUGH. BECAUSE
BUSINESSES OH MY GOD IF YOU GET
OUT THERE AND CREATE THESE
CHILLING EFFECT WITH ALL THESE
NEW LAWS THAT THEN. EVERYBODY
COULD SUE US UNDER PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION THAT MAY HAVE A
CHILLING EFFECT ON INNOVATION
AND THAT WAS WHERE THE DELICATE
BALANCE WAS. AND I DON'T ANSWER
I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION YOU WITH RESPECT TO
SENATOR PANTS MEASURE OR CENTER
WOULD HOUSE THESE MEASUREMENTS
SUPPORT THEM BOTH TODAY. BUT I
WANT TO PUT THAT IN THE NATION
OUT THERE BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT- THEY HAVE HONOR
INTEGRITY TO. WHAT WAS DISCUSSED
AMONG ALL THE PARTIES NOW
OBVIOUSLY FUTURE LEGISLATORS
COULD DO WHAT THEY WANT. THEY
CAN INTERPRET ANYWAY THEY DEEM
APPROPRIATE. BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THAT LEVEL OF
HISTORY IN THEIR STANDING OF
WHAT HAPPENED. AND ALL OF THE
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF HOURS
OF NEGOTIATION AND WHY THIS WAS
IMPORTANT AND- DOES THIS GREAT
THAT CHILLING AFFECT WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF. BALANCING THE
CRITICAL MESSAGE THE SAYS YOU
EXPAND CONSUMER RIGHTS WELL NOT
HAVING A CHILLING EFFECT ON
INNOVATION SO WITH THAT. I
WANTED TO. POINT THAT OUT TO THE
HISTORY TO THE COMMITTEE. FROM
SOMEBODY WHO WAS A PERCIPIENT
WITNESS SOME TWELVE HUNDRED
YEARS AGO. AND YEAH THAT SURE
THAT WITH BUT WAS SUPPORTED BUT
WITH THE ADMONITION THAT- I
WOULD HOLD THE RIGHT TO WEAR.
YOU KNOW DEAL WITH IT LATER. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY WITH ANY CONCERNS I HAVE
SOME CONCERNS IN REGARDS TO THE-
C. P. R. R. A. AND- AND THE NEED
TO START MAKING EXCEPTIONS TO
THAT- FOR. THE NEED TO ADD TO IT
WHEN IT REALLY HASN'T BECOME
EFFECTIVE YET AS A TOOL- IN THE
TOOL BOX AND IN ADDITION TO THAT
THE NEED FOR. A THE PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION WHAT Y. EIGHT Y.
E. THAT IN THIS PARTICULAR BILL
YEAH. THE QUESTION AND- SO THANK
YOU CENTERS FOR THE HISTORY
LESSON ALTHOUGH I THINK I WAS
AROUND THE SAME TIME SO I GUESS
WE'RE BOTH TWELVE HUNDRED YEARS.
OLD SO- I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS SOMEONE EMPHASIZE WHICH
ENSURED THAT YOU RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS IS A- I WILL SAY UNIQUE BUT
THIS IS A VULNERABLE POPULATION
RIGHT THESE ARE STUDENTS AND
THEY DON'T HAVE A CHOICE. THEY
HAVE TO DOUBTS AND THE PROCTOR
IN COMPANY IT IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT THEY CHOSE SO THEY DIDN'T
CHOOSE TO USE THIS COMPANY- THE
SCHOOL OR WHOEVER YOU KNOW
WHICHEVER THE THAT THAT
TESTAMENTARY SAID YOU SHALL USE
THIS PRODUCT AND COMPANY- AND-
WHATEVER TRACKING COMPANY WANTS
FROM YOU. YOU HAVE TO PROVIDE
BECAUSE OTHERWISE YOU CAN'T TAKE
THE EXAM AND THAT EXAM MAY BE IN
MANY CASES- MOST OF US THERE'S-
THE EXAMS ARE PRETTY CRITICAL
EIGHT OUT WE CAN'T SAY OH WELL I
WILL TAKE THE EXAM THEN RIGHT.
SO WE HAVE ESSENTIALLY A
POPULATION A GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE. VULNERABLE BECAUSE THEY
THEY THEY DON'T REALLY HAVE A
CHOICE UNLESS THEY WANT TO GIVE
UP THAT CAREER PATH OR WHATEVER
THAT EXAM IS GOING TO LEAD TO. I
THINK THAT CREATES THAT CREATES
A PARTICULAR SITUATION AND ALSO
THE PRICING COMPANY DOESN'T
HAVE. ANY BUILT THEY CAN ASK FOR
WHATEVER THEY WANT AND THERE'S
NO LIMITATIONS THERE. AND SO
THAT'S WHAT THE SEE THIS BILL
SEEKS TO DO IS TO SAY **** YOU
SHOULD BE COLLECTING ALL THE
INFORMATION YOU CAN TRY TO GET
YOU SHOULD BE TO COLLECTING JUST
WHAT YOU NEED. AND ALSO WE NEED
TO BE SO AGAIN TO PROTECT THE
PRIVACY. BECAUSE AND THEN ALSO
HOW LONG YOU HERE HANG ON TO THE
DATA BECAUSE OF SOMEONE HACKS-YOUR DATABASE. ARE YOU
COLLECTING LL THIS BIOMETRIC
DATA AND SOMEONE GETS THAT DATA-
I HOPE YOU'RE NOT SELLING IT BUT
IF SOMEONE GETS THAT DATA
THERE'S NO WAY YOU CAN SWITCH
OUT YOUR EYEBALL IN THE FUTURE
IF SOMEONE REYES STOLE YOU KNOW
YOUR IDENTITY YOU NAME WITH. THE
PHOTOMETRIC DATA RIGHT THAT IT'S
LOST FOREVER IT'S AND IT'S NOW
AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE FOREVER.
SO I THINK THERE'S PARTICULARLY
ONLY TALKING AND MOBILE
POPULATION PARTICULARLY
SENSITIVE AND WE NEED TO BE SURE
THEY GIVE THEM RECOURSE L. I. I.
EASEMENT I'M NOT A PERSON IS
REALLY INTO PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION I'D USUALLY I'M THE ONE
PEOPLE SAYS WELL. BUILT FRAMED
ACTION I'M NOT SUPPORTING IT.
HE'S OF A- YES- BUT I THINK IN
THIS IN THE GALLATIN FOR CASE-
AND CERTAINLY WANT TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITE SO- YOU KNOW WORK WITH
THE TEAM AND CJ AND SO FORTH-
AND A PRIEST APPRECIATE THAT
ACTUALLY WON THE MAJOR
CONTRACTING COMPANIES ACTUALLY
SUPPORTING THIS BILL BECAUSE I
THINK WHEN IT COMES TO
INNOVATION. THEY RECOGNIZE THE
INNOVATION IS GOING TO BE ON HOW
DO I COLLECT MORE AND MORE DATA
ON PEOPLE THE INNOVATIONS HOW
CAN I ACTUALLY DO A BETTER JOB
PRACTICING AND DO IT BETTER
WITHOUT ACTUALLY NEEDING MORE
MORE INFORMATION THAT PUTS
POTENTIALLY CAN PUT THE TEST
TAKER AT RISK THAT THE COMPANY
HAS TO NOT HAVE TO USE IT YOU'LL
HAVE TO HAVE AS MUCH INFORMATION
TO BE ABLE TO STILL DO THE JOB
AND- AND THEN AGAIN OF COURSE
THEIR CUSTOMERS ACTUALLY THE-
TEST ADMINISTRATOR TO SCHOOL OR
WHATEVER BODIES THE TEST
ADMINISTRATOR AND THAT'S THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR INNOVATION. SO
THE L. A. I DO THINK THAT WE
BECAUSE THE END OF ALL THE
POPULATION THE NEED HAVE
RECOURSE- SO WE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT THE
NATURE OF THE P. R. A. BUT- YOU
KNOW THAT THIS IS A SITUATION
WHERE- THE PERSON WHO IS
AFFECTED- FOOD BY THE WAY IS NOW
THEIR RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
COMPANY IS NOT ONE THAT THEY
CHOSE GOOD SIR FORCED UPON THEM.
IS IN A PARTICULARLY HORRIBLE
SITUATION THEY NEED TO HAVE THE
TOOLS THEY NEED TO- TO BE ABLE
TO GET RE COMPANY SENSE IF
THEY'RE IF THEY'RE INJURED OR
DAMAGED BY APPRECIATE THAT AND I
AND I DID HEAR THEIR
UNWILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT. THE THAT IT IT'S RIGHT IN
THE END AND I'LL SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING YOU KNOW HOW IT CHANGES
IN I DO I AM SENSITIVE TO THE
ISSUE OF HERE'S WHO YOU HAVE TO
GO THROUGH AND HERE'S WHAT YOU
HAVE TO DO TAKE IT OR LEAVE IT
AND I THINK YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT IT'S A VULNERABLE
POPULATION WITH NO VERY LIMITED
CHOICE SO. PRECIADO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SAN CABALLERO ALL
RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SO. OVER CHAIR- SIR WOULD LIKE
CLOSE AT ALL I'M SORRY THE NEMO
IS THERE. SIR AWESOME THE BILL
OKAY WELL- A TWO MY ANSWER THE
CLOSE STRICTLY WHEN I WAS THANK
VERY MUCH MA'AM SHE TO BECAUSE
THE ROLL- SURE THIS IS AS ELEVEN
SEVENTY. BY CENTER DR PAN OF THE
MOTION BY CENTER DID US SO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBER. AMBER CABALLERO I SEVEN ZERO I
DID. ASAL SHOULD I SELL ICONS.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG BY JOE. AIR
ON LAYERED HI STERN. WHAT CAN
SKI WHITE HOUSE HE WIENER SIX OF
SIX TO ZERO SO FAR WITH MEMBERS
MISSING I THANK VERY MUCH THANK
CENTER PAN OF ON ALL RIGHT NEXT
WE'RE BACK TO CENTER WHITE SKI
S. B. ONE ZERO NINE NINE. I
REMEMBER FOURTEEN. THANK YOU
RICHARD MEMBERS- AND I HOPE THAT
MY- FIRST FRANK THE BANKRUPTCY
BILL TO MOVE ON CONSENT WAS.
HELLO HELLO US OF REPEATING-
THEME TRYING THIS BILL BUT YOU
KNOW I'M HERE 2% ON- TEN NINETY
NINE. IN THIS ACTUALLY
REPRESENTS MY CAPSTONE
LEGISLATION IN THE SPACE OF
BANKRUPTCY UPDATES IN CALIFORNIA
LAW KEY AMONG THE BILL'S UPDATES
IS HIGHLIGHTED IN THAT VERY GOOD
STAFF REPORT IS ALLOWS THE
DEBTOR TO KEEP A MODEST USE ME
VEHICLE. ITS CREDITORS FROM
TAKING A CAR FROM CONSUMERS IN
BANKRUPTCY WHEN THEY'RE CURRENT
ON THEIR PAYMENTS AND REMOVED
DISINCENTIVES FOR TRUSTEES TO
HOLD ON TO SOMEBODY'S HOUSE WELL
THE PRICE THE EQUITY BUILDS UP
DURING THE PENDENCY OF THE
BANKRUPTCY CASE TO INCREASE THE
SALE VALUE. CAN RELATE TONIGHT A
CONSUMER THE FRESH START WHICH
WITH ME TODAY IS KATHY MORAN
FROM THE RAND LAW GROUP AND I
CUMAN WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATIONS. OF CONSUMER
BANKRUPTCY ATTORNEYS I URGE AN
AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT MISS MORAN
ARE YOU PRESENT TELEPHONICALLY.
ARE YOU HERE. ALL RIGHT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. AT. MY NAME IS
IT KATHY MORAN I'M A MEMBER OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
CONSUMER BANKRUPTCY ATTORNEYS.
THIRTY FIVE SPECIALIST IN
BANKRUPTCY WITH FORTY TWO YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE IN THE SPACE- THE%
AND I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE AD EDITIONS TO SAFETY NET
THAT THE BANKRUPTCY AND
EXEMPTIONS PROVIDE THE
CALIFORNIA DEBTORS I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT. TWO PARTICULAR.
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL THE
FIRST BEING THE EXPANSION. OF
THE EXEMPTION. OF FREE A PRE. IN
AN ASSET THAT IS THE EXAM. THE
BANKRUPTCY LAW PROVIDES AN
EXEMPTION SIR TO TERMINATE ON
THE DATE OF FILING- BUT YOU WEAR
THAT THAT NUMBER IS SIX AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE CASE. WE IN OUR
CURRENT MARKET WE SEE RAPID THE
POSSIBILITY OF RAPID
APPRECIATION DURING THE
BANKRUPTCY CASE. OF THE
BANKRUPTCY CASE MAY GO ON FOR
MONTHS OR EVEN YEARS AT THE
DETERMINATION OF THE BANKRUPTCY
TRUSTEE AND THE DEBTOR HAS NO-
CONTROL OVER HOW LONG THE CASE.
GOES FORWARD THIS BILL WOULD BE
IT. FIFTY FIVE EXEMPTION TO BE
P. P. EXCEPT OUT YOU ON THE OF
THE FILING AND ANY APPRECIATION
THAT OCCURS DURING THE- COURSE
OF THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
CASE. SB WOULD PRETEND THE
TRUSTEES. FROM SPECULATING IN
REAL IN SOMEBODY ELSE'S REAL
ESTATE BYE BYE PROLONGING ARE
DELAYING THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THE CASE IN THE HOPES THAT AT A
HOUSE THAT WAS FULLY EXEMPT AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE CASE. WILL
APPRECIATE FACTS THAT THE THAT
THE TRUSTEE CAN. PUT THE HOUSE
ON THE MARKET AND IT AND SELL IT
OUT FROM. UNDER THE DEBTOR. AND
I THOUGHT THIS IN EVERY. K. FOR
IN MY OFFICE WHERE THE DEBTORS.
X. OF. EXEMPT EQUITY EQUALED
BLUES THE DEBT PLUS THE
EXEMPTION BUT INSTEAD IT WAS NOT
ABLE TO THE FINAL BANKRUPTCY FOR
FEAR THAT IN THE MONTHS THAT THE
CASE MIGHT GO ON THE MARKET GOES
UP AND HE WOULD FIND AT THE
HOUSE THAT WAS FULLY EXEMPT AND
AVAILABLE TO HIM AND HIS FAMILY
FOR A FRESH START ALL OF A
SUDDEN BECOMES- FODDER FOR A
SALE BY A BANKRUPTCY TRUSTEE. I
THINK THIS DESCRIPTION. PROVIDE
CERTAINTY ENDED. CONSISTENCY
WITH IDEA THAT IT. ARE A STEP ON
THE DAY OF THE- AND- BETTER NOT
FEAR. THE. HE ASIAN THAT MIGHT.
FIND IT MIGHT PROVOKE A FAILED
ATTENDING YOU MISS- THE YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY BUT- MISTER SHE
ARE YOU AVAILABLE. I YES I AM-
CHAIRMAN THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THE TESTIFIED TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF. SB TEN NINETY
NINE- I'VE BEEN IN PRACTICE A
BANKRUPTCY LAWYER IN SAN JOSE
FOR THE PAST THIRTY SIX YEARS.
TESTIFYING TODAY. ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
CONSUMER BANKRUPTCY ATTORNEYS.
DOES IT SOLVE PAST PRESIDENT AND
CURRENT CULTURE BECAUSE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR WILL COLLEGE FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL. WHICH
WILL HELP MANY CALIFORNIA
STRUGGLING WITH THAT. SB SEVEN
NINETY NINE MAKES SEVERAL
MEANINGFUL IMPROVEMENTS.
INCLUDING FOR ALL THINGS A
SUPPORT GROUP FOR PARENTS WERE
OLD BACK SUPPORT HELPING THE
DISABLED. WHO ARE NEED A VEHICLE
IS THEM IN GETTING AROUND ALL OF
THESE THINGS THE BILL WILL HELP
- CALIFORNIA FAMILIES GET A
FRESH START AFTER SEEKING
BANKRUPTCY RELIEF. THERE TO
PROVISIONS WHICH I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT. FIRST THE
BILL WILL STOP THE PRODUCTION OF
VEHICLES OWNED BY THE OWNERS OR
OTHERWISE CURRENT. ON THEIR LOAN
PAYMENTS. TO A CLOUD BANKRUPTCY. CURRENTLY A CAR WONDER CAN
READ OF THEIR THAT HIS CAR. ONLY
FILL IN THE BLANKS FOR.
ACCORDING THE FULL OF. THEY
CONTRACTUAL THE FOR. TITLE THEM
TO REAP BECAUSE- SB TEN NINETY
NINE FOR A THIS. I COULD THE BAY
YOU THE MOLD. NOT BE CONSIDERED
TO BE. WILLIAM A SECOND GROUP OF
THE BILL BOB CALIFORNIA SAFE
HOMES BUT KEPT UP ON THIS
PROPERTY TAX PAYMENTS. UNDER
CURRENT LAW TO PROBABLY DO HAVE
TO DO TO. BUT BE REPAID WITH
EIGHTEEN PER OF. AN AMOUNT FAR
X. MARC INTEREST RATE SEEN IN
OUR STATE OVER THE PAST FEW
DECADES. THE STREET THE NORMS
FINANCIAL BURDEN ON HOMEOWNERS.
WE ARE RETURNING THE PAST DUE
TAXES CHAPTER THIRTEEN
BANKRUPTCY PLANS. THE HOMEOWNERS
WILL FALL BEHIND THE PROPERTY
CHRISTMAS SHOW MOVING HAD
WRAPPED UP. SURE THE- THE
CAPITEC ON THIS ARE THIS WOULD A
BIG HELP TO HOMEOWNERS SITTING
THERE ALREADY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY- OTHER IS AND EMAIL
AND THE ROOM HOW SING NO ONE THE
MICROPHONE NOW OPPOSITION UP
EXCUSE ME STRIKE THAT LET ME GO
TO THE PHONES- THOSE ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT MOTOR IF YOU WE
QUEUE THEM UP IN SUPPORT OF SB.
ONE ZERO NINE NINE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB AT ONE ZERO NINE NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE IF THEY AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT
FROM. ALL RIGHT LET'S NOW TURN
TO OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE-
IN OPPOSITION YES I SEE THANK GO
AHEAD SIR. WE HAVE OF THE
JUDGMENT PRESS A LINE. AND SOME
OF THE- SECTION THANKS THE
APPROACH HOOVER CONCERN- I JUST
WANNA APOLOGISE TO CENTER BY CAL
SKI I WAS JUST RETAIN OVER THE
WEEKEND SO WHEN ABLE TO. GET HIM
A LETTER BUT LOOKING FORWARD TO
HAVING FURTHER CONVERSATIONS BUT
I DO JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THIS
ONE PARTICULAR ISSUE RELATING TO
THE HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION. WHICH
ALL RECALL IN TWENTY TWENTY
LEGISLATURE PASSED IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE WHICH EXPONENTIALLY
INCREASED THE HOMESTEAD
EXEMPTION- AND IT'S NOT EVEN
BEEN FIFTEEN MONTHS OR MAYBE
THIS IS FIFTEEN MONTHS THAT THAT
HAS NOT BEEN IN PLACE. AND NOW
WE'RE LOOKING TO INCREASE IT
EVEN MORE BY TAPPING OR BY
ALLOWING THE- APPRECIATION ON A
HOME AFTER BANKRUPTCY HAS BEEN
FILED- THAT'S NOT FORGET THAT
THE DEBTORS DOES OWE THE MONEY
TO WERE THE CREDITORS. AND THERE. HAS BEEN A JUDGMENT THAT THEY
OWE IT TO THEM. IF THERE IS THE
ABILITY PAY NOT. FUNDS THAT CAN
GO BACK TO CREDITORS WE'RE NOT
JUST TALKING LARGE CREDIT CARD
COMPANIES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SMALL BUSINESSES. PEOPLE WHO ARE
ABLE TO RECEIVE SOMETHING
THROUGH A JUDGMENT. OF BECAUSE
OF A LAWSUIT- THEY WILL NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO GET THOSE
FUNDS BECAUSE WEALTHY
INDIVIDUALS WE ABLE TO SHIELD
THEIR MONEY. IN THEIR EXPENSIVE
HOMES SO WE WITH US AT LEAST OF
THAT PROVISION BE REMOVED THEIR
OTHER PROVISIONS IN THE BILL.
THAT MY CLIENT DOES HAVE
CONCERNS WITH BUT WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS WITH CENTER
WACHOWSKI. AS A BILL MOVES
FORWARD TO ITS NEXT POLICY
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR- OTHERS IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED OPPOSITIONSAYING NO
WHEN APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE
LET'S TURN TO THE PHONES. THOSE
IN OPPOSITION. OF MODERATE
VIEWED CUE THEM UP. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO ADD BE AT ONE ZERO NINE NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE DAY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IT'LLJUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THE FIRST COMMENT. BY
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
LINK IT PRIMARILY DEAL HIM OF A
CON ARTIST I'D SAY NO TO THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THIS BILL THANK
YOU I'D ONE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
GO OUT. THANK YOU CLIFF BURKE
FOR CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLECTORS WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL AS AMENDED WITH JUST A
MOMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIDE FIFTEEN QUID FOR
. YES MY NAME IS GRETCHEN
LYNCHING BURGER AND MY COMPANY
IS JUSTICE MATTERS AND WE
REPRESENT REPORTS OF
PROFESSIONAL AND WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SENATE BILL TEN
NINETY NINE. THANK YOU. IT I
HAVE NO PER COMMENT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT BRING IT BACK
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS SAYING NON
COMMON SAYING NON- IS THERE A
MOTION. WHO CENTER LAYERED MOST
THE BILL OR CENTER HERTZBERG
MOVES ABOUT. YEAH THE CARD OUT
THERE TWELVE HUNDRED YEARS YEAH
. HELLO USING BEFORE YOU SO I-
ALL RIGHT CENTER HERTZBERG MOVES
THE BILL SO I CAN ASK YOU CARE
CLOSE YES I'D MR JUST THE
GENERAL PRINCIPLE THAT WE HAVE
IN BANKRUPTCY IS THE SNAPSHOT OF
THE RULES WORK ON THE DATE OF
THE FILING THAT FIXES YOUR CAT
THAT FIXTURE- OF. ASSETS IN THIS
IS CONSISTENCY THROUGHOUT THE
LAW WE HOPE TO CORRECT THIS
LITTLE LOOPHOLE THEY HAPPEN AYE
PERCH AYE VOTE. ALREADY THANK
YOU- NEXT WE HAVE- I'M SORRY I'M
I'M GETTING WAY AHEAD OF MYSELF-
THE MEDIC CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU
WOULD CALL THE ROLL. THANK YOU.
THIS IS SENATE BILL TEN NINETY
NINE BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE VIEW
THE MOTION BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE. UMBERG FIVE UMBERG BY
FORTIS. BURGESS HI TERRY IT'LL-
ZERO I DID I SAW. THE DRESS SO I
GONZALEZ HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
JONES. LAYERED. LAYERED ICE
STERN. WHITE HOUSE SKI HI WHITE
HOUSE I WIENER. WIENER AYE.
FORTY EIGHT ZERO SO FAR WITH
MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT- WILL
PUT THE BILL ON CALL SO- WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO NOW IS I'M GOING
TO OPEN THE ROLE I KNOW THERE'S
SOME MEMBERS THAT HAVE CONFLICTS
IN TERMS OF TIME WHEN OPEN THE
ROLE OF TO ALLOW MEMBERS TO VOTE
ON ANY BILL THAT HAS PREVIOUSLY
BEEN HEARD THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR- THE LAST TWO CENTER HITE
HOUSE HE'S BILLS I'M GONNA HEAR
MY TWO BILLS AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO- CALL THE ROLL FOR A
FINAL TIME. SO MANY CHIEF
COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CURRENTLY CURRENT
OUTSTANDING MATTERS WITH TIME
YES. IN I WILL YES THROW WE'RE
GONNA OPEN THE AND START WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I CAPITAL CAPITAL
HI GONZALEZ. JONES STERN WIENER
WIENER I STILL MEMBERS MISSING
BUT THE BILL BACK ON CALL. THE
NEXT BILL IS S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR BY SENATOR CORTEZ SAY
THAT'S S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
BY SENATOR CORTEZ HE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I. BORDERS NO
BORDERS NO GONZALEZ HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HI JONES STERN. WIENER
WIENER I AM STILL A MEMBERS
MISSING ALONG CALL. THE NEXT
BILL IS S. B. TEN FIFTY FIVE BY
SENATOR KAMLAGER THAT'S S. B.
TEN FIFTY FIVE BY SENATOR
KAMLAGER WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
HI. THIS IS. YES WITH AMENDMENTS
ABSOLUTELY- BORDERS BURGESS NO
GONZALEZ. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE JONES STERN THERE'S WIENER
RIGHT WIENER FIVE ON THAT ONE AS
WELL SURE THIS IS S. B. TEN
FIFTY FIVE BY SENATOR KAMLAGER
BUT THE CHAIR VOTING I AND IT'S
A BILL WITH AMENDMENTS. OF
COURSE. FIVE SORRY GONZALEZ
JONES STERN STERN I STILL WITH
THE MEMBER MISSING SENATOR BACK
ON CALL. THE NEXT BILL IS S. B.
ELEVEN FORTY NINE BY SENATOR
LEAVE THAT THAT'S S. B. ELEVEN
FOURTEEN NINE BY LEYVA WITH
AMENDMENTS. FORGE'S GORGEOUS NO
CABALLERO. GONZALEZ HERTZBERG.
JONES WHITE HOUSE SKI. WIENER
RIGHT WIENER I STILL HAVE
MEMBERS MISSING ON THAT ONE
RIGHT BACK ON CALL. THE NEXT
BILL IS S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO
BY SENATOR PAN THAT'S S. B.
ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR
PAN. WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI
PORGES PORTIS NO GONZALEZ JONES
STERN STERN AYE WIENER. THIS
WINNER BY IS TO HAVE BEEN BIRDS
MISSING ON THAT ONE THAT PHONE
CALL THE NEXT BILL IS BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG IT'S S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN THAT'S SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
HI BOARD YES. GUERRIERO
RELUCTANTLY I. CABALLERO HI
GONZALEZ. JONES WIENER WIENER
AYE MEMBERS MISSING. ALL RIGHT
BACK ON CALL THE NEXT BILLS S.
B. TEN TWENTY SIX BY SENATOR Y.
CASKEY THAT'S S. B. TEN TWENTY
SIX BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI-
WITH AMENDMENTS OF COURSE AND
THE AND THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
PORGES. GORGEOUS NO GONZALEZ
HERTZBERG. S. B. TEN TWENTY SIX
BY WHITE HOUSE HE- HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HI WINNER WINNER I
MEMBERS MISSING BILLS BACK ON
CALL. I'M SORRY YOUR NO YOU'RE
HERE AND THIS IS AGAIN THIS IS
S. B. TEN TWENTY SIX THE ONLY
MEMBER MISSING IS A MEMBER WHO'S
NOT GOING TO BE HERE TODAY ALL
RIGHT THEN THE BILLS OUT YES
THANK YOU. THE NEXT BILL IS
SENATE SB TEN NINETY NINE BY
SENATOR. CASKEY EVERYONE HERE
VOTED ON I DON'T KNOW SORRY SB
TEN NINETY NINE BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI. CHAIR VOTING AYE
GONZALEZ JONES STERN- STERN I
SUPPORT THAT'S NINE TWO ZERO
THERE'S A MEMBER MISSING ON THAT
ONE BACK ON CALL. SO THANK YOU
NEXT WE HAVE S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY
NINE CONCERNING BIOMETRIC
INFORMATION BY CENTER WACO SKI.
YES MR AND MEMBERS FIRST LET ME
START OFF BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS HAS- BY THE COMMITTEE
AS OUTLINED IN OUR ANALYSIS AND
THINK TO CONSULT FOR WORKING
WITH- MY OFFICE AND THIS. AS
CENTER HERTZBERG. INTE INDICATED
INCENTER PANS BILL WE HOPE TO
TWEAK IT THAT NICE BALANCE HERE
OF IN S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE
OF PROTECTING CONSUMER PRIVACY
EXPANDING ON IT BY REQUIRING
THAT PRIVATE ENTITIES A TEAM
AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT BEFORE
COLLECTING AND DISCLOSING THIS
BIOMETRIC INFORMATION IT FURTHER
PROHIBITS PRIVATE ENTITIES FROM
SELLING TRADING AND USING FOR
ADVERTISING PURPOSES OR
OTHERWISE PROFITEERING FROM THE
DISCLOSURE OF PERSON'S BIOMETRIC
INFORMATION HIT THE CONSENT YOU
CAN USE THE INFORMATION
BIOMETRIC INFORMATION INVOLVES
IMMUTABLE AND HIGHLY DISTINCTIVE
TRAITS SUCH AS THE RICHES OF
YOUR FINGERNAILS. THE TEXTURE
AND COLOR FOR YOUR SKIN'S THE
GEOMETRIC ATTRIBUTES OF YOUR
FACE THESE ARE TRAITS FULL
COMPLETE TIED TO YOUR PERSONAL
IDENTITIES UNLIKE A PASSWORD OR
PIN CODE WHEN COMPROMISED-
LEAGUE BIOMETRICS CAN EASILY BE
CHANGED THIS UNIQUENESS IS PART
OF WHAT MAKES BIOMETRIC.
INFORMATION SO VALUABLE
BIOMETRICS CAN BE USED TO
AUTHENTICATE IDENTIFICATION
PINPOINT INDIVIDUALS FROM A ROOF
VERY LARGE CROWD AND EVEN TRACK
YOUR MOVEMENT IN OTHER WORDS BY
MEXICO RICK BIOMETRIC
INFORMATION FAT FASTLY EMPOWERS
SURVEILLANCE TOOLS. ALTHOUGH
THIS MAY HAVE SECURITY BENEFITS
IT'S CRITICAL TO CONSIDER HOW
WIDESPREAD USE THE BIOMETRIC
IMPACTS ON FREE SPEECH AND FREE
ASSOCIATION AND OTHER
CORNERSTONES OF OUR DEMOCRATIC
SOCIETY CAN BE AND HOW THIS
OFTEN DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS
MINORITY COMMUNITIES. ALSO
CONCERNING IS THAT THESE
PHYSICAL CHARACTERISTICS MAY
GIVE COMPANIES THE ABILITYTO
FIND OUT OUR PREFERENCES AND OUR
EMOTIONS ALTHOUGH THE TECHNOLOGY
IS FAR FROM PERFECT MANY
COMPANIES ARE INVESTING HEAVILY
IN EMOTION DETECTION AND
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE. AMAZON FOR
INSTANCE HAS OUR OWN PROPRIETARY
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE DUBBED
AMAZON RECOGNITION AND APPLE
PURCHASED EMOTION IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN ACCOMPANIED IT
LOOKS TO ESTIMATE THE MOTION
FROM YOUR FACIAL PRINCE. IT MAY
SOUND SCIENCE LIKE SCIENCE
FICTION BUT LET ME ASSURE YOU
THAT BIOMETRICS ARE EX ARE
ACTIVELY BEING INCORPORATED INTO
THE ACTIVITIES SUCH AS JOB
RECRUITMENT DRIVING FINANCING
AND EVEN MARKETING A NUMBER OF
TECHNOLOGY FIRMS HAVE PARTNERED
WITH PRIVATE COMPANIES TO
ANALYZE. THE FACE THE FACES OF
JOB APPLICANTS AND FOR. EMOTION
OR PERSONALITY TRAITS AND
FINALLY I MENTIONED AT THE START
TECHNOLOGY IS FAR FROM PERFECT
S. IS TO IS FAR TOO OFTEN THE
CASE WHEN THE TECHNOLOGY- DOES
FIELD IT TENDS TO HURT PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND MINORITY COMMUNITIES
THE MOST. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN JUST AS ONE EXAMPLE-
GENTLEMAN NIGER PARKS OF NEW
JERSEY WAS WRONGFULLY ARRESTED.
AFTER BEING MISIDENTIFIED BY
FACIAL RECOGNITION SYSTEM
DESPITE BEING THIRTY MILES AWAY
FROM THE SCENE OF THE ALLEGED
CRIME PARK SPENT TEN DAYS IN
JAIL BEFORE POLICE ADMITTED
THEIR MISTAKE MISTER PARKS IS AT
LEAST THE THIRD PERSON. TO BE
FALSELY ARRESTED DUE TO A FAULTY
FACIAL RECOGNITION SYSTEM AND
ALL THREE THE OTHERS WERE A
BLACK MAN THIS IS NOT A ONE OFF
PROBLEM IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. A
TWENTY EIGHTEEN STUDY. SHOWED
THAT FACE IDENTIFICATION SYSTEMS
MISIDENTIFIED WOMEN OF COLOR AT
MORE THAN FORTY TIMES TO READ OF
WHITE MEN RESEARCHERS HAVE ALSO
SHOWN THAT FACIAL RECOGNITION
SOFTWARE INTERPRETS BLACK FACES
IS HAVING MORE NEGATIVE EMOTION
THEY MIGHT FACES IT'S IMPORTANT
TO REMEMBER THAT BIOMETRICS ARE
OFTEN FED INTO ALGORITHMS- THAT
REPRODUCE SOCIETAL PREJUDICES.
IT'S THE REASON WHY ALL RHYTHMS
HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY ADVERTISE
HIGH PAYING JOBS TO MEN OVER
WOMEN AND WHILE MORTGAGE
APPROVAL L. CORRECT THEM CENTER.
PEOPLE OF COLOR. IT'S ALSO THE
REASON WHY WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT WHEN IT COMES TO SOMETHING
SO SENSITIVE AS OUR BIOMETRIC
INFORMATION CIVIC. SUFFICIENT
GUARDRAILS- EMPATE PLACE IT'S AS
IF STAFF REPORT PARTS POINTS OUT
THIS IS A FASTLY DEVELOPING
INDUSTRY AND THEY EXPECTING FOR
FIVE YEARS TO REVENUES AT THEM
OR THE MARKET TO REACH EIGHTY
TWO POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS.
SO IT'S NOT. THE INTENTION OF
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE TO HAMPER
TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGICAL
INNOVATION IS THAT REPRESENT
THAT AREA INSTEAD ELEVEN EIGHTY
NINE LOOKS TO ENSURE THAT GUARD
RAILS ARE IN PLACE. AND ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE A SAY IN HOW
THE DADDY ISSUES AND A MEANS OF
DEFENDING THEMSELVES WHEN THAT
SAY IS TAKEN AWAY AND HERE TO
TESTIFY IS ADAM SCHWARTZ A
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY FOR THE
EXTRAS FRONTIER FOUNDATION I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. SO SIR
BECAUSE YOU JUST TO BE CLEAR YOU
ACCEPTED THE- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
EVERYONE OF THEM EVERYONE OF
THEM AND ALSO JUST TO BE CLEAR
THIS DOES NOT PROHIBIT FOR
EXAMPLE FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY IT DOES NOT ARE. OKAY
SO- MISTER SCHWARTZ IF YOU'RE
HERE. AS MISTER ALL RIGHT THERE
YOU GO GO AHEAD. HI ON BEHALF OF
THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND ARE THOUSANDS OF
MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY IN FLORIDA SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY NINE. MANY THANKS ALSO TO
SENATOR LIKE HOUSEKEEPER
INTRODUCING IT THE BILL WOULD
PLACE COMMONSENSE LIMITS ON HOW
PRIVATE ENTITIES PROCESS
BIOMETRIC INFORMATION. I ADDRESS
OUR EIGHT THREATEN TO PERSON
PRIVACY RACIAL JUSTICE FREAKS BY
. TRANSFORMATION INTO. WHAT WE
GO IT IS FOR A PEOPLE CAPTURE
OUR BIOMETRICS SUCH AS OUR PAPER
AND WHITE PLAINS. WHAT HAPPENS
WITH CHANGE OR BUYING METRICS
UNLIKE A CREDIT CARD NUMBERS OR
EVEN OUR NAMES. BETTER BY
MEASURE TO BE USED TO IDENTIFY
AND TRACK US AND DRAW INFERENCES
ABOUT US. WHAT WE CAN DO IT
INDIVIDUAL TO PROTECT. OURSELVES
FROM BIOMETRIC SURVEILLANCE. THE
COMPANY. A. I. HAS COLLECTED
FIFTY FROM BILLIONS OF PEOPLE TO
BE. WITHOUT PERMISSION AND NOW
WANT TO GET A PRINT FROM EVERY
PERSON ON EARTH. THE SELF THE
SERVICE IDENTIFYING SUSPECTS FOR
EXAMPLE POLICE PAID CLEAR VIEW
TO IDENTIFY A. B. L. M.
PROTESTER PROBLEM HERE IS THE
COLLECTION OF PATRONS WITHOUT
OPTION CONSENT PEOPLE TO PROTEST
AND FROM THE PUBLIC AT LARGE.
CONSIDER THE CASE OF LET ME-
ROBINSON AFRICAN AMERICAN T.
PUBLIC SKATING RINK CHECK AROUND
BECAUSE THEY COLLECT A FACE
PRINT FROM EVERY PATRON AND
MISIDENTIFIED HER IF SOMEONE
ELSE. IS TECHNOLOGIES MAKE
MISTAKES ESPECIALLY OUT TO WOMEN
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR AS SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE HE EXPLAINED. ALSO
THESE CAN BE THERE COULD BE
DISCRIMINATION AND THE
TECHNOLOGIES ARE POINTED. APPLE
EIGHT WRITER STUDY FOUND THAT A
DRUG STORE CHAIN RITE AID BUT
FAR MORE LIKELY TO SCREEN
PATRONS WITH FACE RECOGNITION AT
THE STORE IS LOCATED IN LOWER
INCOME. AND NON WHITE
NEIGHBORHOODS- AND HIGHER INCOME
AND WHITE NEIGHBORHOODS. ALL OF
US TO BE ABLE TO WALK INTO A
STORE WITHOUT THE MANAGEMENT
TAKING OUR BIOMETRICS WITHOUT
OUR PERMISSION IT HELPS MATCHING
UP AGAINST THE LIST OF UNWANTED
PATRONS. ALL THE PROBLEMS SB
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE WOULD REQUIRE
PRIVATE ENTITIES TO DO FOUR
THINGS FIRST. OBTAIN OPT IN
CONSENT FROM THE PERSON BEFORE
COLLECTING THEIR BIOMETRIC OR
DISPOSING THEM. SECOND THE STORE
THE FINAL TRICKS THIRD DON'T
TELL THE FINAL TRICKS AND FOURTH
WEEK OF I. WITH A YEAR. THE
PROVIDE FOR CONSUMER ENFORCED OF
THE FOR. SB EIGHTY NINE IS MY ON
THE OTHER SIDE NATURE
INFORMATION PRIVACY OKAY BACK.
THE MOST IMPORTANT PRIVATE
STATUTE IN THE COUNTRY. TIME TO
COME BRING IT PROTECT TO THE OF
CALIFORNIA. I THANK YOU VERY
BRIEF ADDRESSED TO CONSERVE
RAISED ABOUT BILL FIRST THE
NATIONAL PAYROLL REPORTING
CONSORTIUM HAD SUGGESTED THE
BILL WILL ADVERSELY IMPACT
BIOMETRIC TIME CLOCKS. PEOPLE
PUNCHING IN WITH A CONFERENCE
FOR EXAMPLE. THE BILL EMPLOYERS
TO CONDITION APPOINTMENT ON
COLLECTION AND DISCLOSURE OF
BIOMETRICS ALONG WITH THE
EMPLOYEE SIGNED A WRITTEN
RELEASE. NOTICE AND RELEASE
FORMS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
DEVELOPED BY BOTH VENDORS AND
EMPLOYERS. LAWYER IS GOING TO
PROCESS ITS EMPLOYEES BY METRICS
IT'S REASONABLE TO NOTE REQUIRE
ALSO NOTICED SECURE STORAGE AND
OTHER SALES OF THIS INFORMATION
BUT CONSENT IS NOT REQUIRED FROM
EMPLOYEES. SECOND THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HAS RAISED CONCERNS
ABOUT CONSUMER ENFORCEMENT.
ENFORCEMENT IS A STANDARD
FEATURE OF FEDERAL AND OTHER
PRIVACY LEGISLATION. WITHOUT IT
SUCH LAWS GO UNENFORCED FOR
EXAMPLE IT TOOK THE TEXAS
ATTORNEY GENERAL YOU'RE THE
THIRTEEN YEARS DURING ITS FIRST
ACTION TO ENFORCE THAT STATE
BIOMETRIC PRIVACY LAW AND ACTION
WHICH OF THE COPYCATS OF
SUCCESSFUL CONSUMER LITIGATION
UNDER. ALSO THE STATUTORY
DAMAGES IN SB ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE
ARE MUCH LOWER THAN OTHER ONE
HUNDRED TO A THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER THOUSAND A FIVE TO. SO AGAIN
WE ASK FOR YOUR YES VOTE ON SB
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MISTER
SCHWARTZ ANYONE ELSE HERE IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED WAS
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE SEEING KNOWN
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE BUT-
IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE ON
THE PHONE. WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
NINE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. R.
LIVE IN EIGHTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE. ZERO ACTIVE. ON THE- RIGHT
ONE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU AROUND ONE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. REMEMBER
CATALINA SANCHEZ WITH CORBIN
TIGHTER HERE ON BEHALF OF
PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE THE
PROUD CO SPONSOR AND INSTRUCT
THE PORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WON SEVENTY PLEASE
GO OUT. FINALLY FAMOUS MILITARY
CLICK YOUR FOUNDATION BEING ON
BEHALF OF SECURE TOUGHEST ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND THE GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE COLLECT. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON TRACY ROSENBERG
CALLING ON BEHALF OF OAKLAND
PRIVACY TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
FOR S. B. ONE ONE EIGHT NINE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I WON FIFTY
EIGHT PRECOURT. THE NUTCRACKER
THE CONSUMER JOURNEY OF THE
CALIFORNIA TERMS THE COURT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THINK. ALL RIGHT LET'S
NOT TURN TO THE OPPOSITION I
SEE- MISTER. DILLON HOFFMAN AND
RONAK- DAYLAMI YES SIR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN PERSON THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR RIGHT NOT DAYLAMI
AGAIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
NINE AS A JOB KILLER. BASED ON
WHAT WE'VE ALREADY SEEN WITH THE
ILLINOIS BIOMETRIC INFORMATION
PRIVACY ACT WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
THIS BILL POTENTIALLY ELIMINATE
CONSUMER PRODUCTS OR SERVICES
EXPERTS COMPANIES A COSTLY CLASS
ACTIONS BASED ON TECHNICAL
VIOLATIONS WITHOUT ANY SHOW OF
HARM AND LIMIT THEIR WORK FORCE.
AND AUTHORIZING WHAT WE CAN ONLY
DESCRIBE AS A POTENTIALLY
CRIPPLING PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
EFFECTIVELY AND UNNECESSARILY
CIRCUMVENTS THE PURPOSEFUL
PUBLIC POLICY DECISION TO
ESTABLISH A LIMITED PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION UNDER THE CCPA
FOR DATA BREACHES OF PROTECTED
PERSONAL INFORMATION. SIMPLY
STATED WE SEE NO NEED TO ENACT A
SECONDARY STATUTES GOVERNING
BIOMETRICS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LET ALONE ONE WITH
SENSE WITH SUCH EXTENSIVE
LIABILITY ATTACHED AT THIS TIME-
PARTICULARLY WHEN THE SECURITY
IS NOT YET FULLY IN EFFECT
TONIGHT. REALLY QUICKLY JUST
WANT TO KNOW OF ALL THE STATES
THAT HAPPENED A STATUTES COURSE
EASY PAY TYPE STATUTE ONLY
ILLINOIS HAS A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION. PLEASE BEAR IN MIND
ILLINOIS ENACTED THAT PASSED THE
TIME WHEN SMARTPHONES WERE AMONG
THE NEWEST TECHNOLOGY A FULL
DECADE BEFORE THE STATE PASSED
ITS LANDMARK DATA PRIVACY
PROTECTION LAW THE CCPA. AS WE
PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED THE C. P.
C. C. C. PH. REPRESENTED A
MASSIVE PUBLIC POLICY SHIFT IN
THE STATE TO PROTECT ALL.
PERSONAL INFORMATION INCLUDING
BIOMETRIC INFORMATION AND A
COMPREHENSIVE TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL
AND INDUSTRY NEUTRAL MANNER TO
BE CLEAR STATES THAT HAVE A
PROPOSED THAT YOU DO NOT HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE PRIVACY LAWS LIKE
THE CCPA. THIS IS A HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE LAW DO NOT HAVE IT
BUT THE ONE OR TWO. NOR DO THEY
NEED ONE EXCUSE ME. IN ADDITION
CONCERNS AROUND THE OVERLY BROAD
DEFINITION OF BIOMETRIC
INFORMATION THAT CAPTURES DATA
NOT USED TO IDENTIFY A PERSON
THE LACK OF REASONABLE
EXEMPTIONS. SUCH AS FOR FRAUD
PREVENTION OR SECURITY CONFUSION
AROUND FOR HAVING PROFITS FROM
THE DISCLOSURE BY METRICS. AND
IMPACT THAT HAS ON THE
AVAILABILITY OF PRODUCTS OR
SERVICES. AND OPERABILITY ISSUES
OF THE CCPA INCLUDING QUESTIONS
ON THE APPLICATION EXEMPTIONS
WERE CONCERNED THIS BILL SIGNALS
A RETURN TO PIECEMEAL APPROACH.
TO DATA PRIVACY RIGHTS EXISTED
PRE TWENTY EIGHTEEN UNDERMINE
THE PURPOSE AND AFFECTS ABOUT
LAW. SO I'LL JUST AND MY
COMMENTS WITH THIS AT SOME POINT
I THINK WE HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES
IF WE WANT TO CREATE A SYSTEM
THAT IS MORE ABOUT LAYERING
OBLIGATION UPON OBLIGATION. TO
ENSURE MORE MORE IT'S A SUIT
THAT IS ABOUT PROTECTING
CONSUMER DATA AND A WORKABLE
AND- THEREFORE MEANINGFUL MANNER
FOR THESE REASONS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MR
OFTEN. I GET THE MOST THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS DON'T OFTEN
ON BEHALF OF TECHNO WE'RE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO S. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE. I'LL JUST
QUICKLY ALIGN MY COMMENTS- WITH
THE CHAMBER. I WANT TO QUICKLY
JUST EXPAND ON A COUPLE OF
POINTS- FIRST AS NOTED STATES
THAT HAVE ENACTED BIOMETRIC
SPECIFIC LAWS LIKE THIS BILL ALL
LACK A COMPARABLE STATUTE TO
CBRE- AND AS NOTED ONLY ONE OF
THOSE HAS. A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION ILLINOIS. SO WHEN WE SAY
THAT THIS BILL WILL CREATE
UNTENABLE LEGAL LIABILITY- FOR
COMPANIES AND CAUSE THEM TO
REDUCE PRODUCT OFFERINGS. IT'S
NOT A HYPOTHETICAL- IT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENED IN ILLINOIS- SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THERE'S BEEN
OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED CLASS ACTION
CASES IN ILLINOIS AGAINST TECH
AND NON TECH COMPANIES ALIKE.
OFTEN IN SMALLER IN STATE
COMPANIES- THE NET EFFECT OF
BOURBON ILLINOIS HAS BEEN TO
CREATE A COTTAGE INDUSTRY OF
CLASS. ACTION LAW FIRMS AND TO
PREVENT COMPANIES AND CONSUMERS
FROM DEVELOPING. OR ACCESSING
PROCHAN SUMER PRO PRIVACY USES.
BIOMETRIC DATA LIKE BUILDING
SECURITY. USER AUTHENTICATION
FRAUD PREVENTION IT'S OUR-
COMPANY'S OF PULL PRODUCTS OR
DON'T OFFER CERTAIN FEATURES TO
ILLINOIS RESIDENTS- DEVICES THAT
DISPENSE MEDICINE SAFELY USING
BIOMETRICS. IDENTITY THEFT
PREVENTION MEASURES USED BY
BANKS. AND OTHER FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS AND MARK.
ADDITIONALLY RECENT AMENDMENTS
INCLUDE A REQUIREMENT THAT IF A
PERSON EXERCISE THE RIGHT SOME
OF THIS BILL THE COMPANY HAS TO
PROVIDE THE SAME LEVEL OF
SERVICE OR QUALITY OF OCCURRED
AND IN MANY INSTANCES- THIS
ISN'T POSSIBLE- FOR EXAMPLE
SERVICE THAT USES A BIOMETRIC
SECURITY FEATURE THANK- CAN'T
PROVIDE THE SAME LEVEL FRAUD
PROTECTION IF SOMEONE OPTS OUT-
FOR THESE THEIR BIOMETRICS
BIOMETRIC SIR. AS NOTED
IMMUTABLE- THEY OFFER THE
GREATEST LEVEL OF SECURITY- AND
SO WE CAN'T OFFER THE SAME LEVEL
SECURITY IF YOU OPT OUT OF THAT
THE USE OF THAT- SAID THAT THEN
WOULD THEN BE GROUNDS FOR A
LAWSUIT- FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY NINE LOOK ORWARD TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION. THANK
YOU BRING HIM STRUGGLING. OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION. AS CHAIR MEMBERS
FEELING GRIEVES WITH BY A COME
CALIFORNIAN ON BEHALF OF OUR
FIFTEEN HUNDRED. LIFE SCIENCE
MEMBER COMPANIES RESPECTFULLY
POST THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRED MEMBERS CAME TO ME TREE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION AND PRECIADO THE WORK
OF THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSOR.
THANK YOU. STRUCTURE MEMBERS
JOHN LINGER ON BEHALF OF THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ADVAMED IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU- ALL THE
PHONE LINES THOSE ON THE PHONE
LINE. IN OPPOSITION IF YOU WOULD
TO THE MODERATOR. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AS YEAR LIVE IN EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE. SEVEN ZERO
AFTER FIVE. WHY AND ONE OH FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS BETTER BEING COME OUT
OF THE NATIONAL PAYROLL
REPORTING CONSORTIUM I WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL FOR THE
REASONS CITED ARE LETTER STATED
IN THE ANALYSIS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I WON SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE USUAL
MEMBERS NICK CHAMPION BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. BYE THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BRAD ANDERSON CONCERNED
CITIZEN RIVERSIDE. THANK YOU
NEXT. BY ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
PEOPLE I HAD. THANK YOU TERRY
MEMBERS JERRY SAID ABOUT THE
CEMETERY AND MORTUARY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA AND
PLUMBING MANUFACTURERS
INTERNATIONAL THE REASON. IS THE
STATE THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M FIFTIES PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THANK YOU KAREN NUMBER NINETY
THREE WITH THE BAKER AND- ALSO
IN OPPOSITION. AB RECORDS. YEAH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AROUND ONE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUDGET CORKER WITH THE SECURITY
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OVER A HUNDRED
SEVENTY CALIFORNIA COMPANIES
PROVIDE FIFTEEN SECURITY
PRODUCTS. IS IT BEFORE
CALIFORNIA ALREADY AT THE CPRE
WHICH PROTECTS BIOMETRIC
INFORMATION THIS BILL IMPOSES
OUTDATED AND UNNECESSARY
RESTRICTIONS THAT WOULD
CONFLICT. THE RESULT BE HARMED
NOT PROTECTION FOR CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS AND BUSINESSES AND WE
KNOW THIS BECAUSE OF WHAT
HAPPENED IN ILLINOIS. THERE IS A
BIG EXTORTED THREE NO HARM CLASS
ACTIONS AND BENEFICIAL
TECHNOLOGIES HAVE BEEN SHELVED.
THANK YOU PREVENTIVE SECURITY
AND PROTECT WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT NEXT. THANK YOU
RIDE ONE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ANDREW CAME IN
REPRESENTING THE STATE PRIVACY
AND SECURITY COALITION WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
FOR THE REGION'S PREVIOUSLY
STATED THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT MR CARE MEMBERS NOT
APPLYING ON BEHALF OF. THE
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AS CALIFORNIA IT LOOKS LIKE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT- BRING IT BACK
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
CENTREBOARD THIS. THANK YOU
MEASURE- I KNOW THAT WE HAVE
PROBABLY HAVE A LOT OF COMMENTS-
IN SOME IN KITCHEN ON THIS ISSUE
JUST FROM A PROCEDURAL
STANDPOINT THOUGH- WHEN WE WENT
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF THE
PRIVACY PROTECTION ACT- BACK
WHEN. I AND I THINK THAT DO
NEXT- BECOME ACTIVATED IT WAS IT
IN IN TWENTY ONE OR TWENTY TWO.
HELLO IF YOU CAN. OF TOP YOUR
HEAD. IF YOU KNOW THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ONE WE'RE IN TWENTY TWO
RIGHT. YEAH IN JANUARY OF TWENTY. WE STARTED THIS IS HERE AND WE
WERE TWENTY TWO. EITHER WAY- I
THINK MY POINT IS THAT- THIS IS
RELATIVELY NEW AND STILL BEING
ROLLED OUT I THINK MINOR
STANDARD THERE ARE SOME
EXCEPTIONS THAT ARE STILL BEING-
TEASED OUT. BUT MY RECOLLECTION
IS THAT ALL THE PARTIES WERE
BROUGHT TO BEAR ON THIS ISSUE IN
THERE WERE CONCESSIONS AND
UNDERSTANDINGS MADE DURING THAT
PROCESS IN MY ONLY CONCERN BY
LEESON AT THE PROCEDURAL LEVEL
IS IF WE WENT THROUGH THAT
ENTIRE PROCESS. DODD WE HAVE TO
REPRESENT INDIVIDUALS WHETHER
THEY BE IN THE SPECIAL INTEREST
FOR THE POLICY REALM THAT WHEN
WE AGREED TO SOMETHING. THAT
WERE NOT IMMEDIATELY GOING TO
TAKE A SECOND THIRD AND FIFTH
BITE AT THE APPLE- THAT THAT
SUBSTANTIALLY MODIFIES THE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE WITHIN IT. SO I GUESS YOU
KNOW MAYBE IT'S A QUESTION TO
YOU BUT I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED
THAT WE WENT THROUGH THAT ENTIRE
PROCESS IN MOUNTAINS WERE MOVED.
TO ACHIEVE THAT BILL SUCCESS IN
THE APPROVAL THAT WENT ALONG
WITH THAT. THAT ARE WE RETIRE WE
ARE RISK OF LOSING CREDIBILITY
WITH PARTNERS AS WE MOVE
LEGISLATION- BY BUILDING
COALITIONS AND THEN ONCE WE GET
IT WE TAKE THAT FIFTY BITE AT
THE APPLE. VISIT SHERIFF HER.
ALTHOUGH I AM HUNGRY I DON'T
THINK WE'RE TAKING TOO MANY
BITES OF THE APPLE I IN. D.
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE HAS AN
ENCOMPASSING DEFINITION OF WHAT
IS BIOMETRIC INFORMATION THE
CPRE FOCUSED ON THE INTENT. YOU
KNOW NOT THE CAPABILITY WE'RE
NOT THE CAPABLE THEY WHAT WAS
THE INTENT THAT THE BUSINESSES
WERE DOING SO WE COME AT IT FROM
A DIFFERENT ANGLE THE OTHER IS
THIS IS IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN HAVING
BIOMETRIC INFORMATION COLLECTED
FROM YOU AT THE AT THE- STORE
TOPPED OUT YOU KNOW WE'RE SAYING
YOU HAVE TO OPT IN. IN ORDER TO
HAVE THIS VERY SENSITIVE
INFORMATION ARE COLLECTED THE
ILLINOIS' SITUATION WHERE PEOPLE
FOCUS ON THE L. ONORE SITUATION
YOU KNOW THERE'S A TIME MY DATE
PASSED THAT BILL IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN- IT REALLY DIDN'T START
COMING TO LIGHT IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHEN BIG FIRMS WERE
COLLECTING INFORMATION AND 90% I
THINK THE STAFF REPORT. POINTED
OUT OF THE- PRIVATE READ
FACTIONS WERE OVER. EMPLOYEES ON
THE ON THE SECURITY AT THE TIME
TIMETABLES ARE TIME PUNCHING A
TIME CARDS. THAT'S TAKEN CARE OF
NOW I MEAN YOU DON'T GET TO WORK
UNLESS YOU SIGNED OFF ON LETTING
THEM USE THAT THAT- BIOMETRIC
INFORMATION. TO THE LIMITED
PURPOSE OF MAKING SURE IT'S YOU
WHO'S WHO'S WORKING. THERE YOU
KNOW IT'S ALSO BIOMETRIC
INFORMATION AS I IN THIS
INDICATED MY- OPENING IS. REALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO RETRACT EVERY ONCE
IT'S OUT IN THE PUBLIC IT'S NOT
WHAT THE PASSWORD OR PIN. PIN
CODE FOR YOU YOU CAN A NEW SOUL
SECURITY NUMBER YOU CAN DO STEP
YOU CAN'T CHANGE YOUR FACE. NOT
EASILY- THE BILL. YEAH THE- M. I
THINK THAT'S A THAT'S MY ANSWER
- MORE JUST ANYMORE NO I IN.
RESHOOT THE INTELLECTUAL
ACROBATICS THAT WAS FUN- YEP BY
I THINK MY THOUGHT MY FINAL
POINT ON THAT SAME ISSUE IS THAT
IT MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THERE ARE SUBSTANTIAL
PROTECTIONS THAT WERE PUT IN
PLACE AND NUMBER OF US ACTUALLY
. WENT TO IRELAND AND NUMBER
YEARS BACK TO APPRECIATE HELLO
THE EUROPEANS WERE PUTTING FOR
THEIR PRIVACY. LAWS IN THEIR
PRACTICES- AND THAT BILL OF
COURSE- HAD SUBSTANTIAL-
SIMILARITIES TO THE EUROPEAN
SYSTEM I THINK- IN GENERAL
BECAUSE YOU WERE THERE- ON THAT
ON THAT TRIP AS WELL. SO I THINK
WHEN WE DO WE MOVE. A BILL LIKE
THAT. THE PRIVACY ACT AND WE GET
APPROVAL IN BUYING ANYTHING AND
COOPERATION IN CONCESSIONS THERE
NEEDS TO BE A DEGREE OF RESPECT
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT PROCESS. IN
THAT INDIVIDUALS CANNOT COME IN
IN THE END RELATIVE QUICK
SUCCESSION INSTRUCTED HER
ALTERING OR UNDERMINING IT OR
TWEAKING IT IN WAYS THAT REALLY
YOU KNOW KIND OF. UNDO THE
GOODWILL THAT WAS DONE BEFORE
AND I THINK WITH AT ALL JUST AND
I'VE AND I RESPECT THE WORK THAT
YOU DO OF COURSE. OPERATING ON
THIS THIS MIGHT BE A BIT OF A
BRIDGE TOO FAR YEAH I GUESS
MISTER CHAIR. IT WELL C. P. R.
A. FOCUSED ON INTENT IF THIS
BILL PURELY FOCUSED ON INTENT.
IT WOULD DO LITTLE TO GUARD
AGAINST SORT OF THIS BLANKET
COLLECTION AND DISCLOSURE OF
BIOMETRIC INFORMATION THIS IS
JUST FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT AND
IT IT WILL YOU KNOW THE IDEA IS
TO SUPPLEMENT THE CPR EIGHT NOT
TO OVERTURN ANYTHING WITH THIS
YOU KNOW. MINIMIZING THE
PROVISIONS I'VE TAKEN AMENDMENTS
ON TWENTY THREE MAY I KNOW D. N.
A.'S INCLUDED STATE UC'S ARE OFF
BECAUSE I'VE TAKEN THAT
AMENDMENT OUT SOME TRYING TO
NARROW THIS ONE IT'S- IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY. ALL RIGHT NOW
FOR THE COMETS OR QUESTIONS IS
OUR MOTION. SO HERTZBERG MOVES
THE BILL- SOLD- BEFORE YOU
CLOSE- CENTER WHITE CASKET I
THINK THAT THAT YOU YOU ACCEPTED
THE AMENDMENTS CORRECT CORRECT
ALL RIGHT THERE'S STILL I THINK
SOME MORE WORK TO DO ON THE
BILL- I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
FURTHER DISCUSSION WITH RESPECT
TO THE ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM.
AND WITH THAT- WOULD LIKE CLOSE.
YEAH I. AM I WOULD URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS AND HOPEFULLY WE
CAN IMPROVE TO PRACTICES AND HIT
THAT SWEET SPOT THAT EVERYBODY
SEEMS TO BE SEARCHING FOR. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU COUNSEL. THREE
WITH THE MOTION BY US SENATORS
BURKE OKAY THANK YOU. THIS IS
THE S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE YOU THE
MOTION BY SENATOR HERTZBERG AND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND. AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
UMBERG. NUMBER FIVE BORGIAS
PORTIS NOCAUTEADO. DID ASAL.
DATA SO I GONZALEZ HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE JONES JON SNOW
LAYERED LAYERED I STERN STERN
AYE WHITE HOUSE SKI HI WHITE
HOUSE SKI I WIENER. WIENER I.
AND ALL YOUR MEMBERS ARE HERE
AND SO THAT'S. ONE TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE SIX SEVEN TWO TWO NINE
THE BILLS OUT. ALL RIGHT LET LET
ME I HATE TO DO THIS AND PLEASE
REFRAIN FROM GROANING GOING BACK
TO S. B. TEN NINETY NINE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE A SONORA CAST YOU
JUST TO BE CLEAR YOU ACCEPTED
THE AMENDMENTS. IS PROPOSES
EXTRACT YES ALL RIGHT LET LET'S
OPEN THE ROLE- I BELIEVE IT'S ON
CALL ONE TIME YES THIS IS THE S.
B. TEN NINETY NINE BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING HI AND THAT MOTION WAS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE. AND THE
MISSING. SENATORS ARE GONZALEZ.
JONES JONES I THAT HAS TEN ZERO
ALL RIGHT BILLS OUT. ALL RIGHT
NEXT. SBONE FOUR SEVEN SEVEN.
MISTER KERR AND MEMBERS S. C. X.
O. SORRY. I AM I'M ON RIGHT OR
WRONG OKAY. ALL YOU HELLO WITH.
IS THE EXCELLENT COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS NOTES I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED ON PAGES TEN AND ELEVEN
IN THEIR ENTIRETY. MEMBERS AFTER
TWELVE YEARS OF HAVING THE
PRIVILEGE TO SERVE IN THE
LEGISLATURE SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN REPRESENTS MY FINAL
EFFORT. TO AT LAST SPRING THE
STATE'S WAGE GARNISHMENT LAW
INTO THE MODERN ERA WE HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT ALBEIT MODEST
IMPROVEMENTS OVER THE YEARS AS
OUTLINED IN THE STAFF REPORT TO
BETTER PROTECT WORKERS WHOSE
INCOMES HOVER NEAR THE STATE'S
MINIMUM WAGE FROM BURDENSOME
WAGE GARNISHMENT. BUT WE HAVE
BEEN NOT YET A DONE ENOUGH TO
ENSURE THE CALIFORNIANS WORKING
WHO ARE TRYING TO BALANCE
EVERYTHING NEEDS AND THE DEBTS
THAT THEY ENABLED TO TAKE HOME A
LIVING WAGE TO SUPPORT
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILY.
LAYERED ON TOP OF THIS IS WE ALL
KNOW THIS PANDEMIC HAS. HAD THE
EFFECT OF NOT TREATING EVERYBODY
EQUALLY WE TALK ABOUT THAT K.
RECOVERY WE HAVE SOME PEOPLE
GOING UP AND SOME PEOPLE. GOING
DOWN UNFORTUNATELY HE'S
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE WITH THE
LEAST RESOURCES IN THE ABILITY
TO STAY AFLOAT HAVE BEEN HIT THE
SEVEN ACKNOWLEDGES BOTH OF THESE
REALITIES BY FAMILY PROTECTING A
LIVING WAGE FOR CALIFORNIA
WORKERS TO BE CLEAR. THIS
LEGISLATION DOES NOT ELIMINATE
THE DEBT IT DOES NOT CONTAMINATE
THE DEBT BUT BY REDUCING THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY TAKEN DIRECTLY
FROM OUR PAYCHECKS THE BILL WILL
LIFT PEOPLE OUT OF THIS CYCLE OF
DEBT AND ALLOW THEM TO REPAY. ON
TERMS THAT THEY CAN MANAGE- THE
BILL ENJOYS A BROAD ARRAY OF
SUPPORT RANGING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ALLIANCE TO THE
N. DOUBLE ACP TO LEGAL AID
ATTORNEYS AND CONSUMER ADVOCATES
AND WITH ME TODAY. ARE TWO
WITNESSES- ELIZABETH GONZALEZ
WITH PUBLIC COUNCIL IN DISARRAY
AND WENT FORTH WITH THE EAST BAY
COMMUNITY LAW CENTER ALL RIGHT
MISS GONZALEZ. YOU'RE AVAILABLE
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH INVALID THE NIGHT OF
THE PROVIDER AFTER TURNING THE
PUBLIC COUNCIL PIZZA RIGHT
ECONOMIC JUSTICE PROJECT. ONE
WITH MY CLIENT BASE BY CREATING
AN AMALGAM OF MY PRIVATE CLIENTS
. HOME HOPE. BECAUSE HOPE
SPRINGS MORTARS ABOUT BUT WE-
THE ONLY WAY TO BE IF ALL OF
THEIR INCOME AT THE FIREPLACE I
THINK THAT. FIRST NO DIGITAL
BALAKOT THE VICTIMS. OF THE
EARLY IN ORDER USUALLY THE
RESULT OF A LOT HOPE COULD NOT
HOW TO DO FILE. IN MY FOR
SERVICE FROM FOR. I COULDN'T
HELP COFFEE YOUR CALL OF THE
NOTICE. OKAY WHICH HAVE TO. OF
COURSE DOCUMENTARY BUT SHALL BE
DOCUMENTS MIGHT ONLY IF COPE
WITH AND OTHER ENGLISH. IT OPENS
MORE NOT BY THE NORDIC OR POSTED
NOT EXIST IT. AN APARTMENT
BUILDING BECAUSE OF ALL WILL BE
GARNISH. DOUBLES ONE FIVE DOLLAR
NINETY SEEM LIKE A LOT YOU.
WORKING WITH THE DATA DATA CLAN
LIKE. IMPACTORS. I HOPE IT
DOESN'T OR SEVEN I'M NOT WE WILL
FIND THE KEEPING. THE CONVENTION
FOR THE SHARE NOT ME HOPE SIXTY
IMMENSELY CREDITABLE OPPOSED
CLAIM OF THE OF THE PROJECT AT
NOT PROGRESSED QUITE LOT DOUBLE
AS HOPE YOU CHOOSE TAKE THE LEAD
HERE ALREADY. TO HELP WITH IN A
ONE BEDROOM.
WELCOME TO HELP IN MY LIFE-
ORDER TO PAY MONEY THAT YOU
CANNOT AFFORD TO PAY. THAT ARE
LEFT TO GO THERE. FAR BEHIND ON
RENT. HOW IT'S OFFICE DEREK
WHOLE. AND OTHERS LIKE THE TAKE
CALVET. FIVE THE FOURTEENTH%
SEVENTY FIVE. YEAH JUST YOU WAS
BECAUSE ALL MISS WHEN. SUBSCRIBE
JUST IN. THOMAS WINS HERE BREAK
HI- ED CLOSURES THANK YOU AND
GOOD AFTER CHAIR VICE CHAIR AND
OF THE CAN. I'M DESIREE OR IF
DIRECTOR OF THE CONSUMER JUST
CLINIC I EAST BAKED LAW CENTER
AND MATURE BERKELEY LAW. AS PART
OF MY WORK I TRY LAST IMPACT
SKILLS OF LAWYERING OR MAJORITY
OF THE STUDENT OF THE OUTCOMES
IN OUR CASES ARE POSITIVE AND
RESULT IN THE STUDENTS LEARNING
THE REAL IMPACT OF ADVOCACY THE
PATH TO ACCOMPLISHING THIS CAN
BE VERY STRESSFUL AND DIRE. MY
ORANGE COUNTY COLLEAGUES AT
PUBLIC LAWCENTER OF ASKING TO
SHARE AN ANECDOTE THAT IS NOT
VERY UNUSUAL. FOR DIRECT LEGAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS IN CONSUMER
LAW. A COUPLE WHO WILL CALL DAN
AND JANE HAVE ONE SMALL TO. AND
ON THE WAY. WHICH IN PROVIDE A
CHILD CARE FOR THEIR TOP. THE
FAMILY RELIES ON DAN'S GROSS
INCOME OF FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR. LIKE SO MANY FAMILIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BETWEEN
TAXES RENT UTILITIES FOOD AND
TRANSPORTATION. THEY WERE EITHER
BREAKING EVEN OR SLIGHTLY UNDER
WATER EACH MONTH. ULTIMATELY THE
PLAN WAS FOR THE CLIENTS TO FILE
BANKRUPTCY BECAUSE THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF DEBT THAT THEY HAD WAS
TOO MUCH FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
PAY OFF. THEIR ANOTHER EXAMPLE
OF CONSUMERS WHO EARN ABOUT THE
CURRENT PROTECTIONS FOR WAGE
GARNISHMENT. BUT WHO CANNOT
AFFORD TO PAY ANYTHING TO
ACCREDITOR. SHORTLY BEFORE THE
BANKRUPTCY CASES TO BE FILED THE
JUDGMENT CREDITOR SCHEDULED A
DOCTOR'S EXAM. A DEBTOR'S EXAM
REQUIRES A JUDGMENT DEBTOR TO
APPEAR AT COURT FOR A HEARING.
WHERE THEY ARE ASKED TO ASK
QUESTIONS TO IDENTIFY AND LOCATE
ASSETS. UNSURPRISINGLY THESE
HEARINGS HAPPEN ON WEEKDAYS
DURING NORMAL COURT BUSINESS
HOURS. A NORMAL WORK HOURS FOR
MOST PEOPLE. FOR WHATEVER REASON
THE CLIENTS DID NOT APPEAR FOR
THE DEBTORS EXAM AND THE JUDGE
ISSUED A BENCH WARRANT. THE
CLIENTS CONTACTED LEGAL SERVICES
IN A PANIC FEARFUL THAT THEY
WOULD BE ARRESTED. SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THEY HAD WERE WHO
WOULD TAKE CARE OF THEIR CHILD
IF THEY WERE SENT TO JAIL. HOW
LONG WOULD THEY BE IN JAIL.
COULD THE HUSBAND BE ARRESTED AT
WORK. COULD ONE OF THEM
VOLUNTEERED TO GO TO JAIL SO THE
OTHER COULD STAY OUT TO CARE FOR
THEIR CHILD. HOW WOULD THEY GET
OUT OF JAIL IF THEY COULDN'T
PAY. WELL OUR COLLEAGUES WERE
ABLE TO EDUCATE THEM AND
ULTIMATELY HELP THEM TO GET THE
WARRANT RECALLED. ORDINARY
PEOPLE LIKE THESE CLIENTS AND
PARTICULARLY THE PREGNANT WIFE.
SHOULD NEVER HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
AN ARREST WARRANT BECAUSE OF A
CREDIT CARD DEBT. INCLUDING SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN PROVIDES
THE MOST BASIC OF REASONABLE.
AND PROPORTIONAL DEBT COLLECTION
MEASURES THAT CALIFORNIA'S
DESERVE. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
HER AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
WHEN OTHERS IN SUPPORT REPROACH
A MICROPHONE HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED. CHRIS FOR SCIENCES
POLICY ADVOCATE WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WERE
PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR THANK
YOU OTHERS IS SUPPORT ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED SAYING NO ONE
ELSE APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE
DOESN'T SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD. QUEUE
THEM UP. EVEN THAT I MEAN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT IT. ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE THAT IS IN
SUPPORT. ONE DAY ZERO. HEY WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE PEOPLE. HERE WE
WILL START WITH MY NUMBER ONE
FIFTY SIX BASEBALL HAD. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS REPAIRING WITH
THE PUBLIC LAWCENTER AT THE TOP
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THE FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WAS FAIR AND NEXT. THE LINE
AT ONE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI BASS WE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ONE OF THE- REGION AND
WITH THE FOLLOWING GROUPS AND
INDIVIDUALS IN SUPPORT AS WELL
FEYNMAN'S FOREIGNERS P.
COMMITTEE LEGAL SERVICES AND THE
FALLOUT HOME CONSUMER FEDERATION
OF CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION
CALIFORNIA HAWAII STATE
CONFERENCE OF THE END OF A FEW
KEY. INDIVIDUAL GARY NEWSLETTER
. ALL RECKON JEFF. LEGALLY WORK
. YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA LAWYER
COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS AND
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
CALIFORNIA ACT THE BUILDING
COALITION I LOVE BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS. LEADER
SACRAMENTO URBAN LEAGUE. ACTION
FOR ALL CONTRA COSTA SENIOR
LEGAL SERVICES AND FREEDOM FOR
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
AND ONCE AGAIN THAT IS ONE THEN
ZERO. YOU HAVE FROM THE REGISTRY
DEFINITELY ONE MOMENT.
SORRY WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
BUT YOU CAN'T YOU. IT WILL
BOTTOM LINE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DANIELLE CANDOR BECAUSE OUR ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL CONSUMER
LAW CENTER PROUD CO SPONSORS OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANY MARK YOU
MISTER KATZ ALREADY ATTORNEY THE
OPPOSITION SEEMS REMOTE TREE
HERE. SMOTRICH ASSUME YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION- I AM ALL RIGHT THAT
WAS YOURS THERE- THANK YOU
SHARON MEMBERS- GLAD TO BE HERE
FOR AROUND FOUR WITH CENTER BY
CASKEY- HERE- REMOVED THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
FIRST LIKE TO THANK STAFF A
THOROUGH ANALYSIS- GOING TO THE
MATH ON THIS BILL IS QUITE
SOMETHING TO DO SO I WILL GIVE
THANKS FOR THAT WORK- I WANT TO
FLAG- THIS IMPORTANT CONTEXT
HERE AS A SENATOR REFERENCED-
THE CENTER WAS. WAS EXCESSIVELY
REWRITING CALIFORNIA'S WHICH
CURRENT LAW IN TWENTY FIFTEEN TO
A SIGNIFICANT DEGREE IN TERMS OF
THE CHANGE PROTECTIONS THE WHICH
IS COLLECTIBLE THERE SO WE'VE
MADE RECENT CHANGES IN THIS
FIELD- I ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT.
THIS REWRITE WE SIMPLICITY IS
GOING TOO FAR I'M GLAD TO HEAR
THAT DEMANDS THAT I WILL BE
REVIEWING THEM BUT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THE PERSON ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THAT DEBT ISN'T- YOU
KNOW IT YOU HAVE A PLUMBER RIGHT
IT WAS A DEBT AND CAN'T COLLECT
THAT. THERE ARE PEOPLE TRYING TO
COLLECT THESE THINGS WHO SIMPLY
NEED THAT MONEY- I WANT TO ALSO
TOUCH ON WHICH COUNTRY IS NOT
ONLY USED BY BUSINESSES YOU ALSO
OF RESTITUTION FOR VICTIMS OF
CRIME ISSUES LIKE THAT WHICH CAN
TURN TO CIVIL JUDGMENTS AND THEN
END UP IN WAGE GARNISHMENT SO.
THIS IS A TOOL IT'S USED A LOT
OF PLACES- SUBSTANTIVELY I WANNA
FLY. BY EXAM THE WAY THE SCALE
OF THIS CHANGE- SO WE DID SOME
MATH ON IT AS WELL AND- YOU KNOW
FOR EXAMPLE A PERSON MAKE A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
PRESENTLY UNDER IT SHOULD BE
UNDER THE PROPOSED TAX PREMIUMS.
WOULD BE PAYING THIRTY FOUR
DOLLARS A WEEK AGAIN THAT'S
MAKING A A YEAR. THE MOST YOU
COULD GARNISH ME THIRTY FOUR
DOLLARS A WEEK. WHAT THAT
DOESN'T AFFECT PRESENT LAWS IT
MEANS THAT WHERE YOU PRESENTLY
PAYING AROUND WE ESTIMATED
THIRTEEN WEEKS AHEAD THAT. YOU
MIGHT BE PAYING SOMETHING MORE
LIKE A HUNDRED AND FORTY WEEKS
SO YOU'RE YOU'RE LOOKING AT A-
REALLY SIGNIFICAN EXTENSION OF
THIS. IT'S NOT KIND OF A AT.
THAT DELAY IS SIGNIFICANT- YOU
ALMOST LEAVE THERE MADE MY TIME
FOR MY COLLEAGUES ON YOU GIPSON
FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN THANK YOU. BOB
THIS GIPSON JOHN THE PHONE. GO
AHEAD MACINNES. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GOING TO
GET HERE WITH ENCORE CAPITAL
GROUP IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
OKAY IT ALSO CAPITAL GROUP IS
TREATMENT SAN DIEGO WITH THE
DEPUTIES AND COMPANY THAT HAS
ONE IN FIVE CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
PUBLIC HEALTH. WITH A COMPANY.
AS A LOT MENTIONED. THE PROPOSAL
IS- PREMATURE AND UNNECESSARY-
FIRSTLY WE FUNCTIONALIZED THE
TOOL THAT YOU DEFICIT MANY
ATTEMPTS TO WORK WITH CONSUMERS
ARE ON AVERAGE OUR COMPANY HAS
REACHED OUT TO CONSUMERS
SEVENTEEN DIFFERENT TIMES. YOU
KNOW TO FIGHT THEM THAT THERE IS
THERE MIGHT BE A- LITIGATION
OVER. COMING THERE. ADDITIONALLY
SENATE BILL OH ONE IN THE
FIFTEEN WELL DONE AFTER ROBUST
WORK- WHICH SUBSTANTIALLY
OVERHAULED THE WAGE GARNISHMENT
PROVISIONS IN THE STATE IT HAD
MADE CALIFORNIA OF THE LEVEL
GRADE IN TERMS OF WAGE
GARNISHMENT BY THE NATIONAL
CONSUMER LAW POLITICAL
BOUNDARIES OF THE BILL. THE ONLY
GIVEN EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT LIKE
TAX PASSED. WHICH HAVE YOUR
RESTRICTIONS BANK LEVY AND FELL
OFF MONTHLY THE BILL ONLY WAY TO
GET IT EIGHT O'CLOCK AM WE'LL
SEE TO COMPLETELY BADLY
GARNISHMENT WHICH IS WHAT THIS
PROPOSAL ATTEMPTS TO DO. IN THAT
BILL FIVE OH ONE TWENTY. CREATED
AN AUTOMATIC DEPENDENCY ON LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGE THAT YOU WOULDN'T
HAVE TO ADJUST THE WAGE
GARNISHMENT FORMULA AS WE ARE
HERE DOING TODAY. IT DEPENDS ON
THINK FOR EXAMPLE THE SEVENTY
DOLLAR MINIMUM WAGE IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO AREA- IS AUTOMATICALLY
ADJUSTING UP EXEMPTION UNDER
CURRENT LAW. FINALLY THE OTHER
SIDE IS USING- HOPEFUL INCOME
LEVEL OF APPROXIMATELY THREE TO
FOUR WEEKS RUNNERS AS THEIR
AVERAGES AND IT'S REALLY AT THE
EIGHT THAT INDIVIDUAL INCOME IS
MORE DETAILS OF FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
ACCORDING TO THE CENSUS BUREAU
DATA. AND THIS WAY BECAUSE THE
FORMULA IS FOURTH INDIVIDUAL WE
CANNOT BE APPLIED TO AN ENTIRE
FAMILY GETS HER PAYCHECK FOR
EACH REGION ARE. THE PROPOSAL
WILL ESSENTIALLY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT- ADDITIONAL
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION A FEW CLOSE PRO TO
THE MICROPHONE ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED SHERRIN SENATORS ALEX
ALANIZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGMENT PRESERVATION
ALLIANCE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED NEXT ON THE PHONE
MOTOR IF YOU TWO OF THOSE ON THE
PHONE. IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO ASK THE ONE FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE.
ZERO AT THIS TIME YEAH. WHY ONE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CLOSE BERGEN WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLECTORS IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU WHY ONE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GET YOUR NUMBERS DOWN THE
QUICKEST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION-
OUTLINING OUR COMMENTS WITH
THOSE PREVIOUSLY BEFORE I THINK
YOU. PHOTO THANK YOU THANK YOU
pFIRST DEGREE OF CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
GRETCHEN LYNCHING BURGER WITH
JUSTICE MATTERS OR JUDGMENT
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS AND WE
ABSOLUTELY OPPOSES HILL THANK
YOU FOR HEARING ME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AS- YOU CAN ONLY GET FOR
MARRIAGE WELL AS A VICTIM OF NOT
PROTECTING THE ACTORS WHICH IS A
MONDAY- I WOULD STRONGLY SAY NO
ALREADY MY MONEY BACK THANK YOU
. NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT
ONE OH FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TIM LYNCH ON
BEHALF OF THE RECEIVABLES MANAGE. ALL RIGHT OUR NEXT VERY. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE COMMENTS.
THEM SAYING NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS IS THERE A MOTION.
SENATE ALSO MOVES THE BILL- SO I
KASKY CARE TO CLOSE YES I WOULD
URGE AN AYE VOTE AND I WOULD
JUST SAY LET'S HAPPENED SINCE
TWENTY FIFTEEN IT THE COST OF
BASIC NECESSITIES HAVE RISEN.
PEOPLE ARE NOT MAKING ENDS MEET
BECAUSE THE COST OF THE
SERVICING THEIR DEBTS THEIR
PRINT THEY'RE NOT THEIR WAGES
ARE NOT ADEQUATELY PUT BEING
PROTECTED THE IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE UNITED WAY REPORTED THAT
MORE THAN ONE IN THREE
HOUSEHOLDS 33% OVER. THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION FAMILIES DO NOT
EARN SUFFICIENT INCOME TO MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS AND COUNTY
WHERE I LIVE ALAMEDA COUNTY A
FAMILY OF FOUR YOU NEED TO EARN
A HUNDRED AND ONE. THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED SIX HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
IN THE ANNUAL INCOME TO MEET THE
BASIC NEEDS OF YOUR OF YOUR-
HOUSING FOOD HEALTH CARE AND
TRANSPORTATION AND CHILDCARE. HI
WITH THAT 'LL CONTINUETO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION HAVE SAY
HAVE WITH. THE NUMBER OF BILLS
THAT I'VE I'VE FOUGHT THROUGH
THIS AREA AND I WOULD URGE AN
IPHONE. ALREADY BEEN TO COUNSEL
IF YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL THIS
IS SENATE BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI
WITH THE MOTION BY SENATOR DID
OFF TO THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
AS AMENDED. UMBERG HI AMBERG BY
FORTUS. PORGES SNOW COVER YET
ALL. THE RUSSELL. RUSSELL FIVE
GONZALEZ HERTZBERG HERTZBERG BY
JONES. JONES NO LAYERED LAYARD I
STERN STERN HIGHWAY CAL SKI WHY
CASKEY I WIENER WIENER HI THAT
IS. SEVENTY TWO WITH ALL MEMBERS
PRESENT BILLS OUT THANK YOU.
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN S. B. EIGHT
FOUR EIGHT. SENATOR UMBERG THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. REPORTER THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR
YOU PATIENCE TODAY SB EIGHT FOUR
EIGHT- WHAT IT DOES IS IT
REMOVES THE SUNSET ON THE BILL
THAT PROVIDES FOR REMOTE ACCESS
OF I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THERE
ARE CONCERNS WITH THE COURT
REPORTERS. CONCERNING REMOTE
ACCESS AND HOW IT'S IMPACTED THE
PROCESS OF THE ISSUE IS. WHETHER
OR NOT. WE AS A GOVERNMENT ARE
GOING TO PROVIDE COURT REPORTERS
THAT ARE OFFICIALLY- BOTH
SANCTIONED AND EMPLOYEES OF THE
COURT I THINK WE SHOULD- BUT THE
REMEDY IS NOT NOW TO- IN ESSENCE
STOP REMOTE ACCESS SHOULD THE
SUNSET NOT BE EXCEPT IT
EXTENDED. THEN REMOTE ACCESS
WILL CEASE- ON THE SUNSET DATE
WHICH IS MID TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY THREE I URGE AND I VOTE
WITH ME- TO TESTIFY IS- MISTER
MICHAEL LOAD. AS WELL AS I
BELIEVE MISS- SUBPOENAED TO KERR
IS ALSO AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY. MR
BELOW THAT IN TURN MEMBERS- MIKE
POLLITT SPEAKING BOTH ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEFENSE COUNSEL CIVIL DEFENSE
LAWYERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WE
JOIN WITH CONSUMER ATTORNEYS WE
THINK. THAT THERE HAS BEEN TO
USE A- BROKER OUT FOR A SORT OF
A PARADIGM SHIFT IN RECENT
YEARS- BOTH JUDGES AND DEFENSE
LAWYERS HAD CONCERNS ABOUT
REMOTE APPEARANCES AND- THE
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER THEY'D
BE USED WE WORKED HARD ON SB TWO
FORTY ONE LAST YEAR AND WE THINK
IT WAS A GOOD PRODUCT. NOT
PERFECT AND THE AND THE
TECHNOLOGY ISN'T PERFECT BUT
IT'S GETTING BETTER AND BETTER
ALL THE TIME- ARE. THE DEFENSE
COUNCIL MEMBERS AND OUR JUDGES
BELIEVE THAT TO KEEP CIVIL CASES
MOVING IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT WE
HAVE A CONSTRUCT FOR REMOTE
APPEARANCES. BY THE WAY BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE USE OF CERTIFIED SHORTHAND
REPORTERS COURT REPORTERS ARE
NECESSARY TO CREATE AN ACCURATE
RECORD AND WE SUPPORT HIRING AND
PROVIDING COURT REPORTERS IN
CIVIL PROCEEDINGS BUT YOU ALSO
HAVE TO HAVE A LAW ON REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS. IT'S WORKING BETTER
AND BETTER ALL THE TIME AND WE
THINK IT DESERVES AN EXTENSION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAME MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
OPEN THE LINE FOR SABINA THE CAR
. FIVE MONTHS THANK YOU BY THE
VERY MEMBERS YOU'D LIKE ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER DURING
THE CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A PARTY
SUPPORT DIVISION AT EIGHT FORTY
EIGHT. YEARS HE WAS HEAVILY
INVOLVED IN THE PRODUCTION BY
FEAR WILL EITHER MOVE FORWARD
KEEPING ALONG WITH THE USUAL
COUNCIL THE JUDGES FOUND FOUND
FULL LEGAL AID AND IF THE
COUNCIL. RIGHT GROUP AND MANY
OTHERS. ARE THE BLACK CARE ACT
BECAUSE FORTY ONE COPYRIGHT RTT
HERE PARAMOUNT WE RECORD HE IS
NOT THE COUNTY FELL HARD TO FIX
THE PROBLEM WANT TO MAKE SURE
THE COURT DOES NOT REQUIRE A
PARTY FUTURE METHODOLOGY AS NEW
AND IMPROVED ON COURT TV SENSOR
TECHNOLOGY IN COURT FOR IN THE
COURT ROOM. ABLE TO OPERATE
FULLY. PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROCEEDINGS. THICKLY INSURERS
PRODUCTS- THANK COMPLAIN.
REPORTER CAN ENTER. BUT THE FOR
THE STATE. I THE TOP OF MY
VISIBILITY FIFTH FINISH AND
LOOKS NEXT JULY THE UP WITH THE
MERGER PEOPLE WAS FOUGHT ABOUT
THE CORNER IF ALL DEPENDS FUN
BUT- WITHOUT THANK YOU FOR THE
COURTS WILL BE SHIPPED OUT THE
MARKET TWENTY FOUR COURT AGREED
WITH THE- AMOUNT HEARING THEM BY
THE BENEFITS OF A MORE ACTIVE
COURT BEEN WIPED. BARKING AT
LEGAL AID TO HELP OUR IN THE-
PROVISIONAL FOR DOING THE MATH
VIOLENCE AND CHILD CASES DON'T
HAVE FACE AT THE SCENE OF THE
INPUT. WORKING TEACHER OF ALL
TAKING OFF WORK AND AGREED DAY
IN COURT.
THEY TODAY OPERATIONS OF THE
COURTS CONTINUE. FOR THESE
REASONS THE ARCHER IDLENESS FOUR
EIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
THERE ARE THERE ANY OTHER OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
FOUR EIGHT IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED. THERE IS ROBERT MOTRIN
BEHALF OF MYSELF A CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE ELSE.
SAYING NO ONE ELSE- WILL MOVE ON
TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE LINE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU EVERYONE
SHOULD FIGURE FOR OF S. E. EIGHT
FOUR EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WORLDWIDE ONE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO BUT I THINK IN THOUSAND
THREE STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF
ENCORE CAPITAL GROUP SB EIGHT
FORTY THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU JUST ONE
MOMENT FOR THE NEXT COMMENT.
RIGHT ONE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING KATE- WHAT
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU VERY
GOOD WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANY ONE. IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED IN
OPPOSITION. ACTUALLY WE HAVE-
MICHELLE CASTER ON THE LINE SO
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE LINE
BECAUSE THERE'S NO ONE IN THE
ROOM. GOOD EVENING MICHELLE
CASTRO THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION. I'M A
PRACTICE MY TESTIMONY BY FIRST
NAME DOT LAST WEEK I HAPPEN I
BELIEVE VERY GOOD MEETING WITH
SENATOR- BURKE. I'M HOPEFUL WE
CAN REACH AGREEMENT I'M NOT
ELIMINATING THE FUNDS THAT ABOUT
BY FE QUARRY. AND STATICALLY
TOOK FLIGHT LONGER. WAIT BOB AN
AGREEMENT BUT MAY REGARDING TWO
FOUR ONE FIVE STOP A ONE MONTH
HIGH THE PROJECT WILL PUT. AND
INFLATED TO EXPIRE IN JULY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. DEGREE
OFTEN CREDITED CUTS OF NINE
DOLLARS IN ONGOING FUNDS
DEDICATED TO RECRUITING MORE
OFFICIAL. AND FAMILY SEATING.
ELIMINATING THE CONCEPT PROPOSED
NEXT YEAR EIGHT FOUR EIGHT
UNFORTUNATELY BREAK FLASHES
AGREEMENT. SB TWO FOR ONE
DRASTIC AFFECT ON JANUARY ONE.
NOT YET BEEN PUT INTO PRACTICE
QUIRK-SILVA OPERATING UNDER THE
MORE CULPABLE ADOPTED BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. FIFTY POINT
LOW PROCEEDINGS ON A SACK
EXPERIMENT WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING THE
PROGRAM RECORD THE FIRM OF
PROCEEDING. RECORDERS MARKET
DOWN AND CERTIFY THE RATE PAID
ON RECORD YET THEY ARE FACING
HARDSHIPS. IN A WAY THAT THEY'VE
NEVER EXPERIENCED BEFORE. TIMES
REPORTERS NEED A GRAND RAPIDS
PROCEEDING FOR CLARIFICATION. OR
MAYBE THE WITNESSES IT TOOK
QUICKLY TO OFTEN REPORTER HAVE A
MICROPHONE TURNED OFF WHEN THEY
TRY TO INTERRUPT AND. YET THEY
MUST CAPTURE THE BETA MARKET. HE
RECENTLY AMONG CAL. COURT USED
PRETTY MUCH. TO COVER OF.
REPORTER INTERNET WHEN I SEVERAL
AND SHE WAS ON TO CATCH THE
WHOLE PROCEEDING. THE COURT HAD
TO GO BACK IN LATER THAT DAY TRY
TO RECREATE THE RECORD WITHOUT
THE ATTORNEY PRESENT. TWENTY
FOUR CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS. SOME
MAY SAY THIS IS JUST ONE DAY
WHAT THE- WHAT BUT ONE OF THIS
ONE DAY COULD YOU ARE PROCEEDING
AND YOUR LIBERTY PLASTIC OR WHAT
HAVE YOU BEEN A LONG YOU CAN'T
GET TRAFFIC BECAUSE THE RECORD
WAS INCOMPLETE A LOT. SHOULD
GIVE US PAUSE. I'M NOT HERE TO
SAY EVERYONE PROCEEDING HAS BEEN
A PROBLEM WE'VE ALL EXPERIENCED
REMOTE WORK AND IT CAN BE VERY
CONVENIENT. REPORTERS AREN'T
SAYING THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
WITH THE FORMAL PROCEEDING YOU
HAVE A LOT OF COMMUTING TO WORK
EVERY DAY. OUR CONCERN BECAUSE
THEY'RE HAVING DIFFICULTY
CAPTURING THE BETA MARKER. OUR
NEW STANDARDS SAY THAT WERE NO
LONGER INTERESTED IN A VERBATIM
RECORD AND WE SHOULD BE CLEAR
ABOUT THAT. OR NOT OKAY BUT SLOW
DOWN AND ASSESS WHAT'S
HAPPENING. SO WE CAN GET IT
RIGHT BEFORE MAKING A PERMANENT
PERMANENT. FINALLY THE OTHER KEY
CONCOCTION PROMINENT A WASHER
THE GREEN ALSO IN JEOPARDY THE
COURTS ARE NOT SPENDING THIRTY
MILLION PROVIDED THEM. HIGHER
MORE SIBILANT FAMILY BUT
PORTER'S. PART OF LAST YEAR
DEALS WITH THAT. AND MUST
INCLUDE A DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT
THIRTY NINE TO MAKE SURE THE
LEGISLATURE CONTENT THAT. IF YOU
FOR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
ON THE TELECONFERENCE LINE IT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN. VIETNAM
OPPOSITION. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO ASK HE. EIGHT
FOUR EIGHT. ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WHY TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BENJAMIN THIS CATAMARAN
WITH THEIR AND REGIONALLY SO
SECRETLY AND ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL FOR THE SAME
REASONS THAT- MISS CASTRO.
OUTLINED IN HER TESTIMONY AND WE
JUST NEED TO POINT OUT THIS BILL
DOESN'T EXTEND THE SUNSET DATE
ELIMINATED AND WE DON'T. I IN
THE CENTER AND LIMITING THE
SUNSET MADE ON A BILL THAT HAS
EVEN TAKEN EFFECT YET. AND WE
HAVE NO EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE. OR
STUDY DONE- THAT WOULD INDICATE
THAT THIS IS THE DIRECTION TO GO
IN- WITH THAT- WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL I HOPE WE CAN ENGAGE-
SENATOR- BURKE. IN THE- AMENDING
IT TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU RIDE ONE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE CALL AT. BUT
X. SHARE HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION THE SUPPORTERS ANY
NOT PUBLIC EMPLOYEES ALL IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU VERY GOOD WE'RE GONNA
BE BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE A QUESTIONS CONCERNS
MOTION. SENATOR RUSSELL THANK
YOU- CENTER BERGEN I HAVE HAD
SOME CONVERSATIONS AND- I WORKED
REALLY HARD ON THIS ISSUE I
KNOW- IN LINE WITH CENTER-
BURKE'S OUR GREAT CONCERNED
ABOUT MAKING SURE OUR COURTS
WORK FOR EVERYBODY ON THE
EQUITABLE FOR EVERYBODY BUT
BECAUSE THIS OF FALLS UNDER-
BUDGET SUB FIVE. I WAS VERY VERY
DIRECTLY INVOLVED WE HAD A LOT
OF TESTIMONY IN HEARINGS OF
ABOUT HOW THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM
WAS WORKING AT THAT TIME RIGHT
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE PANDEMIC-
AND THIS AGREEMENT- ABOUT HAVING
A PILOT PROJECT. TO SUNSET IN
JULY OF TWENTY THREE- AND-
HAVING A WORKING GROUP THAT
WOULD MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
COME BACK TO US- THAT WAS A
REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF THE
AGREEMENT I THINK THE- THE THIRD
PART ABOUT WE- ARE PROVIDED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS. IN
ONGOING FUNDS- DIRECTING THE
TRIAL COURTS TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF OFFICIAL COURT
REPORTERS IN FAMILY IN CIVIL
COURTS AND YOU KNOW WE HAVEN'T.
CONFIRMED A WHOLE LOT BUT IT
APPEARS THAT THAT MONEY IS NOT
BEING USED NOT BEING SPENT THE
WAY FOR THE WRONG REASONS- THAT
WE NEEDED THEM SO I WOULD REALLY
ASK TO- AMEND THIS SO WE COULD-
EXTEND THE IT WE CAN EXTEND IT
RATHER THAN HAVING IT-
ELIMINATING THE SUNSET. AND THEN
JUST MAKE SURE WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IS BEANS USE THE WAY
THAT WE DECIDED. TO USE IT- SO
WITH THAT I THINK THE COMMENTS
THANK YOU CENTER NUMBER. I
CENTER SIR THANK YOU I WAS NOT
IS DIRECTLY INVOLVED- BUT I
WOULD ECHO I GUESS THE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE
AND JUST AS THE AUTHOR. JUST FOR
IS PEACE COMES MAYBE YOUR
CLOTHES BUT THOUGHTS ON THE A
LITTLE SHORTER SUNSET BURDEN NOT
A PERMANENT IN EXTENSION BUT
SOMETHING NEAR TERM AND THEN
ALSO THAT WASN'T RAISED IN THE
DIRECT TESTIMONY HERE IN THE
HEARING BUT- THESE JUVENILE
<c.yellow>USTICE CONCERNS ABOUT. THREE</c>
SEPARATE CATEGORY OF CASES THAT
ARE BECAUSE I CRIMINAL IN NATURE
JUST WANT TO GET YOUR- YOUR TAKE
ON BOTH THOSE ISSUES. SO- WEL
IF YOU LIKE I'D BE HAPPY TO
DRESS ALL THE BOTH THOSE
COMMENTS MY CLOTHES THAT WOULD
BE THAT WOULD BE TERRIFIC ARE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS.
I SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU I'M
SURE- SO ALL OF THE SUPPORTING
THIS TIME TODAY I WILL BE HONEST
ARE YOU HAVE SOME- TREPIDATION
ABOUT HAVING SEX OF COURSE MY
FIFTEEN YEARS OF PRACTICE AND
THE- TO MORE THAN A DECADE AGO
SO I DID NOT- ACTUALLY PRACTICE-
REMOTELY- THE IDEA PRACTICE OF
DOING IT REMOTELY- DOES GIVE ME
SOME TREPIDATION- AS AN ATTORNEY
I MEAN THERE WOULD BE ON THE
TECHNOLOGY ISSUES- IT. IS A
SEASON CHALLENGES AND SO I
GUESS- I DO HOPE YOU'LL CONSIDER
A NEW SUNSET FOR PERSONAL THE
SUPPORTING IT- TODAY- AND I ALSO
. JUSTIN IN TERMS OF. I THINK
JUDGES SHOULD HAVE SUPER BROAD
DISCRETION TO DISALLOW- TO
DISALLOW REMOTE STATION- AND I
KNOW THERE ARE A BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT STANDARDS IN HERE BUT
WHEN I JUDGE COUNTER COUNTS- BUT
I JUST TO THINK THAT JUDGES ARE
REALLY BROAD ABILITY- TO- TO
REQUIRE. SUSPICION IN PERSON I
DO LIKE HAVING THE FLEXIBILITY-
AND AUTHORIZING CONTINUE
FLEXIBILITY- BUT I COULD TO SEE-
I COULD I COULD SEE SOME
PROBLEMS ARISE IN THE LONG RUN I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN COMMENT
ON. THAT SURE- IN MY CLOTHES OR
WHATEVER YOU'D LIKE ALL RIGHT IF
YOU COULD DO IT IN YOUR CLOSE AT
ALL RIGHT. WELL I THINK- AND I
DO I DO WANNA AGREE WITH THEM.
TESTIMONY IN TERMS OF MULLIN I'M
NOT SURE YOU CAN ELIMINATE A
SUNSET ON SOMETHING THAT'S NOT
CURRENTLY IN LAW- BUT I DO
THINK- OKAY PASSING MAKING IT.
TAKING IT FROM AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER TO OUR EMERGENCY ORDER TO-
BEING APPROPRIATE TO BE USED IS
- IS THE WAY TO GO BUT I DO WANT
TO GRIEVE WITH US SENATOR WIENER
ABOUT- GIVING DISCRETION TO
JUDGES I DID PRACTICE LIKE I
PRACTICED CRIMINAL DEFENSE WORK
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND- I HAD
. MANY OF MY CLIENTS WERE
MONOLINGUAL SPANISH SPEAKING SO
WE HAD AN INTERPRETER AND WE HAD
MULTIPLE INTERPRETERS DEPENDING
ON HOW MANY- HOW MANY VICTIMS
AND HOW MANY- DEFENDANTS THERE
WERE AND THE THOUGHT OF TRYING
TO DO THAT REMOTELY JUST. CHILLS
ME TO THE BONE I WOULD WANT A
JUDGE TO SAY NO WE UP WE ALL
HAVE TO BE. PRESENT IN THE
COURTROOM IN ORDER FOR THIS TO
THIS KIND OF A CASE TO BE
APPROPRIATELY RECORDED AND
DOCUMENTED SO I WOULD LIKE THE
JUDGES TO HAVE SOME DISCRETION
SO IF YOU COULD IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS ALL OF THOSE- WE- DO
HAVE A MOTION. WE NEED A MOTION
. THERE IS A MOTION A NEW THE
MOTION IT WILL BE TO PASS- BUT
WILL TAKE YOUR GEAR IN HER
STATEMENT IN THE CONSIDER HM.
RIGHT SO IT UP. AS I GO AROUND
THE HORN HERE- I'M PROBABLY
FORGOTTEN SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
BUT AS TO THE QUESTION
CONCERNING DISCRETION JUDGES
HAVE ISCRETION THE AL MAKE IT
EVEN CLEARER IN THE BILL BUT I
BELIEVE IT IS CLEAR IN THE BILL
BUT- TO. AVOID ANY DOUBT JUDGES
HAVE DISCRETION TO BE ABLE TO
REQUIRE WITNESSES TO BE PRESENT
FOR EXAMPLE- IT IN TERMS OF. THE
VERBATIM RECORD- AS WAS
MENTIONED I THINK THERE'S BEEN
THIS IS NOT STILL A BEGINNING OF
AN EXPERIMENT WE'VE BEEN USING
REMOTE ACCESS NOW. SINCE I
BELIEVE THE BEGINNING OF TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY ONE- THE
BILL IS IN LAW WE'RE NOT WE'RE
NOT AMENDING A BILL IT'S NOT
BECOME EFFECTIVE THE BILL AS OF
JANUARY ONE OF TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY TWO BECAME BECAME THE
LAW. OF THE SIMPLY SONS THE BILL
IS THAT EXIST TODAY SUNSETS AND
IN MID. TWENTY TWENTY THREE
WHICH CREATES THIS. WEIRD
SITUATION WHERE IF THE BILL
SUNSETS IN MID TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. AND WE DON'T ACT THIS
YEAR AND WE ACT NEXT YEAR
THERE'S A SIX MONTH PERIOD WHERE
WE GO BACK TO WHERE WE WERE IN
TWENTY. TWENTY OR TWENTY
NINETEEN- THERE HAVE BEEN IS WAS
TESTIFIED TO OVER A MILLION
DIFFERENT- SETTINGS UP NO DOUBT
THAT THERE'S EXCEPTIONS- I'M-
SOMEBODY WHO ACTUALLY TRIED A
JURY TRIAL- MID COVE IT LASTS
ABOUT TWO AND HALF MONTHS AND WE
USE REMOTE ACCESS IN MANY
DIFFERENT FORMS. BOB IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT PERFECT BUT IT'S MUCH
BETTER THAN THE ALTERNATIVE
WHICH IS NOT HAVING A TRIAL. AND
IT IS MUCH BETTER THAN THE
ALTERNATIVE FOR THOSE WHO ARE
INDIGENT BECAUSE REMOTE ACCESS
PROVIDES FOR EXAMPLE FOR STATUS
CONFERENCES. FOR IT CERTAINLY
MINISTERIAL MATTERS THAT THEY
CAN ACCESS THE COURT WITHOUT
MISSING A DAY OF WORK THEY CAN
ACCESS THE COURT FROM SOMEWHERE
NEAR WHERE THEY LIVE GO TO LEGAL
AID OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT- AS
OPPOSED TO HAVING COME TO COURT
BUT IF THEY WANT TO COME TO
COURT. THIS DOES NOT PREVENT
THEM FROM COMING TO COURT- THE-
CHALLENGE THAT WE- IS A
CHALLENGE CONCERNING PROVIDING
COURT REPORTERS. IN COURT ROOMS.
TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO. ALL
LITIGANTS TO HAVE AN OFFICIAL
COURT REPORTER PRESENT AND ICOMPLETELY ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS
WITH SENATOR ALSO WHEN SHE SAYS
WHERE DID THAT THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS GO I DON'T KNOW WHERE
THAT THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS HAS
GONE BUT WE CERTAINLY SHOULD
FIND. OUT AND WE CERTAINLY
SHOULD AS A MATTER OF PUBLIC
POLICY DO OUR BEST TO ENSURE
THAT THERE ARE COURT REPORTERS
AVAILABLE- RIGHT NOW THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS SHORTAGE OF COURT
REPORTERS WHICH IS STYMIEING.
AND IN FACT PROVIDES BASICALLY
IT PROVIDES AN ADVANTAGE TO
THOSE LITIGANTS THAT CAN'T
AFFORD A REPORTER THEY CAN BE
OUT. THEY CAN BE QUITE
EXPENSIVE. I AGAIN ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH THE MISS CASTRO IN
HER COMMENTS. ABOUT TOM HOW WE
HAVE- WE HAVE AN DURRETT. BUT
WE'VE BEEN DOOR IN A SITUATION
WHICH SORT OF CATCH AS CATCH CAN
CONCERNING COURT REPORTERS IN
TERMS OF AN AGREEMENT THE AYE I
WASN'T PARTY TO ANY AGREEMENT AS
TO AT THE SUNSET. SO I'M I'M NOT
SURE EXACTLY HOW THAT INVOLVED.
BUT I AM AMENABLE TO
CONSIDERING- AND ADDITIONAL
SUNSET. BUT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T STYMIE THE COURTS
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
EVERYONE AND REMOTE ACCESS IS A
TREMENDOUS TREMENDOUS EXPEDITE-
AND ALSO COST SAVER AND IT DOES
NOT IMPACT THE QUALITY OF
JUSTICE SO ORIGINAL VOTE. THERE
IS A MOTION- MADAM- COUNCIL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. YES THIS
IS A SENATE BILL EIGHT FOUR
EIGHT BY SENATOR- BURKE. I WITH
THE MOTION BY CENTER HERTZBERG
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG HI I'M
BURKE HI PORGES. GORGEOUS I
CARRY IT ALL HI COMMITTEE AT ALL
I DO WRESTLE. GONZALEZ I. THREE
OKAY BACK DID I SO THE REST SO
HI GONZALEZ HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE JONES. JONES FIVE LAYERED
SHARED BY STERN STERN ALRIGHT
WAKE HOUSEKI WHITE HOUSE KEEP
FIVE WINNER WINNER I THAT'S TEN
TWO ZERO WITH ALL MEMBERS VOTING
. I WAS OUT TEN ZERO THANK YOU
WILL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN WHICH IS SB TEN THIRTY
SEVEN CENTER AMBER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SB TEN THIRTY SEVEN SIMPLY
REQUIRES INDIVIDUALS
PARTICIPATING IN DEPOSITIONS
SELECT APPEAR IN PERSON TO
COMPLY WITH LOCAL HEALTH AND
SAFETY ORDINANCES I URGE AN AYE
VOTE WITH ME- TELEPHONICALLY AT
LEAST IS- A MISSILE VIA.
SUBPOENA TO KERR FROM THE-
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
. VERY GOOD- MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR MISTER CAR. I AM ON MANAGER
MEMBERS BUT IT WILL BE THREE
GIVEN THAT OUR- EQUITY CONSUMER
DURING THE CALIFORNIA PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL OF THE
DEFENSE COUNSEL. WITH THE FACT
YOU KNOW MANY INDUSTRY THAT
SHIFTED IT FROM OUTSIDE OF THE
LEGAL PROFESSION IS NO EXCEPTION
LAST YEAR- BURKE TWENTY TWENTY
WHEN WE WORK ON AT ELEVEN FORTY
SIX THE SENATOR- BURKE FROM
ATTORNEYS EXPRESSED THAT DURING
REMOTE AT THE DEPOSITION BUT
LIKE TO APPEAR IN PERSON. EITHER
WITH THEIR CLIENT OR WITH THE
DEPONENT AND AT THE CRANBERRY
SEVEN SIMPLY REQUIRES THAT IF
ANYONE ELECT TO APPEAR IN PERSON
AT A COMPLY WITH UP TO FIFTY
ORDINANCES. THE PHONE SURE THAT
EVEN THE PLANET CAN ATTEND
SAFELY AND AVOID THE USE- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR BEING DROPPED OR A
JUDGE THE REASON FOR YOUR SECTOR. AFFECT YOUR EYES SO. PRETTY
GOOD. IS THERE ANYBODY IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED THERE IS. SEEN
MADAM CHAIR MICHAEL FOR THE TO
KIND BECAUSE THEM WE'RE IN
CONCERT DIALOGUE WITH THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS ABOUT HOW
THESE DEPOSITIONS ARE BEING
CONDUCTED AND IT HAS EVOLVED
OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS. WE
THINK THAT AT LEAST WE CAN DO
IS- CLARIFY THAT YOU HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH LOCAL SAFETY AND
HEALTH ORDINANCES WHEN A PERSON
DOES APPEAR IN PERSON BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF REMOTE
APPEARANCES GOING ON IN
DEPOSITIONS AS WE SPEAK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED.
SEEING NO ONE WILL MOVE BACK TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE. IF YOU
COULD PLEASE ASK IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU VERY GOOD-
WILL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION. IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL HERE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
SAYING NO ONE WILL MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. IS OR
ANYBODY ON THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
ACT THE TERM THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AT THE END OF THE ROW
AT THE FIVE. AT REQUIREMENTS
THANK YOU VERY GOOD FOR THE
BILL. THERE IS A MOTION TO MOVE
THE BILL BY SENATOR LAYERED ANY
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS SEEING THEN
. MADAM CHIEF COUNSEL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL- YEAH THERE'S AN
AYE VOTE THANKS- NOW MADAM CHIEF
COUNSEL. YES THIS IS S. B. TEN
THIRTY SEVEN BY SENATOR- BURKE
WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR LEHRER
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
I'M BURKE. I'M I'M BURKE AYE
BURGESS. ZERO I AM VERY AT ALL
I'D THE WRESTLE. THE RUSSELL THE
REST SO I GONZALEZ HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG I'D JONES JONES I
LAYERED LAYERED AYE STERN AYE
STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI Y. CASKEY
AYE WIENER WIENER AYE. IF YOU
HAVE NINE TWO ZERO I THINK
EVERYONE IS GOING TO BE HERE ALL
RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT ALL RIGHT
SHALL WE OPEN THE ROLE ON ALL
OTHER BILLS THAT ARE OUTSTANDING
. OKAY STARTING WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE CONSENT CALENDAR-
WITH THE MOTION WITH IT I VOTE
BY THE CHAIR TO READING I-
GONZALEZ JONES. I DON'T DIE
STERN. STERN HI THAT'S TEN TWO
ZERO EVERYONE VOTING BILLS OUT
CONSENT CALENDARS CONFIRMED.
CONSENT CALENDAR BUT NOW WE MOVE
ON TO. AND WE MOVE ON TO S. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR BY SENATOR
CORTEZ HE THAT'S S. B. ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY SENATOR CORTEZ HE
WITH- THE CHAIR VOTING I. AND
GONZALEZ. JONES JONES NO STERN
STERN HI. THAT'S EIGHT TO ALL
MEMBERS VOTING. BILL SELF. THE
NEXT MEASURE IS S. B. TEN FIFTY
FIVE BY SENATOR KAMLAGER. WITH
AN AYE VOTE BY THE CHAIR.
GONZALEZ JONES JONES NO. EIGHT
TO- MEMBERS VOTING ITSELF THE
NEXT MEASURE IS S. B. ELEVEN
FORTY NINE BY SENATOR LEYVA
THAT'S S. B. ELEVEN FORTY NINE
BY SENATOR LEAVE THAT WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I. CABALLERO
GONZALEZ HERTZBERG. JONES JONES
NO WAY CASKEY. THE VOTE IS IT'S
FIVE TWO ZERO NEEDS ONE MORE
VOTE WHY CAL SKI. WHY CASKEY I.
THAT IS SIX TWO TWO S. WE ARE
STILL. MISSING NUMBER AS FLOWS
SO OKAY THANK. TWO NEXT ITEM IS
S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO BY
SENATOR PAD WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING HI GONZALEZ. JONES JONES
NO. EIGHTY TWO OH MEMBERS VOTING
FILLS UP NEXT MEASURE SB A LET
SORRY S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR HERTZBERG SB
THIRTEEN SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG CHAIR VOTING
AYE BORGIAS. JONES JONES NO.
EIGHT TO ONE ALL MEMBERS WHO ARE
PRESENT PUTTING. THE NEXT
MEASURE IS S. B. AND LAST
MEASURE IS S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY
NINE BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI
S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI TRIP
READING AYE. KILEY IT'LL.
GONZALEZ OKAY ONE. THREE FOUR
FIVE SIX SEVEN THAT SEVENTY TWO
OUT. EVERYTHING. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WILL RECONVENE ON
APRIL NINETEENTH REST UP. WHAT.